THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE UP SH THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
IS NOW IN ORDER COULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL MAN SECRETARY.
JOHN SAWYER.
HERE LACKEY.
BARRICADE CAM.
DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE QUIRK HERE
SANTIAGO WICKS.
THANK YOU FORM IS PRESIDENT AND
I'M OFFICIALLY CALLING TO ORDER
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
WILL START WITH A SPECIAL ORDER
OF BUSINESS TO HEAR AB.
THREE NINETY TWO I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR DR WEBER FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE FORD.
I LIKE TO MAKE A FEW POINTS
ABOUT OUR PROCESS TODAY.
GIVEN A GREAT INTEREST IN THIS
BILL AND TO INSURE A ROBUST
CONVERSATION.
I'M GOING TO ALLOW ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY BEYOND OUR NORMAL FIVE
MINUTE COMMITTEE RULES.
TODAY WE WILL BE ALLOWING TEN
MINUTES TEN MINUTES FOR EACH
SIDE TO PROVIDE WITNESSES ON THE
BILL. TO FACILITATE TODAY'S
DISCUSSION I WOULD LIKE TO
CHANGE THE ORDER JUST A LITTLE
BIT.
WE'LL HAVE THE AUTHOR PRESENT
THE BILL.
AND HER WITNESSES PROVIDE
TESTIMONY.
THEN I WILL ASK THE OPPOSITION.
TO PRESENT.
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTION.
FINALLY I WOULD THEN ASK.
THAT THE PUBLIC PROVIDE THEIR
COMMENTS.
FIRST THOSE IN SUPPORT.
AND THEN THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
WILL BE OPENING UP THE
MICROPHONES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THEN.
IF YOU'RE NOT ONE OF THE
DESIGNATED WITNESSES PRESENTING
WITH THE AUTHOR OR THE
OPPOSITION.
DID YOU ARE ASKED TO STATE ONLY
YOUR NAME [inaudible]
ORGANIZATION.
AND POSITION ON THE BILL.
I WOULD NEED TO LIMIT.
EVERYONE TO THOSE COMMENTS ONLY
AS YOU CAN SEE AS YOU CAN LOOK
AROUND.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE HERE
INTERESTED IN SHARING THEIR
POSITION.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE AT LEAST
EVERYONE WILL NEED EVERYONE TO
FOLLOW THE RULES.
MY STAFF WILL BE THE POSITION ON
THE FLOOR DIRECTING MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THE MICROPHONE
WHEN THAT COMES UP.
WE HAVE TWO MICROPHONES HERE ON
THE FLOOR AS WELL AS ONE ABOVE
IN THE GALLERY.
WE WILL FIRST HAVE EVERYONE INTO
FORCE SPEAK.
AND THEN MOVED TO THE GALLERY.
ONCE WE HAVE CLEARED THE GALLERY
WILL MOVE BACK TO THE FLOOR AND
CONTINUE IN THAT FASHION.
ONCE YOU SPEAK YOU'LL BE ASKED
TO LEAVE THE ROOM TO MAKE SPACE
FOR OTHERS WHO MAY BE OUT.
IN THE HALLWAY.
WHO WANT TO SPEAK BEHIND YOU?
AS YOU CAN SEE.
WE ARE AT FULL CAPACITY.
SO WE WILL NEED TO FOLLOW THESE
RUES TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE HAS
A CHANCE TO SPEAK.
ADDITIONALLY I AM REQUESTING
THAT THERE BE NO AUDIBLE.
DEMONSTRATIONS TODAY.
IT ONLY SLOWS UP THINGS
DISTRACTS WHAT WE NEED TO HEAR
FROM OUR WITNESSES.
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM CLAPPING.
OR SNAPPING.
AND INSTEAD SIGNIFY YOUR SUPPORT
BY WAVING YOUR HANDS LIKE THIS
[inaudible]
OKAY. ONE MORE TIME.
WAVING YOUR HANDS LIKE THIS
THANK YOU.
FINALLY.
I KNOW A GREAT MANY YOU HAVE
TRAVELED A LONG DISTANCE TO BE
HERE TODAY.
PLEASE NOTE THAT.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
THAT RESTROOMS ARE LOCATED
OUTSIDE OF THIS ROOM DOWN THE
HALL TO THE LEFT.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION.
BEFORE I STARTED TO RESENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE JUST A
COUPLE.
OF COMMENTS -- I JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS.
TODAY MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON
A BILL THAT WILL BEGIN
ADDRESSING.
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY OVER THE
USE OF FORCE.
THE MENTALITY OF FIRST OF SHOOT
FIRST ASK QUESTIONS LATER NEEDS
TO STOP.
WHILE THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
PERFECTION.
AB THREE NINETY TWO IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARD
CHANGING LAW ENFORCEMENT
BEHAVIOR TOWARD PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE I
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM CAN RAISE.
QUESTIONS FOR STAKEHOLDERS THERE
ARE SOME THAT BELIEVE THIS BILL
GOES TOO FAR.
AND THEN OTHERS THEY BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH.
WHAT IS CLEAR HOWEVER AT THAT
THIS IS A CRITICAL CONVERSATION
ABOUT PROTECTING THE LIVES OF
CIVILIANS?
AND OFFICERS ALIKE.
IS SIMPLY TOO IMPORTANT TO LET
IT FAIL.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS COMMERCE
CONVERSATION IS DEEPLY PERSONAL
AND EMOTIONALLY CHARGED FOR
INDIVIDUALS ON ALL SIDES OF
DISCUSSION.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING IN MY POWER.
TO ENSURE ALL VOICES ARE HEARD.
AND RESPECTED AND RESPECTED THIS
MORNING.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE WE HAVE
COME TO A PERIOD IN TIME WHERE
PEOPLE YELL AND FIGHT WITH EACH
OTHER WHEN THEY HAVE
DISAGREEMENTS.
AND TO DATE THAT MUST STOP.
WE CANNOT MAKE PROGRESS BY
SHUTTING PEOPLE OUT WE CAN ONLY
GROW AND MOVE FORWARD BY WORKING
TOGETHER FOR BETTER.
AND SAFER SOLUTIONS FOR ALL.
WHAT GOOD IS A POLICY CHANGE
WITHOUT THE BUY IN OF THE
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT?
WHAT GOOD ARE REVISED TRAINING
STANDARDS WITHOUT TRUE COMMUNION
ENGAGEMENT AND LAW ENFORCEMENT?
TODAY IS THE FIRST STEP IN A
LONG PROCESS -- WANTED I BELIEVE
WE WILL ALL BENEFIT FROM AS WE
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
WITH THAT [inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU MAY PRESENT THAT'S WELL PUT
IT UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE -- I WANT TO BEGIN BY
FIRST THANKING THE CHEER FOR HIS
SUPPORT AND ONGOING HELP AND IN
FASHIONING THIS BILL AND
ORGANIZING TODAY'S MEETING -- I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
BECAUSE I THINK I'VE MET WITH
EACH ONE OF YOU INDIVIDUALLY --
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT OUR GOALS ARE BUT WE WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH WITH AB.
THREE NINE TWO I'M HERE TO
PRESENT YOU AB THREE NINE TO THE
CALIFORNIA ACT TO SAVE LIVES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CHANGE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL STANDARD WHEN
POLICE CAN USE DEADLY FORCE TO
MATCH BEST PRACTICES ALREADY IN
PLACE AT SOME DEPARTMENTS.
AND THAT WE KNOW WORK TO KEEP
BOTH OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC
SAFE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
OFFICERS KILLED A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
MOST OF THOSE WERE UNARMED.
OF THE FIFTEEN POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WITH THE HIGHEST PER
CAPITA RATES OF POLICE KILLINGS
IN IN THE NATION. FIVE OF THEM
ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
BAKERSFIELD STOCKTON LONG BEACH
SANTA ANA AND SAN BERNADINO.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN POLICE IN KERN
COUNTY KILLED MORE PEOPLE PER
CAPITA.
THAN ANY OF THE U. S. COUNTY.
CURRENT LAW RESULTS.
IN OFFICES KILLINGS OF BILLION
FAR MORE OFTEN THAN UNNECESSARY
LEAVING MANY FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES DEVASTATED AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC LESS SAFE.
THESE TRAGEDIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
STUDIES SHOW PLEASE KILL ON ARM
YOUNG BLACK MEN AND MORE THAN
TWENTY TIMES THE RATE THE KILL
YOUNG WHITE MAN.
THIS IS UNDERSTANDABLY CREATED A
RIFT BETWEEN POLICE AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO THE
DETRIMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE POWER OF POLICE OFFICERS TO
USE DEADLY FORCE IS PERHAPS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITY
WE CONFER ON ANY PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
AND MUST BE GUIDED BY THE GOAL
OF SAFEGUARDING HUMAN LIFE.
POLICE OFFICER SHOULD NEVER TAKE
A HUMAN LIFE WHEN THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW SANCTIONS
POLICE USE OF DEADLY FORCE EVEN
WHEN OFFICERS DO NOT FACE AN
IMMINENT THREAT TO THEIR LIFE.
OR OR BODILY SECURITY AND EVEN
OFFICES HAVE REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVES AT THEIR DISPOSAL
TO SAFELY ADDRESS A SITUATION
WITHOUT TAKING ANYONE'S LIFE.
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING LAW
GOVERNING WHAT A HOMICIDE BY AN
OFFICER IS JUSTIFIED WAS WRITTEN
IN.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THIS CODE
BEING THE SINGLE OLDEST
UNAMENDED USED BEFORE STATUTES
IN THE COUNTRY.
NOT ONLY FAILS TO INCLUDE BEST
PRACTICES BUT AUTHORIZES DEADLY
FORCE THAT VIOLATES THE US
CONSTITUTION.
PENAL CODE EIGHT THIRTY FIVE A
WHICH REGULATES POLICE USE OF
FORCE WAS ENACTED IN SEVENTEEN
FIFTIES IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN
AND IS THE SECOND OLDEST A
MINUTE USE OF FORCE STATUE IN
THE COUNTRY.
AB THREE NINE TWO IS ABOUT
PREVENTING UNNECESSARY DEATHS BY
CLARIFYING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OBLIGATIONS WHEN MAKING THE
DECISION TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
THIS BILL LIMITS THE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE BY POLICE OFFICER
TO THOSE SITUATION WHERE IT IS
NECESSARY TO PREVENT IMMINENT
AND SERIOUS BODILY INJURY OR
DEATH. TO THE OFFICER OR ANOTHER
PERSON.
THE BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
OFFICE ISSUES DE ESCALATION
TACTICS WHENEVER POSSIBLE.
THE BILL IS SQUARELY IN LINE
WITH BEST PRACTICES STANDARDS
RECOGNIZED BY ACADEMICS AND
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
AND IS MODELED AFTER POLICIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE AT
SEVERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THESE DENNIS A KNOWN TO REDUCE
SERIOUS USE OF TWO TO REDUCE
SERIOUS YOU SUPPORT WITHOUT
HAVING ANY NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
OFFICER SAFETY OR PUBLIC SAFETY.
AS A RESULT OF IT THIS BILL ALL
AGENCIES WILL REQUIRE TO UPDATE
THE POLICIES TO UNDERSTAND THESE
BEST PRACTICES AND TO ENSURE
THAT OFFICERS ARE TRAINED TO THE
STANDARDS.
SOME POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE THEY THEY
NEED TO HOLD THEMSELVES TO A
HIGHER STANDARD UP TO UPDATING
THE USE OF FORCE POLICIES TO
ADOPT BEST PRACTICES.
LIKE REQUIRING THE ESCALATION
WHEN FEASIBLE USING FORCE THAT
IS PROPORTIONAL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OBJECTIVES AND
GROUNDING THE PROP POLICIES IN
THE SAME CITY OF HUMAN LIFE.
A THREE YEAR STUDY OF SEATTLE
USE OF FORCE POLICY WHICH
INCLUDES KEY ELEMENTS OF AB
THREE NINE TO SHOW THAT IT
RESULTED IN OFFICES USING LESS
FORCE WITH NO NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
OFFICER SAFETY OR PUBLIC SAFETY.
SINCE SAN FRANCISCO IMPLEMENTED
A SIMILAR POLICY IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THEIR USES OF FORCE HAS
ALSO BROUGHT GONE DOWN
DRAMATICALLY.
BOTH OF THESE POLICIES LIKE THE
OTHER POLICIES ADOPTED ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT CONTAIN THE KEY
ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL WERE
DEVELOPED UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF
THE OBAMACARE A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
IN ADDITION THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S RECOMMENDED
CHANGES TO SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT'S USE OF FORCE TRACKS
CLOSELY WITH AB. THREE NINE TWO
FOR EXAMPLE THE AG RECOMMENDED
THAT SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT QUOTE REQUIRE THAT
OFFICES EXHAUST ALL REASONABLY
AVAILABLE ALTERNATIVES BEFORE
USING DEADLY FORCE.
MUCH LIKE WHAT IS REQUIRED UNDER
AB.
THREE NINE TWO IT IS OBVIOUS TO
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT OUR CURRENT
STANDARD FOR USING FORCE AND
SPECIFICALLY DEADLY FORCE.
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE THE SANCTITY
OF HUMAN LIFE OR PROTECT
PEOPLE'S FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
RIGHTS.
AB THREE NINE TWO IS A NECESSARY
STEP TO AFFIRM THE SANCTITY OF
HUMAN LIFE AND PROTECTING HUMAN
LIFE.
BY NEARLY A CENTURY FOR NEARLY A
CENTURY AND A HALF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE WITNESSED THE JUSTIFICATION
OF PLEASE HOMICIDES DUE TO A
STANDARD THAT ALLOWS THE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE.
EVEN IF THERE ARE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES.
FAR TOO MANY DAYS HAVE GONE BY
WITH FAR TOO MANY DEATHS BECAUSE
OF THE INACTION OF THOSE WHO
HAVE THE POWER TO ENACT CHANGE.
THE NEED FOR REFORM IS CLEAR AND
LONG OVERDUE.
AND IT'S TIME TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
THE SAME TO YOU OF HUMAN LIFE IS
POLICING HIGHEST PRIORITY IT IS
TIME FOR US TO ENACT A STATE
POLICY THAT WILL SAVE LIVES.
HERE TO TESTIFY OF ON THIS BILL
AFTER MY CO AUTHOR SPEAKS WILL
BE THE RETIRED DEPUTY CHIEF OF
IRVINE POLICE CHIEF JEFF NOBLE.
THE CLICK SKI OUR HAMILTON WHO
WAS A COUSIN OF DANTE OF VAPOR.
OF THE RETIRED TO IT LAPD OF
CHIEF.
AND THEIR LIVES MEDINA WHO IS
THE MOTHER OF CHRISTIAN --
ESCOVEDO WHO WAS KILLED IN BY
LAPD AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN MISTER
CARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
PROBABLY COULD PRESENT EIGHTY
THREE NINETY WITH DOCTOR WEBER
AS YOU MENTIONED WITH UPDATE OUR
HUNDRED YEAR OLD LAW.
RELATED DEADLY FORCE.
AND FOCUS ON MAKING SURE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE FOR THE
TIME FOR CHANGE IS NOW.
THE REALITY IS THAT 99% OF THE
TIME LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS DO
NOT CROSS THE LINE WITH
UNNECESSARY DEADLY FORCE.
BUT WHEN THE 1% HAPPENS THERE
NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE CURRENT STANDARD IS OUTDATED
DOESN'T PROTECT AGAINST
UNNECESSARY LOSS OF LIFE AND
DOES NOT HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT DE
ESCALATE INCIDENTS.
THESE TRAGEDIES ARE HAPPENING
HAPPENING FAR TOO OFTEN.
WE ALL HEARD ABOUT THE TRAGIC
DEATH OF STUFF ON CLARK IN MY
HOME TOWN HERE. TEN MILES DOWN
THE ROAD.
WHEN A YOUNG MAN WHO SHOT AND
KILLED BY SACRAMENTO POLICE
OFFICERS WHO MISTER MISTOOK HIS
CELLPHONE FOR A GUN?
HOWEVER THE FATAL SHOOTING TEN
MILES DOWN THE ROAD OF MICHAEL
MCINTYRE AND HIGHWAY FIFTY SHOWS
THE NEED FOR CHANGE.
AFTER THE SHOOTING OUR FORMER
POLICE CHIEF RICK BRAZIL WHO IS
A SACRAMENTO INSPECTOR GENERAL
CONCLUDED THAT THE NUMBER OF
ROUNDS FIRED AT MCINTYRE WERE
EXCESSIVE.
UNNECESSARY AND PUT THE
COMMUNITY AT RISK AND ARE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES ON THE GROUND
I SLAIN CONTAIN MCINTYRE WITHOUT
FIRING ADDITIONAL SHOTS.
BRAZIL CONCLUDED THAT THERE ARE
OPTIONS TO AVOID DEADLY FORCE.
OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY CHOSE NOT
TO FILE CHARGES SHE SAID SHE DID
IT BY THE BOOK.
THIS SHOWS NEED TO RE EVALUATE
THE BOOK.
DOWN LA IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AN LA
POLICE OFFICER SHOT AND KILLED
AN UNARMED HOMELESS MAN BRANDON
GLENN.
GLENN WAS ON HIS STOMACH PUSHING
HIMSELF UP AN OFFICER STEP BACK
AND SHOT HIM TWICE IN THE BACK
KILLING HIM.
AFTER THE SHOOTING THE LA POLICE
DEPARTMENT FILED THERE IN THAT
STARTED INVESTIGATION AND THE
POLICE CHIEF MISTER BACK IN A
RARE INSTANCE SAID THAT THE
OFFICER.
NEEDS TO BE PROSECUTED HE SAID
IN RARE OCCASIONS WHERE SHOOTING
IS NOT JUSTIFIED NOT LEGAL THE
OFFICER SHOULD BE PROSECUTED.
THE LA DISTRICT ATTORNEY JACKIE
LACEY DECIDE NOT TO FILE CHARGES
SAID THERE WAS NOT A REASONABLE
DOUBT EVEN THOUGH AND THE
OFFICER ACTED WITHIN THE LAW.
AND I GUESS THIS LEADS TO THE
QUESTION IF THE POLICE CHIEF BUT
LET'S NATION'S SECOND LARGEST
CITY SHOWS THAT AN OFFICER ACTED
INAPPROPRIATELY BROKE THE LAW
SHOULD BE FIRED AND PROSECUTED
DA SAYS NOPE IT'S ALL GOOD WE
SHOULD RE EVALUATE THE CURRENT
SYSTEM.
EVEN THOUGH THERE WEREN'T FILES
CHARGED IN THE GLENN CASES CITY
OF LA PAID FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE FAMILY.
THAT'S ONE THING WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT IN YOUR CITY MISTER CHAIR
IN THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS THE
CITY OF LA HAD TO BORROW ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FROM
WALL STREET TO PAY OUT.
WRONGFUL DEATH SETTLEMENTS THESE
ARE MONIES THAT COULD GO TO
OTHER USES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO RIGHT NOW
IS NEGOTIATING A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR.
WRONGFUL DEATH SUIT IN THE CLERK.
IN THE CLERK INCIDENT AGAIN
MONEY THAT COULD GO TO OTHER
PURPOSES.
LASTLY THAT THE OPPOSITION
STATES AT THIS BILL WOULD
UNDERMINE POLICING AND OFFICERS
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO THEIR JOB
WHEN WHEN I DO THEIR JOB.
BUT AS DOCTOR WEB STATED THIS
JUST ISN'T TRUE THE POLICY IS
BASED UPON BEST PRACTICES IN THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE STANDARDS ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE IN MAJOR WEST
COAST CITIES SEATTLE AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE SEEN
FEWER OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFER WE BROUGHT
BACK PUBLIC TRUST.
IN CONCLUSION CHANGE IS HARD.
BUT WE KNOW THERE'S A BETTER WAY
WITH US TODAY IS THAT BETTER WAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
SO THE FOUR WITNESSES.
YOU HAVE A TEN MINUTE.
ALTOGETHER HI YOU BREAK IT UP
IT'S UP TO YOU -- IF I STOP YOU
IS NOT.
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW ANY.
MALICE TOWARDS YOU OR ANYTHING
OR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BECAUSE OF
WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS FAIR AS WE
CAN TO BOTH SIDES.
AND JUST QUICKLY.
PEOPLE UP HERE TO THIS WE CAN
SEE YOU AND WE INFILL.
THAT'S THIS IS A GOOD THING.
AND YOU'VE BEEN VERY GOOD SO
WHOEVER WANTS TO BEGIN FIRST.
GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JEFF NOBLE AND IS A FORMER
DEPUTY CHIEF OF POLICE I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO I SPENT TWENTY
NINE YEARS AS A POLICE OFFICER
IN CALIFORNIA RETIRING AS THE
DEPUTY CHIEF OF POLICE OF THE
IRVINE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE I HAVE
SERVED AS AN EXPERT WITNESS IN
USE OF FORCE CASES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
INCLUDING CASES THAT INVOLVE THE
DEATHS OF TO MERE RICIN
PHILANDER CASTEEL.
BASED ON THAT EXPERIENCE I AM
CONFIDENT THAT AB THREE NINETY
TWO IS A REASONABLE STEP TOWARD
REDUCING SHOOTINGS BY POLICE
OFFICERS IMPROVING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND BEGINNING THE
PROCESS.
OF REBUILDING TRUST BETWEEN THE
POLICE AND THE COMMUNITIES THEY
ARE MEANT TO SERVE.
AB THREE NINETY TWO CHANGES THE
LAWS GOVERNING POLICE USE OF
FORCE IN CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT OFFICERS CAN'T USE
DEADLY FORCE IF A REASONABLE
OFFICER WOULD THINK THAT THERE
ARE CURRENT LIVES AVAILABLE.
THAT'S NOT FAR FROM THE
STANDARDS QUIRK SUPPLY NOW BUT
BY REQUIRING ALTERNATIVES ONLY
WHEN REASONABLE.
THE BILL REQUIRES OFFICERS TO
USE LESS LETHAL WEAPONS AND
PRACTICE DE ESCALATION IN THOSE
EIGHT SITUATIONS WHERE IT'S SAFE
TO DO SO.
IN DOING THAT THE BILL IS A
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENT ON
EXISTING LAW.
THE PROPOSED CHANGE IS WRONG LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS OUT IN
OPPOSITION.
AND IN THIS REGARD FOR THE VERY
REAL NEED FOR CHANGE.
BY ARGUING THAT THIS WILL RESULT
IN INCREASED DANGER FOR OFFICERS.
I BELIEVE THEY ARE WRONG.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THAT OFFICERS
HAVE A TOUGH JOB.
A JOB THAT REQUIRES MAKING
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT DECISIONS
OFTEN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
WITHOUT TRYING TO REVIEW A
MANUAL OR CONSULT THE SUPERVISOR.
EIGHTY THREE NINETY TWO IS AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO ADDRESS THOSE
CHALLENGES.
UNDER THE BILL OFFICERS ACTIONS
ARE EVALUATED THROUGH THE LENS
OF AN OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE
POLICE OFFICER BASED ON THE
TOTALITY OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
KNOWN TO THE OFFICER AT THE TIME.
THIS SAME APPROACH TO EVALUATING
POLICE USE OF FORCE AS COURTS IN
DEPARTMENTS CURRENTLY USE UNDER
THE GROUND STANDARD.
NO REASON LOSS OR THINKS IN
OFFICER CONFRONTING AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER HAS TO START NEGOTIATING
A TRY TASER FURS.
WHEN OFFICERS CONFRONTED WITH
pIMMEDIATE LIFE THREATENING
DANGER THE NECESSITY STANDARD
WILL STILL ALLOW OFFICERS TO USE
DEADLY FORCE TO KEEP THEMSELVES
SAFE OR TO PROTECT OTHERS?
IN THE END AB THREE NINETY TWO
STANDS FOR SIMPLE RULE.
POLICE SHOULD USE DEADLY FORCE
WHEN IT IS SAFE AND REASONABLE
TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION IN SOME
OTHER WAY.
THIS IS NOT A RADICAL CHANGE.
INDY AB THREE NINETY TWO
PROVIDES A STANDARD IS
CONSISTENT WITH MUCH OF CURRENT
LAW AND POLICY THAT MOST OF THE
PUBLIC AGREES WITH AND MANY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
ASSUME IS ALREADY IN PLACE.
BY WRITING THE STANDARDS INTO
LAW EIGHTY THREE NINETY TWO
INSURERS THE DEPARTMENT'S
STATEWIDE WILL CHANGE THEIR
POLICIES AND TRAIN TO CONFORM TO
STAY LONG.
AND BY SETTING STATEWIDE
STANDARDS AB THREE NINETY TWO
INSURERS OFFICERS CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY USE DEADLY
FORCE UNNECESSARILY. TO
ADMINISTRATIVE DISCIPLINE CIVIL
LIABILITY OR CRIMINAL CHARGES.
AB THREE NINETY ONE COURAGE
OFFICERS TO YOU SOUND TACTICS
AND DISCOURAGE THEM FROM GETTING
INTO AVOIDABLE FIGHTS.
BOTH CHANGES WILL MAKE OFFICERS
CHANGE OFFICER SAFER THAT IS WHY
I SUPPORT AB [inaudible]
THREE NINETY TWO NEXT.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS YEAR HAMILTON.
AND I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE MY
FAMILY HAS GONE TO SOMETHING NO
FAMILY SHOULD EVER HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ACTUALLY TO
PASS AB THREE NINETY TWO OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE ON APRIL FIFTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MY COUSIN
DIED IN A SEA OF POLICE BULLETS
IN A WALMART PARKING LOT IN
BARSTOW. FOR OFFICES FAR THIRTY
SHOTS AT BEYOND SAY.
THAT THE CAR HE WAS DRIVING AND
TASED HIM AND LEAVING HIM TO
CHOKE ON HIS OWN BLOOD. ONE OF
THE OFFICERS WHO SHOT YA SE WAS
PREVIOUSLY CHARGED WITH A HATE
CRIME.
AND RACIAL SLURS AN ATTACK ON A
MAN IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN SO
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT OUR
POLICING CALIFORNIAN AMERICA.
THAT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ARE
NOT SAFE FROM STATE SANCTIONED
VIOLENCE EVERY YEAR COUNTLESS
FAMILIES LIKE MINE Là SUFFER
FROM THE PAIN OF LOSING SOMEONE
AS AMAZING AND KIND OF THE ON
TODAY.
BEYONCE HERE BUT SHE LIKE WE
CALL HIM AFFECTIONATELY WAS A
FAMILY MAN WHO WOULD GIVE HIS
LAST TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY ELSE
WAS OKAY.
HE WAS SELFLESS ANY LOVE JUST
THREE BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS
MORNING ANYTHING IN A ROW AND
THEY LOVED HIM.
BUT SHE SMILE WAS CONTAGIOUS HE
WAS ALWAYS SMILING AND YOU KNOW
WE LOVE SINGING AS RB SONGS AT
THE TOP OF HIS LUNGS.
HE LOVES PLAYING WITH HIS FAMILY
FRIENDS BASKETBALL FOOTBALL JUST
LIKE ANY OTHER.
TWENTY SIX ZERO EVERY MEMORY I
HAVE THEM IS FUN.
THERE WAS NEVER A DULL MOMENT
WITH BUT SHE HE WAS TAKEN FROM
US BECAUSE THE POLICE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARE ALLOWED TO
SHOOT PEOPLE EVEN WHEN THEY HAVE
ALTERNATIVES TO DEADLY FORCE.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO PASS AB THREE NINETY TWO I
WANT TO FEEL PROTECTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOT A FOR MY LIFE
BECAUSE THEY MY MISTAKE MY FALL
FOR A GUN.
OR MAY SHOULDN'T TO A VEHICLE
THAT I MEAN BECAUSE OF THE COLOR
OF MY SKIN.
WE CAN SAVE LIVES BY MAKING SURE
POLICE ARE TRYING TO USE THE
ESCALATION TACTICS BEFORE JUST
SHOOTING TAKING SOMEONE'S LIFE.
POLICE OFFICERS SHOULD ALWAYS DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
PRESERVE LIFE THEY NEED TO START
EMPATHIZING WITH THE PEOPLE.
OFFICER SHOULD ALSO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY UNJUSTLY
KILL SOMEBODY JUST LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE BEFORE THE ONTO WAS KILLED
I WASN'T INTERESTED IN POLITICS
OR ACTIVISM.
I KNOW THAT POLICING BARS TO
WERE RACES AND THAT THEY HARASS
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF
OUR SKIN.
BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL THE ENTREE
WAS MURDER THAT I REALIZED THAT
MY VOICE HAD TO BE KNOWN.
AND REMEMBER IN MEMORY OF THE ON
TO ASK THAT YOU PLEASE PASS AB
THREE NINE TO HELP US HONOR HIM
AND THE COUNTLESS PEOPLE.
A CALLOUS OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT
ARE KILLED BY POLICE BY TAKING.
THIS IMPORTANT STEP TO MAKE SURE
FEWER FAMILIES HAVE TO ENDURE
THIS PAIN THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOUR AND A HALF MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH MEDRANO ESCOVEDO AND
MY SON CHRISTIAN ANTHONY WAS
KILLED BY LAPD OFFICER AND
ORDERED CALCUTTA PUBLIC BACK
DIVISION ON JANUARY FOURTEENTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MY SON CHRISTIAN
WAS A POLITE RESPECTFUL
COMPASSIONATE CARING YOUNG MAN.
I LAST SAW HIM FOR DINNER THE
NIGHT BEFORE HE WAS KILLED
BEFORE HE LEFT HE TOLD ME HE WAS
GOING TO A FRIEND'S HOUSE AND
SAID GOOD NIGHT AND HE LOVED ME.
LITTLE DID I KNOW I WOULD NEVER
HEAR THOSE WORDS EVER AGAIN.
ON THE EARLY MORNING HOURS OF
JANUARY FOURTEENTH AFTER
NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS TO GET A RIDE
HE AND A FRIEND DECIDED TO WALK
HOME BECAUSE HE WANTED TO GET TO
IS BAD THEY WALKED HIMSELF THE
MONEY TO OUR NEIGHBORHOOD OF
MONTICELLO HIGH IT'S A LOS
ANGELES.
WHICH IS.
WHICH WAS APPROXIMATELY FOUR AND
A HALF HOURS LONG.
THEY GOT TO THE CORNER BILLION
AND I'M AT THIS A WERE EXHAUSTED
HE LAID TO REST IN THE DRIVEWAY
BEHIND FOR PARKED VEHICLES OF
THAT DRIVEWAY AND ENDED UP
FALLING ASLEEP.
A CALL WAS MADE TO LAPD
HOLLENBECK DIVISION OF TWO MEN
SLEEPING BEHIND A VEHICLE.
THE DISPATCHER PUT UP THE CALL
EIGHTY W. ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON SUSPECTS AT NO TIME WERE
THEY COMMITTED A CRIME THEY WERE
SLEEPING.
THEY WERE JUST LAME AND RESTING
ON THE PAVEMENT IN A DRIVEWAY.
AUTHORED AGONIST PARTNER
RESPONDED TO THE CALL ALTHOUGH
OFFICER ATTACK AMID CLAIMS TO
HAVE WORKED WITH THE SAME
PARTNER ENORMOUS OCCASION AND
HAVE THE DISCUSS TACTICS
DEPLOYMENT DE ESCALATION
PURPOSES IN THE PAST WITH THE
SAME PARTNER.
THEY FAILED TO FOLLOW POLICIES
IN REGARDS TO ANY OF THE ABOVE.
MENTIONED TACTICS.
IF THEY ALSO THOUGHT THAT MY
SLEEPING SON WAS A THREAD WHY
DID HE USE A TASER CALL FOR BACK
UP OR TAKE COVER BEHIND THE FOUR
VEHICLES THAT WERE PARKED IN THE
DRIVEWAY.
HE DIDN'T EVEN IDENTIFIED
HIMSELF AS A POLICE OFFICER NOR
GIVE VERBAL COMMANDS THEN AFTER
HE KILLED MY SON HE TRY TO
JUSTIFY IT POLICE KNOW THE MAGIC
WORDS I FEAR FOR MY LIFE.
JUST BY SAYING THAT THEY FEAR.
JUST BY SAYING THAT THEY WERE IN
FEAR THEY GET AWAY WITH KILLING
PEOPLE MY SON'S LIFE WAS CUT
SHORT.
WHEN ALSO TACKLE CLAIMS TO HAVE
BEEN IMPAIR FOR HIS SAFETY AND
SHOT AND KILLED MY SON CHRISTIAN?
HE DID NOT CALL FOR BACK UP
BECAUSE HE STATED IT WAS A BUSY
NIGHT AND CLOSE TO THE IN THE
SHIP HE STATED HE DID NOT CALL
FOR AIR SHOULD BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T THINK THEY WOULD RESPOND
AT THE TIME OF DAY.
HE DID NOT TAKE COVER BEHIND THE
FOR PARKED VEHICLES HE CLAIMED
THAT HE WAS IN FEAR FOR HIS
SAFETY GET FAILED TO USE HIS
RESOURCES.
HE COULD HAVE USED A TASER
CALLED FOR BACKUP USE RUBBER
BULLETS OR LESS LETHAL WEAPON
THIS BILL IS BASICALLY
EVERYTHING THAT THEY DIDN'T DO
AND CHRISTIANS CASE HAD THIS
BEEN.
BILL BEEN LONG CHRISTIAN WOULD
STILL BE ALIVE POLICE SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS IF THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY USE OTHER MEANS THEY
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO USE IT.
THIS BILL CAN SAVE MOTHERS FROM
GRIEVING THE LOSS OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
WHICH IS WHAT I'M EXPERIENCING
RIGHT NOW.
REGGIE TO PASS ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY TWO AND MAKE IT
LONG IT WOULD SAVE COUNTLESS
LIVES.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES.
MY NAME IS CHERYL DORSEY I'M
RETIRED LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT SERGEANT AS A RETIRED
VETERAN SERGEANT LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT HAVING SPENT
TWENTY YEARS IN PATROL.
MY LIVED EXPERIENCES FORM THE
BASIS UP SUPPORTING LEGISLATION
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY SAVE
LIVES EVIDENCE OF UNNECESSARY
USE OF DEADLY FORCE IN THE
RELUCTANCE BY SOME OFFICERS TO
DE ESCALATE CONTENTIOUS.
ENCOUNTERS EXIST JUST BECAUSE AN
ALLEGED SUSPECT ATTEMPTS TO
EVADE ARREST BY JUMPING FENCES
AND HIDING IN A BACKYARD HE
SHOULD NOT BE EXECUTED ONE COUNT.
WHEN CORNERED STEFAN CLARK WAS
CHASED INTO A CONTAINED AREA
OFFICERS WERE AIDED BY THE
ELIMINATION OF AN AIR UNIT?
RATHER THAN SEE COVER AND
CONCEALMENT AND ESTABLISH A
PERIMETER THE OFFICER FIRED
TWENTY ROUNDS IS DEFINED THEY
WERE CONSUMED BY CONTAGIOUS
GUNFIRE THEIR OWN THE OFFICERS
CLAIMED THEY THOUGHT.
STEFAN HAD SHOT THEM HE HADN'T
THE OFFICERS CLAIMED THEY
THOUGHT STEPAN HAD A GUN HE
DIDN'T BECAUSE GREAT DIFFERENCES
GIVEN TO AN OFFICER'S VERSION OF
THE DANCE.
THE PROSECUTORS PROSECUTORS
CITED WITH THE OFFICERS EVEN
THOUGH NEITHER PAUSED IN THE
MIDST OF THOSE TWENTY ROUNDS TO
REASSESS WHETHER OR NOT A THREAT
EXISTED WHILE OFFICERS WERE
CALLED TO MAKE SPLIT SECOND LIVE
PERSON DEATH DECISIONS OFFICERS
ARE ALSO EXPECTED. TO RELY ON
THEIR TRAINING AND COMMONSENSE
POOR TACTICS LEAD TO UNNECESSARY
SHOOTINGS OFFICERS ARE TRAINED
IN I'D TARGET IDENTIFICATION AT
HER PRACTICE SHOOT DON'T SHOOT
SCENARIOS AND SHOULD KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE SHOOTING AND WHY.
ABSENT IMMEDIATE DEFENSE OF LIFE
OR SOME OTHER EXIGENCY ARKHAM
STANCE DE ESCALATION SHOULD
ALWAYS BE A CONSIDERATION FOR
THOSE WHO SAY THAT HAVING
OFFICERS GO THROUGH A MENTAL
CHECKLIST PRIOR. TO FIRING THEIR
WEAPONS WOULD ENDANGER THEIR
LIVES I SAY THEY ARE BEING
INTELLECTUALLY DISHONEST FOR
THOSE WHO SAY THAT AB THREE
NINETY TWO WILL NEGATIVELY
INFLUENCE POTENTIAL RECRUITS.
I SAY THAT NOT EVERYONE WHO
WANTS TO BE THE POLICE SHOULD BE
THE POLICE.
BEING A POLICE OFFICER REQUIRES
GOOD JUDGMENT MENTAL READINESS
IN THE ABILITY TO ACT IN CONCERT
WITH ONCE TRAINING MUCH LIKE A
SURGEON A PILOT OR SHELF.
PSYCHOLOGICAL RE EVALUATIONS
POLICE OFFICER LACKS THE SLACK
THE SKILL SET OR TO PERMIT TO
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY
DISTRESSFUL HIGH RISK ACTIVITIES
WHICH IS INHERENT TO POLICE WORK
THIS IS NOT THE JOB FOR YOU
POLICE CHIEFS IN UNION TO
MINIMIZE TO MITIGATE BAD
BEHAVIOR.
DO A DISSERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY
AB THREE NINETY TWO WILL NOT
PREVENT A POLICE OFFICER FOR
SHOOTING SOMEONE WITHOUT JUST
CAUSE BUT IT MAY GIVE AN OFFICER
POTS AND FOR THAT REASON I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
SO NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION AND DOCTOR WEBER
MISTER.
MR MCCARTY WE MAYBE OR THE STOCK
TO WORK -- MAYBE CALL YOU BACK
FOR QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE SO.
SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
SUGGESTION TO THE PEOPLE WHO
WANTED TO STAND.
PLEASE LOOK BEHIND YOU COULD OR
SOMETHING BUT IT MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO STAND UP.
THAT YOU MAY BE BLOCKING HIM
FROM SEEING.
THE THE WITNESSES SO
[inaudible]
I WOULD.
URGING NOT TO STAND BECAUSE YOU
YOU YOU NEVER KNOW.
A WITNESS HERE MAY CONVINCE
SOMEBODY TO MAKE ANY OPPOSITION.
THAT CAN'T SEE YOUR CAME HERE
FROM THE WITNESSES AND SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE SO SOME COURTESY
THE PEOPLE BEHIND YOU SO THEY
CAN ALSO SEE -- AND HERE WHAT'S
GOING ON
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
TO BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SHANE
LEVINE AND I REPRESENT THE
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE
CALIFORNIA LODGE.
I WANT TO BEGIN MY FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGING THE PAIN IN A
MOTION THIS ISSUE HAS COST BEING
IN AN US VERSUS THEM SITUATION
IS NOT IDEAL FOR ANY OF US.
LOSS OF LIFE NO MATTER WHAT SIDE
OF THIS DEBATE YOU ARE ON IS
PAINFUL AND LIFE ALTERING. ONE
FORSMAN IS OFTEN THRUST IN THE
LIFE AND DEATH SITUATIONS NOT BY
CHOICE BUT BY OATH.
UNFORTUNATELY AB THREE NINETY
TWO WOULD CREATE AN UNTENABLE
SITUATION FOR OUR OFFICERS WHEN
CONFRONTING THE SITUATIONS IN
THE FUTURE.
AB THREE NINETY TWO SETS OUT TO
CREATE A NECESSARY STANDARD
BEFORE AN OFFICER CAN USE DEADLY
FORCE AS DEFINED NECESSARY MEANS
THERE WAS NO REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE. TO DEADLY FORCE THE
PROBLEM IS THE STANDARD WOULD BE
APPLIED IN HINDSIGHT WHEN
JUDGING AN OFFICER'S ACTIONS IN
THOSE SPLIT SECOND.
DECISION MAKING PROCESS AB THREE
NINETY TWO IS NOT A NECESSARY
STANDARD AB THREE NINETY TWO IS
AN IMPOSSIBLE STANDARD.
OFFICERS ARE OFTEN FORCED TO
MAKE SPLIT SECOND JUDGMENTS IN
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE TENSE
UNCERTAIN AND RAPIDLY EVOLVING.
AB THREE NINETY TWO WOULD
REQUIRE SUPER HUMAN DECISION
MAKING THAT IS SIMPLY NOT
POSSIBLE.
STATISTICALLY MOST POLICE
SHOOTINGS USUALLY ARISE OUT OF
OFFICERS RESPONDING TO
UNEVENTFUL SITUATIONS AS
HANDLING BURGLARIES ARE
DISTURBANCES.
INCIDENTS FROM START TO FINISH
ARE VERY TIME COMPRESSED WITH
THE LARGEST NUMBER OCCURRING
UNDER THREE SECONDS.
OFFICERS CANNOT BE EXPECTED TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES IN TWO TO
THREE SECONDS WHEN CONFRONTING A
LIFE OR DEATH SITUATION.
IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW NOT
ONLY WILL IT NOT CHANGE OUTCOMES
IN IN DANGER LAW ENFORCEMENT.
EXPERTS HAVE SAID IT WILL LEAD
TO LESS PROACTIVE POLICING
FURTHER EXACERBATE RECRUITING
AND RETENTION ISSUES AND LEAD TO
LESS QUALIFIED TRAINEES AT THE
ACADEMY.
OFFICERS WILL NOT WANT TO DO
THIS JOB KNOWING THAT WHEN THEY
GET CALLED INTO A SITUATION TO
HAVE TO MAKE A LIFE OR DEATH
DECISION.
THEY WILL BE PROSECUTED CIVIL
ACTION TAKEN AGAINST HER
DEPARTMENT AND THEIR ENTIRE
CAREER SAVAGE BY THE PRESS THEY
WILL SIMPLY WALK AWAY.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
TODAY.
AND I WOULD ASK DOCTOR WEBER
RESPECTFULLY TO COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AND TRY TO REACH A
COMPROMISE.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NOTEBOOK THANK YOU.
AND CAN YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES
YOU HAVE. TEN MINUTES.
ONCE I FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK
THIS AGAIN.
MY NAME IS JULIE ROBERTSON AND
I'M A DEPUTY SHERIFF FOR THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
ON SEPTEMBER SEVENTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MY PARTNER
MARK SAUCE YOU.
AND I WERE DISPATCHED TO A
CUSTOMER DISTURBANCE AT A LOCAL
AUTO STORE.
WHERE STORE CLERK AND I WERE
SHOT MARK WAS SHOT AND KILLED?
THERE IS NO INDICATION PRIOR TO
OUR ARRIVAL AND DURING OUR BRIEF
CONTACT FOR THE SUBJECT INVOLVED
THAT HE WAS ARMED.
WITHIN TEN SECONDS OF ARRIVING
AT THE STORE THE SUBJECT BEGAN
SHOOTING AT US.
MARK REACTED BY ATTEMPTING TO
FIND COVER.
AS HE WAS FINDING COVER THE
GUNMEN CONTINUED TO FIRE AT MARK
WHILE CHASING HIM RESULTING IN
MARK'S ALMOST IMMEDIATE DEATH.
AFTER MARK HAD FALLEN THE GUNMAN
TURNED TOWARD ME AND BEGAN
FIRING.
A VOLLEY OF GUNFIRE BETWEEN ME
AND THE GUNMEN FOLLOWED.
HE LEFT THE STORE AND FLANK ME
FROM A DIFFERENT SIDE ENTRANCE
DOOR.
HE PROCEEDED TO SHOOT ME AGAIN
TO FINISH WHAT HE STARTED.
AT ONE POINT DURING THE
FIREFIGHT THE GUNMEN BEGAN
SHOOTING WITH ONLY IS BACK
EXPOSED TO BE.
I RECALL THAT MOMENT THINKING
THAT IF I WERE TO SHOOT HIM IN
THE BACK.
I WOULD BE THE NEXT OFFICER IN
THE NEWS BEING SCRUTINIZED FOR
MY ACTIONS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT HE JUST
MURDERED MY PARTNER SHOT ONE
STORE CLERKS AND ALSO SHOT ME.
I WAS FIGHTING FOR MY LIFE AND
FIGHTING TO PROTECT COMPLETE
STRANGERS AS I CHOSE TO STAND
BETWEEN THE GUNMAN EMPLOYEES AND
PATRONS.
THE THOUGHT OF HAVING TO SECOND
GUESS MY ACTIONS IN THAT MOMENT
IS FRIGHTENING.
I STILL HAVE EVERY INTENTION TO
RETURN A PATROL AND MARKS HONOR.
BUT THIS BILL MAKES ME WONDER
SACRIFICING EVERYTHING IS WORTH
IT.
BY THE SOUNDS OF IT THE ONLY
OPTIONS GIVEN TO ME IF HANDED A
SIMILAR SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
TO DIE.
BE CRIMINALLY CHARGED FOR LIVE
WITH THE BLOOD OF INNOCENT
PEOPLE IN MY HANDS.
ON THAT DAY MY WORST NIGHTMARE
BECAME REALITY I LEFT FACING THE
FEAR FALLING ASLEEP EACH NIGHT
ONLY TO RELIVE THE ENDLESS LOOP
OF MY FRIEND MARK'S MURDER.
FEELINGS OF HELPLESSNESS
LONELINESS AND DESPAIR
CONSTANTLY FLOOD MY THOUGHTS.
KNOWING I WOULD MORE THAN LIKELY
DIE THAT DAY MY ONLY CONCERN WAS
TO DIE ALONGSIDE MARK.
I SHIELDED HIM WITH MY BODY IS
MY LAST ATTEMPT TO PROTECT HIM.
I KNOW HOW TO LIVE WITH MARKS
BLOOD ON MY HANDS FOR THE REST
OF MY LIFE.
MY ACTIONS THAT THEY WERE PURELY
REACTIONARY AND MY SURVIVAL
INSTINCTS KICKED IN.
TIME WAS ON MY SIDE AND I WAS
NOT AFFORDED THE LUXURY OF BEING
ABLE TO WEIGH MY OPTIONS BEFORE
REACTING.
HAD THIS BILL BEEN AFFECT I
WOULD HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
RETREAT TO AVOID BEING KILLED OR
IMPRISONED.
INSTEAD OF RETREATING I STOOD MY
GROUND AND FOUGHT TO PROTECT THE
LIVES OF THOSE STILL INSIDE THE
STORE.
MY ONLY INTENTION IS TO PROTECT
AND SAVE LIVES HOW IS IT THAT I
WOULD BE QUESTIONS AND JUDGED BY
THE ONES WHO LIVE SO DISTANT
FROM THE DANGERS WE INHERENTLY
FACE EACH DAY.
MARK SACRIFICE EVERYTHING I'M
WILLING TO SACRIFICE EVERYTHING
BUT THIS BILL WOULD TIE OUR
HANDS BEHIND OUR BACKS.
HOW MY ABLE TO PROTECT AND SERVE
THE COMMUNITY KNOWING THAT I
WOULD BE CRIMINALIZED IN
DEMONIZED FOR MYSELF THE
SECTIONS? TO MARK I'M SORRY
FAILED TO PROTECT YOU.
IT WAS MY RESPONSIBILITY BRING
HOME SAFELY TO YOUR FAMILY IT
WAS AN HONOR TO HAVE SERVED
ALONGSIDE YOU AND I COULDN'T
HAVE ASKED FOR A BETTER PARTNER.
I'M ONLY HERE TODAY BECAUSE YOU
SACRIFICE EVERYTHING I MISS YOU
AND I LOVE YOU BROTHER.
THANK YOU SH.
RESPECT PLEASE [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
MISTAKENLY STORM I'M A UNION
SIDE LAWYER REPRESENTING THE
RIGHTS OF PEACE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AS A MOTHER AND A LAWYER I'M
CONCERNED WITH THE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE PRESERVATION OF ALL
HUMAN LIFE.
THE PROTECTION OF PEACE OFFICER
SAFETY AND EQUAL PROTECTION
UNDER THE LAW.
IT IS NO SMALL TASK TO BALANCE
THESE DIFFERENT INTERESTS AND
THERE WERE THE OF STATEWIDE
DISCUSSION.
HOWEVER AB THREE NINETY TO HIS
PROPOSED CHANGES DO NOT EIGHT
AND STRIKING THAT BALANCE.
RATHER THEY CRIMINALIZE POLICE
USE OF FORCE.
AND INCENTIVIZE DISENGAGEMENT
THROUGH CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
THIS TIPS THE BALANCE I
NECESSARILY JEOPARDIZING PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THE PROPOSED CHANGES ARE
PREDICATED ON THE FALSE
NARRATIVE THE CURRENT LAW AND
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS.
RIGHT OFFICERS TO USE DEADLY
FORCE.
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE DEADLY
FORCE IS NOT NECESSARY.
IN REALITY THE COURTS HAVE LONG
HELD THAT OFFICERS ME ONLY USE
NECESSARY FORCE.
THE ISSUE THEN TURNS ON HOW
NECESSARY IS DEFINED.
AB THREE NINETY TWO SIX TO
REDEFINE NECESSARY.
SUCH THAT THERE IS NO REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE.
IF TRUSTS THE ANALYSIS FROM
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE STANDARD.
TO AN AFTER THE FACT SUBJECTIVE
STANDARD WITH THE BENEFIT OF
TWENTY TWENTY HINDSIGHT.
THE NECESSARY STANDARDS A
HARDENED CRUX OF THIS BILL I'M
GOING TO DRESS THOSE CONCERNS
FIRST.
AS I SAID NECESSARY HAS ALWAYS
BEEN THE STANDARD.
IN A PINE AND OBJECTIVELY
REASONABLE STANDARD THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT ENGRAM
VERSUS CONOR HELD.
THE REASONABLENESS OF A
PARTICULAR USE OF FORCE MUST BE
JUDGED FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF A
REASONABLE OFFICER ON THE SCENE.
AND IT'S CALCULUS MUST EMBODY AN
ALLOWANCE FOR THE FACT THAT
POLICE OFFICERS ARE OFTEN FORCED.
TO MAKE SPLIT SECOND DECISIONS
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF FORCE
NECESSARY IN A PARTICULAR
SITUATION.
THE PURPOSE OF AB THREE NINETY
TWO IS A RADICALLY ALTER THE
STANDARD BY WHICH THE COURT WILL
DETERMINE NECESSITY.
MY OVERRIDING THE SUPREME
COURT'S OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE
STANDARD.
THE NEW SUBJECTIVE STANDARD FOR
DETERMINIST SB WOULD BE CREATED
AND OFFICERS WOULD BE DENIED
SELF DEFENSE RIGHTS.
IF IN RETROSPECT ANY OTHER
LESSER COURSE OF ACTION WAS A
POSSIBILITY.
THIS CREATES AN IMPOSSIBLE
STANDARD AND REPRESENTS THE
EPITOME OF SECOND GUESSING.
NECESSITY WOULD BE DETERMINED
BASED ON THE CONSIDERATION OF
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS WITH THE
BENEFIT OF TRANQUILITY TIME IN
HINDSIGHT.
THE REAL WORLD SITUATIONS WHERE
DEADLY FORCE IS WERE IS USED
REQUIRE OFFICERS TO MAKE SPLIT
SECOND DECISIONS.
WITHOUT THE LUXURIES OF TIME
TRANQUILITY AND HINDSIGHT.
OUR NINTH CIRCUIT HAS ALREADY
YOU HELD EIGHTY THREE NINETY
TWOS DEFINITION OF NECESSARY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
RECOGNIZING THE REQUIRING
OFFICERS TO DETERMINE THE LEAST
INTRUSIVE TACTICS.
WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO EXERCISE
SUPER HUMAN JUDGMENT.
WHEN LIVES HANG IN THE BALANCE
OFFICERS MUST ACT WITHIN THAT
RANGE OF CONDUCT BUT AS
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE?
THIS BILL STANDARD FOR
EVALUATING THE REASONABLENESS OF
DEADLY FORCE PROVIDES NO
DEFERENCE TO RESERVE OFFICERS
OFTEN SPLIT SECOND EVALUATION OF
WEATHER LESSER FORCE.
IS AS SAFE OR AS EFFECTIVE.
NECESSITY BE REDEFINED INTO
SUBJECTIVE INQUIRY INTO WHETHER
THE OFFICER FAILED TO EMPLOY A
HYPOTHETICAL ALTERNATIVE.
THIS HINDSIGHT ANALYSIS HAS BEEN
EXPRESSLY REJECTED BY THE COURTS.
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF SELF
DEFENSE.
THIS BILL PROPOSES AN INFERIOR
RIGHT OF SELF DEFENSE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
VIOLATING EQUAL PROTECTIONS
GUARANTEES OF THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT. EIGHTY THREE NINETY
TWO EFFECTIVELY STRIPS OFFICERS
THEIR RIGHT OF SELF DEFENSE IF
THEY COULD HAVE USED ANY
REASONABLE ALTERNATIVE INCLUDING
RETREATING.
THE SANCTITY OF LIFE PRINCIPLE
APPLIES TO EVERYONE SUSPECTS
VICTIMS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
BUT THE NO REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE CENTER IS NOT
POSSIBLE.
IF FORCED IT FORCES THE ANALYSIS
OF DEADLY FORCE FROM OBJECTIVELY
REASONABLE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. TO AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL HINDSIGHT
ANALYSIS.
INVITING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO RESTORALAX FOR
STRANGERS TO BE SECOND GUESSED
AND PROSECUTED.
IF ANY HIRED EXPERT CAN CONJURE
AN ALTERNATIVE.
THEY'RE ORDINARY MEN AND WOMEN
FACE AN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES NOW BEING ASKED TO
EXERCISE DEEPER HUMAN JUDGMENT.
PLEASE VOTE NOW THANK YOU
[inaudible]
Q..
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NOW OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT WOULD ALLOW FOR US IS NOW.
AND THERE WERE GET COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC ME TOO FROM PUBLIC
[inaudible]
SO.
BACK AT CAMP.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER FOR BRINGING THIS
DISCUSSION TO ASK THANK YOU TO
BOTH SIDES. FOR PRESENTING YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY.
I THINK THAT WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM EVERYBODY IS THE VALUE OF
THE SANCTITY OF LIFE.
AND IT IS INCUMBENT UPON EACH OF
US TO LOOK AT THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT
ARE OUT ON THE STREETS EVERY DAY.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH THE
CASES THAT WERE DISCUSSED.
IS THAT THE PENDULUM HAS SWUNG
TOO FAR IN ONE DIRECTION SUCH
THAT WE AREN'T PROTECTING.
AND HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE THOSE
WHO ARE TAKING LIFE FROM OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
I DO HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT
THE TEXT OF THIS LANGUAGE SWINGS
THE PENDULUM TOO FAR IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION.
BECAUSE THE SANCTITY OF THE LIFE
OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT.
WE ASK THEM EVERY DAY TO GO OUT
AND PROTECT US AND SERVICE THEY
TAKE OATHS TO DO JUST THAT.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BILL THAT WE PASSED THROUGH
THIS BODY.
DRAWS THE CORRECT BALANCE
BETWEEN THOSE TWO CONCERNS.
AS I READ THE BILL -- I DON'T
KNOW THAT I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THE OPPOSITION IS
SAID ABOUT IT BUT I HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN SECTIONS
ONE NINETY SIX AND EIGHT THIRTY
FIVE AND HOW THAT WOULD BE
CONSTRUED BY COURT.
I'VE CONCERNS ABOUT SECTION A
FOR AND WHETHER THAT GOES TOO
FAR IN THE WRONG DIRECTION --
BUT I THINK THE CONVERSATION IS
TO CONTINUE BECAUSE CLEARLY THE
BALANCES OFF RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE
LOSING LIVES UNNECESSARILY AND
PEOPLE ARE NOT BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT DOCTOR ABROAD LIKE TO ASK
YOU -- I'D LIKE TO ENSURE YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION MOVING FORWARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THIS BILL
HITS THE FLOOR WE DO HAVE THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN THE TWO
I'M SURE YOU PROBABLY AWARE -- I
KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE NEW HERE BUT
PROBABLY WHERE THE WE SPENT THE
LAST YEAR WORKING ON REACHING OF
SOME TYPE OF COMPROMISE AND WE
WILL COMMITTED TO DOING THAT NOT
ONLY ON THIS SIDE OF THE HOUSE
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE AS WELL.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT I
MEAN WE'VE BEEN WORKING SINCE --
THE END OF LAST SESSION WHICH
WAS IN SEPTEMBER -- DILIGENTLY
AND DID NOT IMMEDIATELY
INTRODUCED THE BILL BECAUSE WE
WERE WORKING AND HELPING TO
BRING A COMPROMISE SO WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THAT -- AND AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT WE HOPE
THAT THERE'S ALSO SIMILAR
COMMITMENT ON BOTH SIDES WE KNOW
THERE HAS TO BE A COMING
TOGETHER OF TWO SITES AND WATER --
TO ROBERT SOME CONCLUSIONS
THAT'S NECESSARY -- SO WE'RE
VERY COMMITTED TO THAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO HAVING A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE.
AND THAT DOES PROVIDE A BALANCE
THIS IS NOT A A BILL IF YOU LOOK
AT IT CAREFULLY AS YOU LISTEN TO
THE OFFICERS AND THOSE WHO ARE.
SPEAKING OUT IN SUPPORT OF IT
IT'S NOT A BILL DESIGNED TO MAKE
ANYBODY'S UNSAFE.
IT'S DESIGNED TO MAKE ALL OF US
SAFE AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
IT IN OTHER AREAS AS INDICATED
THAT IT DOES DO THAT.
UNTIL WE ARE COMMITTED TO THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TRY TO REACH SOME
COMPROMISE BEFORE THIS GOES TO
THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN AS YOU KNOW I HAVE
SPENT MANY.
HOURS READING.
AND DISCUSSING THIS WITH ALSO
HAS -- I THINK THE VOTE ON THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
WE'VE HEARD TODAY FROM. THREE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE LOSS
OF LIVES.
IN THEIR OWN LIFE ON BOTH SIDES
OF THIS ISSUE AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT AND I KNOW WE'RE
ALL COMMITTED.
INCLUDING YOU DOCTOR EVER TO
MAKING SURE THAT LIVES ARE
PROTECTED SO -- I THANK YOU FOR
THAT COMMITMENT AND YOU KNOW I
AND VOTING TODAY TO MOVE THIS
CONVERSATION BOARD I LOOK FOR TO
SING A BILL THAT IS.
A LITTLE BIT CLEARER TO ME ON
THE FLOOR AND THAT -- STRIKES
THAT NECESSARY NESS PROTECTS
HUMAN LIFE ON ALL SIDES AND DOES
WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE QUIRK SHOW ON NOT NEARLY.
I'VE BEEN HERE SIX YEARS ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND I VERY MUCH AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN ALL OF HER
COMMENTS -- AND I THINK THEY
WERE VERY WELL PUT SO I WILL NOT
REPEAT THEM THAT I HAVE THE SAME
RESERVATIONS I WILL.
VOTE -- TO BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD FOR NEGOTIATION ON THE
FLOOR BUT I CANNOT VOTE FOR
DENTS CURRENT FORM.
THANK YOU I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
WHEN I'VE MY COMMENTS WAS THAT
SHE WAS NEW AND HAD NO REFERENCE
TO EXPERIENCE BY WAS THE FACT
THAT SHE WAS NOT HERE WHEN WE
WERE BRINGING THE BILL FOR WHAT
LAST YEAR.
AND THAT THE WORK THAT PUT WENT
INTO IT FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR AS
WELL AS OUR COMMITMENT AT THE
END OF LAST SESSION TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION SO THAT WAS MY
ONLY COMMENT WAS WAS THAT.
AIMED AT THE FACT THAT OF THOSE
WHO WERE HERE KNEW HOW MUCH WORK
WE DID THERE SEVERAL OF YOU WERE
NEW BUT KNOW HOW MUCH WORK WE
DEAL WITH.
NINE THREE ONE AND AND WE
CONTINUED AND MADE A COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE A CONVERSATION AT
THE END OF LAST SESSION.
MISS WICKS AND MS COMATOSE.
THANKS THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK --
THE AUTHORS DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FOURTH
AND CONTINUING.
THE CONVERSATION OVER THE YEAR
PLUS YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS --
AND FOR THE WITNESSES WHO --
HAVE TESTIFIED TODAY ON BOTH
SIDES -- I ALSO HAVE TREMENDOUS
RESPECT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS AND IF I THINK THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM ARE.
FOLKS WHO ARE.
DOING THE BEST IN THE SITUATION
THAT THEY'RE IN AND THEY ARE OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND
HUSBANDS AND WIVES THEY'RE PART
OF OUR COMMUNITY.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT -- EFFECTIVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT EFFECTIVE
PLACINGS BUILT ON TRUST.
AND IN FAR TOO MANY COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY BLACK BLACK AND
BROWN COMMITTEES THAT TRUSSES
BEEN LOST.
AND I I BELIEVE WHAT THIS
CONVERSATION IS RAISING IS.
A CONVERSATION AROUND SOME VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTHS.
SOME UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTHS THAT
WE CAN'T IGNORE THE FACT THAT
BROWN AND BLACK FOLKS BROWN AND
BLACK MEN.
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY KILLED AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY.
AND I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT.
STEP AN IMPORTANT BILL -- ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I WANTED TO ASK --
DEPUTY CHIEF NOBLE.
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HEAR
IS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TRAINING
BUT WE DON'T NEED ENFORCEABLE
STANDARDS THE ENFORCEABLE
STANDARDS OF NECESSARY FORCE IN
AB.
THREE NINETY TWO CAN YOU TALK
DIRECTLY ABOUT WHY YOU THINK
THAT CHANGE IN USE OF FORCE
POLICY THAT LANGUAGE.
IS CRITICAL FOR THIS BILL.
I'M SORRY I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT POLICE OFFICERS NEED
TRAINING IN THE MORE TRAINING
GIVE OUR POLICE OFFICERS THE
BETTER OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE FOR
SUCCESSFUL INTERVENTION
CONCLUSION OF THE THAT IS.
THE REASON WHY THERE NEEDS TO BE
A BILL LIKE THIS IS BECAUSE
THERE NEEDS TO BE CONSEQUENCES
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR THAT
VERY VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
OFFICERS WHO ABANDON THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES WHO STAND IN
FRONT OF A CAR INSTEAD AND USE
DEADLY FORCE RATHER THAN TAKING
A STEP TO THE SIDE.
WHO CREATE DANGER -- DUE TO
RECKLESS TACTICS THIS IS NOT
ABOUT SITUATIONS WHERE AN
OFFICER IS CONFRONTED WITH A
SPLIT SECOND DECISION.
IN THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE THERE
TRULY CONFRONTED WITH A SPLIT
SECOND DECISION DEFERENCE SHOULD
BE GIVEN TO THE DECISION MAKING
OF THE OFFICER.
BUT MANY SITUATIONS THE VAST
MAJORITY TO SITUATIONS I WOULD
ARGUE EVOLVED OVER TIME WHAT
TACTICS AND DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES MAY BE USED. TO TO
ATTEMPT TO LOWER.
THE THE THE RUB IS AT THE END OF
THE DAY THAT EVEN WITH DE
ESCALATION THAT'S NOT A FAIL
SAFE.
AND IF AN OFFICER STILL NEEDS TO
USE FORCE IMMEDIATELY NEEDS TO
USE FORCE.
THEY SHOULD ABSOLUTELY USE FORCE
AND WE SHOULD HAVE ROAD OFFICERS
LIKE THIS YOUNG WOMAN WHO SPOKE
TO THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE WHO IS
ABSOLUTELY WHO WROTE.
WHO WHO ANSWERED THE CALL TO
SERVE AND PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY --
AND SUFFERED THIS INCREDIBLE
TRAGEDY THIS IS WHAT WE WANT WE
WANT YOUNG HEROES LIKE THIS
YOUNG WOMAN WHO IS UP UP
TESTIFYING BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT WHAT WE DON'T WANT IS
OFFICERS WHO ABANDON THEIR
TRAINING WHO ABANDON THEIR
COMMON SENSE IN BAND THEIR THEIR
DECISION MAKING AND IT RESULTS
IN IN THE LOSS OF LIFE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT LOOK
THAT CONTEXT ON THE OTHER THING
THAT YOU HEAR ABOUT IS YOU KNOW
ASKING THAT.
AND THE IDEA OF SORT OF
REASONABLE ALTERNATIVES WOULD BE
TOO COMPLICATED.
WE'VE HEARD THAT FROM FROM
OPPOSITION THAT OFFICERS WOULD
HAVE TO MAKE -- DECISIONS AND
SPLIT SECOND -- AND THEY DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY OR ABILITY TO
KIND OF RUN THROUGH A CHECKLIST
OF OPTIONS BEFORE USING FORCE
THERE BY PUTTING THEMSELVES IN
DANGER.
CAN YOU SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THAT.
WHY ABSOLUTELY AGREE WE DON'T
GIVE OFFICERS A CHECKLIST AYE
AYE I TALK ABOUT THEM IN MY
STATEMENT IS THAT YOU KNOW THESE
ARE SITUATIONS WHERE OFFICERS
THEY CAN'T MAKE A PHONE CALL
THEY CAN'T REFER TO A MANUAL
THEY CAN'T CALL SUPERVISOR?
THEY HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS AND
THAT'S WHERE THEIR TRAINING --
COMES INTO PLAY IS NOT JUST
CLASSROOM TRAINING BUT IS
SIMULATION TRAINING -- THESE
DISCUSSIONS IS PRACTICED -- I
DON'T EXPECT PERFECT DECISIONS I
EXPECT DECISIONS TO FALL WITHIN
A REASONABLE RANGE BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO WHAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
IS THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES KNOWN TO IN THAT
INDIVIDUAL OFFICER AT THE MOMENT
THAT THEY USE THE FORCE.
NOT IT WHEN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
TWENTY TWENTY HINDSIGHT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE
OFFICER KNEW NOT WHAT WE LOOK WE
MAY LEARN LATER ON AND WITH
TWENTY TWENTY HINDSIGHT IS NOT.
A PASS FOR ALL DECISIONS THAT
POLICE OFFICERS MAKE WE
ABSOLUTELY REVIEW POLICE OFFICER
JUST IS MAKING WE REVIEW IT WITH
OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE DISCIPLINE
TRAINING WE REVIEW IN THE CIVIL
COURSE ALL THE TIME -- SO POLICE
DECISION MAKING IS REVIEWED IT
SHOULD BE REVIEW OF ALL -- AND
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO DO IT
WITHOUT LOOKING AT IN HINDSIGHT
AND SO IN YOUR OPINION THIS BILL
WILL NOT PUT OFFICERS IN HARM'S
WAY.
NO I DON'T BELIEVE SO THANK YOU.
IT'S DOCTOR WEBER IT'S MY
COMMITTEE.
TALK TO WEBER.
NO I WAS JUST WONDERING I DON'T
KNOW IF THE OTHER OFFICER SHE
ASKED HIM TO THE QUESTIONS AND
SHE HAD ANYTHING TO ADD TO IT
BUT WE CAN THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
THANK YOU SO WHAT I KNOW IS THAT
MAKING SPLIT SECOND DECISIONS OR
INHERENT TO POLICE WORK -- IF
SINCE WE'RE COMMON EVERYONE
WOULD HAVE IT AND I SAID IN MY
STATEMENT THAT NOT EVERYONE WHO
WANTS TO BE THE POLICE SOULD BE
AND SO CERTAINLY WE WANT TO HIRE
OFFICERS.
PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY WHO
CAN MAKE THOSE SPLIT SECOND
DECISIONS AND IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
ANYTHING EXTRA FOR AN OFFICER IN
A LIFE OR DEATH SITUATION MUCH
LIKE WHAT IT WOULD REQUIRE ME TO
DO IF I COMMIT A TRAFFIC STOP.
I'VE GOT TO DECIDE REALLY QUICK
WHERE I WANT TO STOP YOU WHEN
I'M GOING TO ACTIVATE MY LIGHTS
WHEN I'M GOING TO CONTACT.
MY ARE TO YOUR COMMUNICATIONS
AND LET THEM KNOW WHERE WE ARE
HOW I'M GOING TO POSITION MY
VEHICLE SO THAT I'M SAFE AS I
APPROACH YOU IN YOU IF I HAVE
YOU GET OUT ALL OF THESE THINGS
I HAVE TO DO.
FAIRLY QUICKLY MUCH LIKE THE USE
OF DEADLY FORCE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT OFFICERS ARE
USING DEADLY FORCE AS A FIRST
RESORT WHEN THEYCAN'T CATCH
SOMEONE WHEN SOMEONE IS FAILING
TO COMPLY.
AS OPPOSED TO A LAST RESORT
WHICH IS WHAT OFFICERS ARE
TAUGHT TO DO AFTER YOU'VE DONE
EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE TO YOU AND NONE OF
THAT HAS WORKED IN YOU CAN GET
TO THAT.
IN A MATTER OF SECONDS BUT
YOU'RE ONLY TO USE DEADLY FORCE
AFTER YOU'VE DONE EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT YOU'VE BEEN TRAINED
TAUGHT AND NO TO DO.
AND THEN THERE NEED TO BE SOME
REASONABLENESS WITH REGARDS TO
THE NUMBER OF ROUNDS THAT ARE
FIRED BECAUSE ON THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT WE ARE TAUGHT.
FIRED TWO ROUNDS IN RAPID
SUCCESSION RE ASSESS THE THREAT
BEFORE YOU FIRE IN THE CASE OF
STEFAN CLARK EIGHTEEN MORE.
THAN HELPFUL THANK YOU AND NEXT
MUST COME LIKE A DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR WEBER.
FOR BRINGING THIS -- VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO THE
TABLE REPEATEDLY -- YOU KNOW AS
I SEE IT THIS.
BILL KIND OF RE STATES WHAT THE
STANDARD SHOULD BE RIGHT AND I
ACTUALLY WISH WE COULD BE IN A
PLACE WHERE WE COULD BE
REPEALING.
THIS KIND.
OF BELL RATHER THAN TALKING
ABOUT GETTING IT PASSED AND
SIGNED INTO LAW.
BUT WE'RE JUST NOT THERE YET.
AND THE REASON WHY WE'RE NOT
THERE YET IS BECAUSE WE CONTINUE
TO SEE.
AND READ ABOUT SO MANY KILLINGS
THAT ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING BLACKS BROWN PEOPLE
THOSE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND
THOSE WHO ARE POOR.
AND THE TRAUMA THAT COMES FROM
SEEING THAT REPEATEDLY.
MAKES PEOPLE BEGIN TO QUESTION
THEIR OWN SAFETY.
AND THEIR OWN RIGHT TO LIFE.
AND WHEN THAT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN YOU ARE FORCED TO YOU
SHOULD BE FORCED TO HAVE.
THESE KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS.
I I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT --
THAT TAXED AM THAT I HOPE ALL
SIDES -- CAN ANSWER BUT I DO
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT -- WE NEED
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE ABSOLUTELY NEED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WE SHOULDN'T
WANT TO BE CRIMINALIZING LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE I WOULD
ACTUALLY ADD THAT -- OUR CIVIL
SOCIETY IS ACTUALLY PREDICATED.
ON HAVING LAW AND ORDER AND
HAVING POLICE OFFICERS THAT WE
CAN TRUST THAT ARE NOT GOING TO
BE INCARCERATED I THINK WHEN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS HAPPEN.
YOU ACTUALLY BEGIN TO
DISINTEGRATE THE FABRIC OF OUR
CIVIL SOCIETY.
SO TO HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
RIGHT NOW IN TWENTY NINETEEN
SUGGESTS WE ARE AT A CRITICAL
JUNCTURE.
ABOUT HOW OUR SOCIETY IS
OPERATING.
I'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF YOU ALL
TALK ABOUT CRIMINALIZING USE OF
FORCE AND SO I JUST NEEDED SOME
CLARIFICATION ON MY END ARE
THERE ACTUAL ACTUAL PENALTIES
PRESCRIBED.
IN THIS BILL IF AN OFFICER USES
DEADLY FORCE I DIDN'T READ
ANYTHING ABOUT AN OFFICER BEING
CHARGED WITH A MISDEMEANOR OR AN
OFFICER BEING CHARGED WITH A
FELONY.
SO MAYBE I'M MISSING SOMETHING
BUT ARE THERE ARE PENALTIES THAT
WOULD BE PRESCRIBED.
THANK YOU OUT OF THE RING WITH
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA THERE
NOTE -- NEW PENALTIES -- ADDED
NO NEW CRIMES TO FIND -- BY THIS
BILL THIS BILL MODIFIES -- THE
SECTION OF THE PENAL CODE ONE
NINETY SIX WHICH PROVIDES THE
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE OF
JUSTIFIABLE HOMICIDE.
BY A PEACE OFFICER -- AND MAKES
CLEAR THAT PEACEOFFICERS HAVE
AVAILABLE TO THEM THE SAME
JUSTIFICATION OF SELF DEFENSE
AVAILABLE TO ANY PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA -- WHEN THEY'RE UNDER
AN IMMINENT THREAT OF DEATH OR
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY OR ACTING
TO DEFEND ANOTHER PERSON?
AGAINST AN IMMINENT THREAT OF
DEATH OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY
AND IN ADDITION GIVES PEACE
OFFICERS -- AN ADDITIONAL
DEFENSE -- IF UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES THEY ACT TO DATE
KILL AN INDIVIDUAL -- WHO IS
FLEEING -- WHERE THEY HAVE
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THE
PERSON -- HAS COMMITTED A
VIOLENT FELONY AND WOULD POSE A
THREAT OF DEATH.
OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY TO
OTHERS -- IF NOT IMMEDIATELY
APPREHENDED EVEN IF THEY DON'T
POSE AN IMMINENT THREAT AT THE
MOMENT.
AND SO THE REALITY IS THAT
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW IF AN INCIDENT
LIKE THIS DID OCCUR IT THE
YOUNGEST WOULD STILL BE ON THE
DA'S OFFICE TO ACTUALLY
INVESTIGATE IN CHARGE.
RIGHT AND WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
A VERY STRONG COHESIVE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN D. A.'S AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT RIGHT SO.
I AM VERY I'M BEGGING IN ANSWER
TO A QUESTION MAYBE I KNOW BUT
PLEASE SHARE YES.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT IT
IS STILL UP TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ON TO INVESTIGATE TO
MAKE FACTUAL DETERMINATIONS AS
TO WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
ON BASED ON THE EVIDENCE AND TO
MAKE A DECISION AND THAT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS DISCRETION
ABOUT WHETHER TO CHARGE
[inaudible]
OR NOT.
AND THEN -- IN FACT IN THE
SECTION THAT TALKS ABOUT THE
TOTALITY OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES --
I READ THAT.
OR MAYBE IT'S MY INTERPRETATION
THAT IT STILL IS GIVING -- IT
BECAUSE IT SAYS THAT THE BASED
ON THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES KNOWN TO OUR
PROCEED BY THE OFFICER AT THAT
TIME SO I READ THAT IS STILL
GIVING QUITE A BIT OF DISCRETION
VISIONS.
AND SO AM I MISINTERPRETING
SOMETHING BECAUSE I HAVE HEARD
FROM YOU KNOW FOLKS THAT IT WILL
LIMIT.
OF POLICE OFFICERS ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY DO THEIR JOB WHICH IS
WHAT WE WANT THEM TO DO SO --
AND I THINK ALL FOLKS AT THE
DíAS.
AT THE TABLE SHOULD FEEL FREE TO
SHARE.
BUT DOES IT STILL GIVES.
POLICE OFFICERS THE DISCRETION
TO DO THEIR WORK AND MAKE THOSE
KINDS OF QUICK JUDGMENT.
UP I CAN I CAN START SAY BRIEFLY
I BELIEVE ABSOLUTELY SO AND IN
PARTICULAR.
THE DEFINITION OF TOTALITY OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES IS EXPLICIT
THAT IT MEANS ALL FACTS.
ARE KNOWN TO THE PEACE OFFICER
AT THE TIME SO THIS IS NOT ABOUT
JUDGING IN HINDSIGHT THIS IS NOT
ABOUT JUDGING AN OFFICER BASED
ON FACTS.
THAT ARE UNCOVERED IN THE
INVESTIGATION LATER IF AN
OFFICER RESPONSE TO SOMEBODY --
POINTING A GUN AT THEM AND WILL
IT IS LATER DISCOVERED THAT THAT
GUN IS UNLOADED OR IS A REPLICA.
THOUGH THE FACT THAT IT IS
UNLOADED OUR REPLICA THAT WAS
NOT KNOWN TO THE OFFICER AT THE
TIME IS NOT PART OF THE CALCULUS
OF JUDGING WHETHER THE THE USE
OF FORCE -- WAS REASONABLE IT IS
BASED ON THE FACTS KNOWN TO THE
OFFICER AT THE TIME AND IN FACT
NOT ONLY IS IT EXPLICIT IN A
LANGUAGE BUT ALSO IN THE
LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS IN EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE A SUBSECTION A IT IS
CLEAR -- THAT -- IT IS CLEAR
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT INTEND TO
SUBJECT OFFICERS TO JUDGE
OFFICERS ACTION IN HINDSIGHT.
I'M FIRST I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO
YOUR INITIAL QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THIS BILL
MANDATES A PARTICULAR CHARGE AND
I DISAGREE -- WITH THE GENTLEMAN
STATEMENTS.
THE BILL HAS PROPOSED.
TAKES AWAY THE DEFENSE OF JUST
WHILE HOMICIDE FROM AN OFFICER
IF THEIR TACTICAL CONNECTING
DECISION MAKING UP TO THE USE OF
FORCE.
IS DETERMINED TO OF BAD
CRIMINALLY NEGLIGENT I THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY SAYS IN THAT CASE
OFFICER WILL ONLY HAVE DEFENSE
WHAT WILL BE EXCUSE ME WILL NOT
HAVE THAT -- FROM A DEFENSE FOR
JUSTIFIABLE HOMICIDE AND WILL
FACE A MANSLAUGHTER PROSECUTION.
THIS IS BEEN EXPRESSLY
REPUDIATED.
BY THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
VERSES MENDEZ -- IT IS BEEN VERY
CLEARLY ARTICULATED BY THE
HIGHEST COURT IN THIS COUNTRY
INDEPENDENT ACCESS -- VIOLATIONS
OF THE FOURTH A MEMBER SEE THE
INDEPENDENT VIOLATIONS THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT NEED TO BE
REVIEWED SEPARATELY IN DISTINCT
FROM ANY USE OF FORCE AND JUST
BECAUSE YOU MAY HAVE COMMITTED A
SEPARATE FOURTH MY MY VIOLATION.
IMMEDIATELY PRECEDING A
JUSTIFIABLE USE OF FORCE YOU
CANNOT LOSE YOUR DEFENSE OF SELF
DEFENSE BECAUSE OF THAT INITIAL
VIOLATION OF SOMEBODY'S FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS -- IN REGARDS
TO YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE TO
TABI OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS WOULD
MOVE THE MOVE THE ANALYSIS FROM --
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE STANDARDS
TO A SUBJECTIVE I AGAIN I
DISAGREE -- THAT THIS IS STILL
LOOKING AT IT FROM OFFICERS
PERSPECTIVE AT THAT TIME IT VERY
CLEARLY IS ASKING. FOR A HOST OF
EXPERTS TO COME UP OUT OF THE
WOODWORK AND TRY TO CONJURE UP
ANY ALTERNATIVE.
OTHER THAN THE DEADLY USE OF
FORCE IT SPECIFICALLY SAYS TO
LOOK AT TIME DISTANCE COVER
TACTICAL REPOSITIONING.
WHICH IS NOTHING SHORT OF
RETREATING BUT BY ANOTHER WORD
AND IT'S ASKED TO BE REVIEWED
FROM THE COMFORTS OF A BUILDING
LIKE THIS FROM A NICE CHAIR
SITTING AT A TABLE REVIEWING A
VIDEO SLOWING IT DOWN LOOKING
FRAME BY FRAME.
NOT BY SOMEBODY -- NOT NOT BY
THE PERSPECTIVE OF SOMEBODY LIKE
JULIE ROBERTS SAYING WHO'S IN
THE FIGHT OF HER LIFE WATCHING
HER PARTNER BE MURDERED TRYING
TO DEFEND [inaudible]
DEFEND -- BY INNOCENT CIVILIAN
BY STANDARDS AND SO YOU'VE GOT
TO KEEP THE ANALYSIS AT THE
OBJECTIVE REASONABLE OFFICERS
PERSPECTIVE AT THE TIME TAKING
INTO WHAT THE OFFICER.
KNOWS AND ACCEPTING THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE IN A RAPIDLY
EVOLVING SITUATION NOT LOOKING
AT THIS LATER TO SEE -- WELL
SHOOT THEY SHOULD HAVE SEEN THAT
THAT WAS JUST A NERF GUN OR NOT
A REAL GUN OR THEY SHOULD OF YOU
KNOW.
GOING BACK TO THEIR CAR AND
RETREATED IT'S IT'S UNREASONABLE
AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE AND IN FACT
IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
CASE NINETEEN NINETY FOUR SCOTT
BEHIND RIGHT THE COURT EXPRESSLY
REJECTED THIS HINDSIGHT
SUBJECTIVE ANALYSIS.
AND SAID THAT TO REQUIRE
OFFICERS TO LEE USE THE LEAST
INTRUSIVE MEANS AND THE LEAST
INTRUSIVE MEANS ONLY.
REQUIRE SUPER HUMAN JUDGMENT AND
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS.
KAMLAGER-DOVE -- I'D LIKE TO
RESPOND AS HAVING BEEN SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN IN PATROL FOR TWENTY
YEARS BOTH AS AN OFFICER AND A
SUPERVISOR.
AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
I FEEL NO RESTRAINT ABOUT MY
SAFETY IN TERMS OF HOW I RESPOND
TO SUSPECTS WHO OFTEN RAN FOR ME.
AS A FEMALE OFFICER WHO AWARD
HAPPY ABOUT THE SERVICE THAT I
WAS PROVIDING AT THAT TIME AND
DURING MY TWENTY YEARS -- I
WORKED SOUTH BUREAU CRASH
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AGAINST
GANGS.
I WAS INVOLVED IN DEALING WITH
VIOLENT CRIMINALS ON A DAILY
BASIS I SHOT NO ONE I HAD
SUSPECTS RUN FROM ME FIGHT ME
CURSE ME I SHOT NO.
ONE AND SO AS A POLICE OFFICER
YOU'RE REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO
RELY ON YOUR TRAINING AND
SOMETIMES YOUR TRAINING MEANS
BEING ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
SOMEONE IN SUCH A WAY THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO GAIN COMPLIANCE
SOMETIME THAT TRAINING MEANS.
I'VE GOT TO CHASE YOU AND RALPH
SO WITH YOU TO GET YOU WENT TO
CONTROL BUT WHAT I'M NOT ALLOWED
TO DO IS IF YOU ARE PROFANE IF
YOU ARE NOT COMPLYING IS PUNISH
YOU.
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT I'M NOT
ALLOWED TO SHOOT YOU BECAUSE I
CAN'T CATCH YOU I'M NOT ALLOWED
TO SHOP TO CHOKE YOU TO DEATH
BECAUSE YOU WON'T TURN AROUND
AND SO AS A POLICE OFFICER I CAN
TELL YOU FOR TWENTY YEARS.
I DID THAT JOB AND I DID IT
FACING ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE AND I
FELT NO CONSTRAINT IN TERMS OF
HOW I COMPORTED MYSELF.
DAY TO DAY I DIDN'T HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT IT I DIDN'T HAVE TO
ASK ANYBODY I DIDN'T CALL THE
LAN LINE AND ASK MY WATCH
COMMANDER I RELIED ON MY
TRAINING.
AND I DID WHAT I WAS SUPPOSED TO
DO EXPECTED TO DO REQUIRED TO DO
AND I'M NOT SUPERHUMAN YOU SEE
ME I'M JUST A GIRL.
WILL NOT HAVE ANY MORE OUTBURSTS.
PLEASE.
I WANTED TO RESPOND NEARLY TO
THE QUESTION OF THE ON
CONSTITUTIONALITY AND JUST SAY
THAT THAT IS.
PLAINLY NOT THE CASE ON THE IDEA
THAT THIS BILL IS IN ANY WAY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT IS.
TRUE THAT THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT HAS SET A LOWER
STANDARD FOR POLICE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE WHEN IT IS
ADDRESSING WHETHER THAT USE OF
FORCE VIOLATE INDIVIDUALS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
THAN THIS BILL WOULD SET FORTH
BUT NOTHING -- IN THAT OPINION
IN ANY OF THEIR JURISPRUDENCE
SUGGEST THAT OFFICERS HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO KILL
PEOPLE AND NOTHING -- PREVENTS
THIS BODY FROM SETTING
CALIFORNIA LAW -- TO BE A HIGHER
STANDARD -- FOR THE USE OF
POLICE DEADLY FORCE THAN THE U.
S. CONSTITUTION ONE THAT IS IN
LINE WITH BEST PRACTICES --
AGENCIES -- AND PROGRESSIVE
AGENCIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY I'M
AND I ALSO JUST WANTED TO
BRIEFLY SAY.
THE BILL EXPRESSLY -- THE THE
THE WITNESS -- POINTED OUT.
TO WE TALKED ABOUT THE
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE OFFICER
STANDARD WHICH THIS BILL
EXPRESSLY INCORPORATES IT
DEFINES NECESSARY.
AS GIVEN THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT AN
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE OFFICER
WOULD IN THE SITUATION WOULD
CONCLUDE THAT THERE WAS NO
REASONABLE ALTERNATIVE.
THESE ALL THE MECHANISM BY WHICH
THIS BILL APPROACH IS EVALUATING
USE OF FORCE IS THE SAME
REASONABLE OFFICER -- APPROACH
THAT.
CURRENT LAW USES IT JUST SETS
THE STANDARD HIRED TO
UNNECESSARY STANDARD RATHER THAN
A VAGUE.
WAS THE USE OF FORCE REASONABLE
STANDARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO -- I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR RESPONDING TO MY
QUESTIONS -- BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT.
I HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT SINCE
WE STARTED SESSION.
I GUESS I COULD ARGUE THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT EVER SINCE I MARRIED A
BLACK MAN WHO HAD.
WHO HAS BLACK CHILDREN -- I
STILL BELIEVE THAT IT IS UP TO
THE DA TO MAKE THESE
DETERMINATIONS ABOUT THE LEVEL
OF CRIMINAL NEGLIGENCE AND IF AN
OFFICER COULD WOULD BE
PROSECUTED.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT REGARDLESS
OF THESE SITUATIONS AFTER
INCIDENTS.
OF ANY KIND HAPPEN THAT OFFICERS
WOULD BE HAVING DEBRIEFING
SESSIONS TO FIGURE OUT HOW BEST
HOW TO INCORPORATE BETTER BACK
BEST PRACTICES INTO THEIR
TRAINING.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY IF
NOTHING ELSE MISTER CHAIR --
THIS BILL IS ASKING US TO TAKE A
PAUSE.
ON HOW WE INTERACT WITH EACH
OTHER.
THE PUBLIC.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC SHOULD NOT BE AFRAID OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE SHOULD BE
WELCOMING THEM.
AND WANTING THEM IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN OUR HOMES AND ON
OUR STREETS.
IF YOU MAY JUST INDULGE ME
MISTER CHAIR.
I WANT TO EXPLAIN WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT.
I WANT TO LET YOU ALL KNOW.
I'M GONNA SHARE INCIDENT.
THAT WILL HELP YOU UNDERSTAND MY
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
I WAS OUT DOING ERRANDS.
I WAS VERY CLOSE TO HOME.
MY HUSBAND CALLED ME AND SAID
THE ALARM WENT OFF AT THE HOUSE
ARE YOU CLOSE CAN YOU GO.
I SAID YES I HAPPEN TO BE RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER [inaudible]
I PART I THE DOOR WAS CRACKED A
LITTLE BIT AYE NGUYEN IN.
I WENT IN THE HOME THERE WERE
FOUR POLICE OFFICERS IN THERE
WAITING FOR ME.
ALL HOLDING THEIR HOLSTERS
LOOKING VERY COMMON PATIENT.
THREE MEN AND A WOMAN.
THEY SAID WE GOT A CALL.
THE BACK DOOR WAS OPEN IT WAS
WINDY THE SANTA ANA WINDS.
THE DOOR WAS CRACKED OPEN SO
THEY CAME IN THEY CHECKED THE
PERIMETER OF THE HOUSE AND THEN
THEY WENT INSIDE TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOTHING WAS GOING ON
BECAUSE THE ALARM HAD GONE OFF.
I PUT DOWN MY GROCERIES.
I STOOD THERE AND I LISTEN TO
THEM SHARE THIS INFORMATION WITH
ME VERY CALMLY THEY WERE VERY
RESPECTFUL.
AND I NOTICED.
THAT I STARTED SHAKING.
I STARTED CRYING.
IN MY OWN HOME.
AND I REALIZED.
THAT I WAS CRYING BECAUSE I WAS
AFRAID.
I DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE ANY SUDDEN
MOVEMENTS.
I THOUGHT MAYBE WILL I GET SHOT
IN MY OWN HOME BECAUSE I DO
SOMETHING.
THAT MAKES THEM CONCERNED OR
FEARFUL.
I THOUGHT OH MY GOD WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IF MY SIX FOOT THREE VERY
DARK BLACK HUSBAND UNEXPECTEDLY
COMES HOME TO CHECK ON ME AND
THE HOUSE WELL THEY THINK HE IS
AN INTRUDER.
COMING AFTER ME WILL THEY SHOOT
MY HUSBAND.
IN MY OWN HOME QUESTIONING MY
AUTHORITY [inaudible]
MY PRIVACY [inaudible]
MY SAFETY.
I WILL ARGUE.
THAT I AM A RELATIVELY YOUNG
BLACK WOMAN.
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF PRIVILEGE
LESS THAN MANY MANY OTHERS.
AND I WAS AFRAID.
THAT REVEALED MY OWN TRAUMA
ABOUT THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'RE HAVING ABOUT THESE KINDS
OF KILLINGS THAT WE SEE AND WE
READ ABOUT.
AND IF I AM TRAUMATIZED IN MY
OWN MIDDLE CLASS HOME.
THEN WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PAIN AND THE FEAR AND THE TRAUMA.
THAT COMMUNITIES BLACK BROWN
ASIAN POOR MENTALLY ILL AND L.
G. B. T. FACE EVERY DAY.
AND WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO WORK WITH
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
TO SAY HOW DO WE PROTECT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HOW DO WE
PROTECT COMMUNITIES.
SO THAT WE CAN ALL BENEFIT FROM
THE LAWS IN THE DEMOCRACY THAT
WE A SPOUSE.
SO IT IS FOR THOSE REASONS THAT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AND I WILL BE URGING URGING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO COME TO CONSENSUS
[inaudible]
BECAUSE THIS.
ALL.
MUCH MORE THAN IT SHOULD.
AND AS A STEP MOTHER.
I'M A YOUNG BLACK BOYS IN A
BLACK GIRL.
AND A HUSBAND WHO MY LOVE.
ON MY ANNIVERSARY OF MY WEDDING.
I DON'T WANT ANY OF US TO LIVE
IN FEAR.
NOT YOU NOT YOUR TEAM.
AND NOT THESE COMMUNITIES RIGHT
HERE.
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
INDULGING ME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
MR LACKEY OR MISTER DHEA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I I WANNA BEGIN BY SAYING THAT --
CLEARLY WHAT.
EXIST IN OUR SOCIETY TODAY IS A
LOT OF DISTRUST [inaudible]
THERE'S A A GREAT DISCUSSION
THAT NEEDS TO CONTINUE.
ON HOW WE BUILD THAT TRUST.
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THOSE WHO ARE NOT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR PUBLIC AND
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN'T TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I DON'T DENY THE BAD SHOOTINGS
OF HAPPENED.
AND I TRULY APOLOGIZE FOR ANY
POLICE MISS CONDUCTOR INJUSTICE
BECAUSE IT HAS HAPPENED.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT.
I THINK SOME THINGS ARE MISSED.
AND I FEEL LIKE.
WITH EVERY FIBER OF MY BEING
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT.
DISCUSSION THAT I HAVE ENGAGED
IN MY ENTIRE ELECTED EXPERIENCE.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT'S GOING ON
HERE AND THERE'S A LOT OF
MISPLACED PERSPECTIVE.
AND WHAT I WANT TO TRY.
TO HELP.
THOSE WHO DISTRUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS TO TRY TO JUST
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THAT SIDE OF THE DISCUSSION.
YOU KNOW ALL PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO
SWEAR THAT WE'RE WE'RE REQUIRED
WHEN I SAY WE ARE NO LONGER A
MEMBER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT I WAS
FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
SO I I DO BELIEVE I UNDERSTAND
THAT PERSPECTIVE.
AND I JUST WANT TO CLEARLY TRY
TO BRING SOME BALANCE TO THIS
DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE EMOTION OF
DISTRESS IS HUGELY POWERFUL.
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO DISCOUNT
THAT.
I TRIED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
THIS ONE PART OF THIS BILL.
I CAN NEVER SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT NEGOTIABLE AND THAT IS
THE TERM REASONABLE.
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT ALL
PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO SWEAR
WILLINGNESS TO DIE.
IN PRESERVING PEACE.
ARE THREATENED BY THIS VERY VERY
TERM.
IMAGINE HOW THE PROPOSAL OF
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT
WOULD BE RECEIVED.
THAT'S HOW DRAMATIC THIS POLICY
SHIFT HAVE.
AND I'M TELLING YOU WHY I MEAN
EVEN.
I'M NOT.
SUGGESTING THAT TAKE PLACE AT
ALL.
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT'S
THE DRAMATIC IMPACT.
CHANGING THE WORD REASONABLE.
IN THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
ONESELF WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE
THEIR LIFE IS THREATENED.
THAT'S A SUPREME COURT TESTED
STANDARD EVERYONE.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THE AND
JUSTICE THAT HAS HAPPENED.
HAS HAPPENED BECAUSE OF THE
RULING.
OF A JURY.
AND A TRIAL.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT A PERFECT
STANDARD.
BUT I COULD TELL YOU.
WITH OUT ANY HESITATION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO JUST SHARE A
VERY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE MYSELF.
AND I SEE THERE'S GROANS IN
RESPONSE TO THAT BUT I THINK
IT'S IT'S AND DESERVES TO BE
MENTIONED.
I HAVE A VERY DEAR FRIEND OF
MINE.
WHO SERVED ALSO IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SUBSEQUENTLY
RETIRED?
DURING THE COURSE OF HIS.
SERVICE.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN A DEADLY
SHOOTING. TO WHERE HE HAD TO
TAKE THE LIFE OF A PERSON WHO
WAS ATTACKING HIM.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT THAT
INCIDENT CHANGED HIS LIFE.
AND NOT FOR THE GOOD.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS JUSTIFIABLE.
THE FACT THAT HE HAD TO TAKE
SOMEONE ELSE'S LIFE [inaudible]
CAUSED HIM [inaudible] TO ADAPT.
TO THAT CHALLENGE IN A WAY THAT
WAS HURTFUL.
AND IT LED TO AN ADDICTION.
THE LEAD TO A A FAMILY
INTERVENTION.
AND THE FAMILY INTERVENTION
TRIED TO REACH OUT AND SUPPORT
THIS FRIEND OF MINE.
LIFE.
AND THAT SOMEONE IS FORGOTTEN IN
THIS DISCUSSION IS THAT.
WHEN PEACE OFFICERS ARE PLACED
IN A POSITION? TO WHERE THEY
FEEL LIKE.
THEY HAVE TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
NO ONE CAN REALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT UNLESS YOU'VE BEEN IN THAT
POSITION.
AND I WOULD JUST ASK
[inaudible]
THE IF WE NEED TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS LET'S MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS BUT LET'S ANYTHING
THAT.
CHANGES THE WORD REASONABLE.
IN THE ABILITY. TO DEFEND
ONESELF IS UNREASONABLE.
AND I WOULD ASK THE JUST NOT BE
THE MEASURE THAT WE USED TO
BUILD BACK TRUST BECAUSE IT WILL
DO.
MORE DAMAGE AND VERY VERY.
SAD CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE
OFFICERS WILL HESITATE.
THAT HESITATION.
WILL CAUSE A LOT WILL RESULT IN
LOSS OF LIFE AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY WANTS THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER [inaudible]
DIAZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SERMON AYE AYE -- I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN -- MENTION -- TODAY.
THIS ISSUE IS -- EXTREMELY TOUGH
A VERY A VERY PASSIONATE
EMOTIONS ON BOTH SIDE I WANT TO
SAY THAT -- I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR DR WEBBER -- FOR
BRINGING THIS ITEM FOR BECAUSE
SHE DOES HAVE THE COURAGE. TO
FIGHT FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE IS
RIGHT -- I MY BIGGEST CONCERN.
WITH THIS BILL [inaudible]
IS.
THE ABILITY TO SECOND GUESS OUR
FRONTLINE OFFICERS [inaudible]
AND CAUSE THEM TO HESITATE.
OR SLOW DOWN EVEN FOR A SECOND
OR TWO WHILE THEY ARE IN THE
FIELD.
SOMETIME TAKING FIRES
[inaudible]
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS.
AN ACCEPTABLE MEDIUM.
ANYWHERE BETWEEN.
WHAT IT IS THAT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE
VERSES WHAT -- OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY -- IS.
ADVOCATING AGAINST.
I HOPE THERE IS -- AND AND IF
THERE IS THAT I WON REFER BACK.
TO WHAT MY OF MY COLLEAGUES --
MISTER QUIRK AND MISTER AND MRS --
BAR CAN WAS VOTE.
MENTIONING EARLIER.
IS THAT IT GIVE.
A WE TRULY HAVE.
SOME RESERVATION ABOUT THIS BILL
TODAY.
THIS IS THE COMMITTEE THIS THE
POLICY COMMITTEE WHERE.
WE SHOULD WORK THIS OUT.
BECAUSE IF WE LET THIS BILL.
GET OFF THE FLOOR HOW DO YOU
NEGOTIATE WITH [inaudible]
EIGHTY MEMBERS -- THE EIGHT OF
US.
HALF THE POWER WITHIN THIS BODY.
TO SEE IF WE CAN COME.
TO AN ACCEPTABLE SOLUTION TO
BOTH SIDES IF THERE IS -- ONE TO
TO BE HAPPY.
BUT IF WE COME HERE AND AND WE
SAY THAT.
WE WE UNDERSTAND ISSUES.
WE WILL MOVE THIS BILL FOR FOR
FURTHER.
NEGOTIATIONS I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT IS.
THE RIGHT APPROACH.
AND AND AND FOR THAT TODAY IS
GERMAN -- I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND I STRONGLY URGE -- MY
COLLEAGUES DOES THAT STILL HAVE
SOME RESERVATION ABOUT THIS BILL.
TO KEEP IT HERE FOR A LITTLE BIT
LONGER TO THE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY WORK ON IT.
WHEN IT GETS TO THE FLOOR?
THE THE FLOODGATES IT'S IT'S
IT'S OPEN [inaudible]
AND THANK YOU MISTER.
YET TO COME -- I JUST WANT TO
START BY SAYING LOOK THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST COMMITTEE SO I WE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS BECAUSE NONE
OF OUR BILLS ARE PERFECT IN THE
FIRST COMMITTEE.
I MEAN WE'VE OFTEN SAT BEFORE
CHAIRS WITH OFTEN SAT BEFORE --
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN AND DISCUSS
THE FACT THAT OUR BILLS WILL
CHANGE AND IN FACT.
YOU KNOW THE AUTHOR AND I WERE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING.
PROPOSAL THAT I'M MOVING FORWARD.
TOTALLY DIFFERENT COMMITTEE
RIGHT NO MY STE WHY NO MY BILLS
NOT COOKED BUT IT'S GOT NINE
MONTHS TO GO IN IF I CAN'T GET
IT DONE AND AND NINE MONTHS THEN
WILL SPILL OVER TO A TWO YEAR
SESSION.
THAT'S THE NORM -- AND SO I I WE
WERE DIFFERENT IN IN THAT SORT
OF OPINION IN.
BUT I WANT TO SAY FIRST TO TO
BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND AND THE
AUTHOR.
THAT I I'VE BEEN HERE FOR A
SHORT TIME ABOUT FIVE YEARS.
AND I'VE SEEN A LOT OF HEATED
DEBATES THIS IS ONE OF THE
HEATED DEBATES I SEEM WERE BOTH
SIDES OF CONDUCTED THEMSELVES.
IN THE MOST PROFESSIONAL WAY.
AND THE CONVERSATIONS ON BOTH
SIDES OF BEEN LOUD BUT IN A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE.
POLICY ORIENTED WAY I NEVER
HEARD FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT THERE NEED THAT THAT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'VE HEARD I'VE HEARD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE LANGUAGE --
AM PRETTY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THE
AUTHOR ONCE AND I AGREE THERE
NEEDS TO BE A BETTER WAY TO DO
POLICING DRIVER LONG
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU -- ON HOW.
TO DIFFERENT SIDES CAN SEE THE
SAME LANGUAGE.
AND TWO DIFFERENT SIDES SEE A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT OUTCOME.
AND THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
CHALLENGING.
BUT I DON'T THINK.
BECAUSE THAT SITUATION EXISTED
THE BILL NEEDS TO BE HELD.
IN THE FIRST COMMITTEE IN AND
I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE I THINK THE MESSAGE THAT
IT SENDS OUT.
IS THAT THIS IS NOT A SEARS
ENOUGH ISSUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND I DO HAVE TRUST IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I'VE BEEN
THERE BEFORE. TO ASK MEMBERS TO
HELP ME TO GET MY COMMITTEE OUT.
OF MY BILLS OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
I UP I HAVE SOME FAITH IN THE
SYSTEM -- THAT'LL BE A IS THAT
THEY'LL BE A CONVERSATION.
NO NO ONE HERE WANTS TO SEE AN
OFFICER PART.
I'M PRETTY CERTAIN ABOUT THAT --
BUT NO ONE HERE ALSO WANTS TO
SE.
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WHO IS
INNOCENT.
OR GUILTY HURT EITHER.
I MEAN LET'S BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT AND I TRUST AND AND I TRUST
IN THIS WEBER MY INTEREST IN
THIS WEBER THAT SHE'S TAKEN A
LOOK AT THIS -- AND THEY TAKE A
LOOK AT THE END OF THE LANGUAGE
AND ENSURING THAT THAT WE THAT
WE DO.
THAT THAT IT REFLECTS.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO NOT
TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT AT THE
THAT AND THEIR ABILITY TO COME
IN?
AND TALK IN AND AND PROPOSE
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS LIVE
LEGITIMATE ISSUES.
NOT WANTING TO CHANGE IS ONE
THING.
AND WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE RIGHT
WE HAVE TO NUDGE FOLKS TO CHANGE
A LITTLE BIT.
WELL -- BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE
DO UP HERE THAT'S WHAT
LEGISLATION DOES -- BUT WE WANT
TO DO IT RIGHT NOW I DON'T WANNA
THANK YOU LOOK I HAVE A
DIFFERENT.
PERSPECTIVE ON ON HOW I VIEW LAW
ENFORCEMENT BASED ON THINGS THAT
HAPPENED -- IN MY LIFE AND MOST
RECENTLY -- WHAT WE'VE HEARD
SITUATIONS OF PEOPLE BEING
SCARED OF LAW ENFORCEMENT I I'VE
ALSO BEEN A SITUATION WERE
RECENTLY I'VE SHARED WITH MOST
PEOPLE HERE PRIVATELY IT'S A
FIRST TIME ALL SHARE PUBLICLY --
I'D LIKE TO ATTEND THE BREAK INS
IN MY HOUSE.
OF THE FIRST WHEN I WAS THERE --
AND FORTUNATELY THE PERSON
DIDN'T.
MANAGE TO GET IN AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAME IN THEY WERE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
ALWAYS WONDERED WHAT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO THE RESPONSE TIME WAS
A QUICK ENOUGH AND THE PERSON
WAS NOT A SERIOUS THREAT BUT
THEY THEY GOT TO THE DOOR AND
THEY WERE STARTING TO DO WHAT
THEY GOTTA DO AND I'M UPSTAIRS.
WITH MY KIDS BUT YOU CAN IMAGINE
WHAT GOES ON YOUR MIND.
I NOT BEEN THERE.
HAD HAD BEEN TWO HOURS LATER
MORE SLEEP [inaudible]
EVERYTHING.
THAT YOU WOULD FOR YOUR LIFE.
FLASH BEFORE MY EYES IN THAT
MOMENT.
THE SECOND ATTEMPT TO BREAK IN --
WAS A GOOD VIEW WEEKS AGO.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME WE KNOW
WITH THOSE ONE PERSON OR TWO
PEOPLE AND AND AND IT WAS
TERRIFYING.
AND AND OBVIOUSLY I FLY UP HERE
FOR WORK THAT'S NOT A SECRET.
FOR ANYBODY THINK THAT'S A
SECRET WHILE -- BUT I OFTEN
THINK WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THAT
HAPPENED AND YEAH I WAS ON THE
PHONE [inaudible]
AND RAISING MY VOICE ASKING THEM
TO GET THERE SOONER AND QUICKER.
IN FIVE MINUTES.
IT'S NOT LIKE AN ETERNITY.
AS I'M WAITING SIDE OF MY HOUSE
AND MY WIFE IS UPSTAIRS LOCK IN
THE LOW OR PUTTING AS MUCH
THINGS SHE CANNOT FOR THE DOOR.
NOW IT WASN'T AS BAD.
AS AS I AM MAKING IT THE SOUND
ONCE WE HAD ALL THE FACTS.
BUT WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE THE FAX.
ANYONE HERE WOULD BE TERRIFIED.
DID NOT KNOW WHAT THOSE ONE
PERSON OR TWO PEOPLE OUTSIDE --
AND FORTUNATELY FORTUNATELY
NOTHING HAPPENED I RAN OUTSIDE
WITH THE BATON THE REST OF IT I
WILL.
I WILL CHAIR BECAUSE I I WAS ONE
OF THOSE GUYS THAT RULE WALKED
OUTSIDE WITH ABOUT NOT KNOWING
WHAT WAS GOING ON IT TO BE
CONFRONTED -- ALSO BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BUT THAT WAS THEIR JOB.
AND IT TOOK ME ABOUT TWO TWO
DIFFERENT -- COMMANDS TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE I WAS AT BUT I WAS A
LITTLE BIT WORRIED AND IDEA
WASN'T THINKING RATIONALLY THE
TIME -- SO MY PERSPECTIVE ON
APPROACHING THIS -- IS
UNDERSTANDING AND APPRECIATION --
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT'S HARD WORK.
AND THE SITUATIONS THEY OFTEN
PUT THEMSELVES IN -- TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND AND I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT EVEN HAVING SAID THAT I I I
STILL THINK.
IT'S NECESSARY TO BOOK THIS BILL
OUT.
EVIL DOES BILL OUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN YOU DON'T HAVE RESPECT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE WAY I AM
INTERPRETING THIS.
BUT IT MEANS THAT THAT THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
THE MOVE.
FOR AND ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
THERE THE WAR WILL HAVE TO SIT
DOWN AND WE'LL HAVE TO HAMMER
OUT ANY ANY ANY [inaudible]
POLICY DISCUSSIONS.
THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN IN
LANGUAGE AND THIS IS WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS DOES -- TO
ALL ONE THANK THE AUTHOR AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR COMING.
HAVE IN THIS -- IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION.
AND I'M FAITHFUL IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT IS THAT
AT THE END OF THE DAY -- GOOD
LEGISLATION IS BUILT.
AND IT ACHIEVES THE GOALS --
THERE ARE SET FORTH -- HERE
TODAY.
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SPEAK ON THIS.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE
CHARACTERIZE THIS.
IN A WAY THAT THAT.
IN A WAY THAT THAT THAT MAKES
SENSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO AND UP.
AND YOU KNOW I I PROBABLY WANT
TO ALSO.
MAYBE TRY -- TO RESET.
THE PRIORITIES OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO.
IN THE BIG PICTURE.
AND I KIND OF CAME TO ME AS I
SAT LISTENED. TO BOTH SIDES
THAT'S WHAT'S SO GREAT ABOUT.
COMMITTEE HEARINGS YOU GET TO
HEAR BOTH SIDES AND IF YOU
REALLY LISTEN.
YOU CAN REALLY HEAR SOMETHING AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW -- I DO A LOT
OF WORK WITH TRONG WHERE'S TRUMP
ON CARE.
ASUS WHETHER IT'S WHAT I CALL
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
THE COMMON THAT PEOPLE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCE.
AND AS I LISTEN TO THIS.
THE SHERIFF'S -- JULIE ROBINSON
THIS THIS HERO ABOUT DEFENDING
HERSELF AND HER PUBLISHER
PARTNER.
I REALIZED HOW MUCH TRAUMA SHE'S
EXPERIENCE.
AND THEN WHEN IT.
I LISTEN TO MY COLLEAGUE TO MY
LEFT.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT.
SOMEONE DID HE WORK WITH OR IF
YOU KNEW VERY WELL.
THAT -- WAS INVOLVED IN OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING.
THAT TRAUMATIZED HIM. TO THE
POINT WHERE HE TOOK HIS OWN LIFE.
AND THEN I HEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUE TO MY RIGHT.
THE END WHO -- KIND OF BROKE
DOWN.
AND ABOUT JUST HAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN HER HOME.
AND WORRIED ABOUT HER FAMILY.
ESPECIALLY IS NOW AFTER AMERICAN
MALE ALL RIGHT I CAN EMPATHIZE
WITH HER.
AND I KNOW WHAT THAT FEELINGS
LIKE.
AND SO ON BOTH SIDES ESPECIALLY
YOUNG MEN TO TESTIFY TODAY --
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO TOUCH AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S IS RISEN TO THIS
LEVEL.
BUT I HOPE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS WE HAVE
TO TAKE CARE OF THIS AND WE HAVE
TO GET THIS RESOLVED.
BECAUSE WE ARE ALL TRAUMATIZED.
WHEN AN OFFICER?
IS KILLED BY A CRIMINAL.
THEY ARE TRAUMATIZED THE WHOLE.
SECTOR THEY'RE TRAUMATIZED.
AND IT HAS AN EFFECT ON HIM THAT
I THINK SOMETIMES.
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
JUST LIKE AN AFTER MERRICK IN
LIKE IN COMMITTEE WOULD ALWAYS
SEEK MENTAL HEALTH.
IN FACT IT IS PROBABLY.
FROWNED UPON.
ON BOTH OUR COMMUNITIES.
I WILL NEED.
NO PART OF THIS DISCUSSION
SHOULD BE ABOUT.
WHAT HAPPENS?
AFTER THAT HAPPENS.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. TO BOTH
SIDES WHEN I AM HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO HEAL
THAT COULD THAT IS PROBABLY WHAT
KEEPS THAT'S ST GETTING WORSE
AND WORSE.
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO RESET.
THE CONVERSATION AS I BELIEVE IT
I HOPE AS WE MOVED OUT.
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
SUBSTANTIVE DISCUSSIONS ON HOW
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
ON TO RESOLVE THIS -- I'M
LOOKING AT PAGE.
THREE SEE WHERE SAYS NEITHER
THIS SECTION OR SECTION ONE
NINETY SEVEN PROVIDE A PEACE
OFFICER WITH THE DEFENSE TO
MANSLAUGHTER IN VIOLATION OF
SECTION. ONE NINETY TWO IF THAT
PERSON WAS KILLED DUE TO THE
CRIMINALLY NEGLIGENT CONDUCT OF
THE OFFICER INCLUDING SITUATIONS
IN WHICH THE VICTIM IS A PERSON.
OTHER THAN THE PERSON THAT THE
OFFICER WAS SEEKING TO ARREST
RETAIN CUSTODY OR DEFENDING
GUESTS OR IT DIDN'T ASSESS CITY.
FOR THE USE OF DEADLY FORCE WAS
CREATED BY THE PEACE OFFICERS
CRIMINAL NEGLIGENCE.
I DON'T THINK LAW ENFORCEMENT
MEANS.
IT BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
DOES A CRIMINAL ACT.
BECAUSE THEY HAD TO MAKE A SPLIT
SECOND DECISION.
THAT WE CAN'T JUDGE A CRIMINAL
ACT.
BUT I'M HEARING.
CONVERSATIONS BOTH WAYS AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN COME TOGETHER
IF YOU NEED TO BE SOME
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE. TO ENSURE
THAT THAT 1% OF THE NINE OF THE
1100% AND THAT THE 99% ARE
CLOUDED [inaudible]
WITH.
WHAT THE 1% DOES DâN LET'S WORK
TOGETHER TO DO THAT TO MOVE THE
SPORT -- SO THAT WE HAVE THINGS
IN PLACE [inaudible]
SO THAT [inaudible]
WE DO.
CREATE.
BETTER OFFICERS I DON'T BELIEVE
WE NEED TO GO TO THE LOWEST
DENOMINATOR.
I BELIEVE WE CAN SET STANDARDS
POLICIES PROCEDURES AND TRAINING.
SO THAT WE GET THE BEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST.
AND THE ONES THAT CAN BE LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOT EVER I DON'T
BELIEVE EVERYBODY CAN BE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THAT'S WHY
YOU HAVE TRAINING THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE A WHOLE SYSTEM. TO WEED
THEM OUT.
AND IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HAVING A HIGHER STANDARD A
HIGHER STANDARD.
OF POSSIBLE TRAINING IN A FOR
FUTURE BECAUSE WE'VE NOW. 239-2
HAVE NOW SET A HIGHER STANDARD
[inaudible]
THEN LET'S [inaudible]
DO THAT.
LOOK I WANT TO BE A POLICE
OFFICER.
BUT I DON'T HAVE TWENTY TWENTY
VISION.
AND ALSO I'M OLD THEY DON'T HAVE
A EIGHT HAVE ALL THAT I STUFF
YOU ZHAI'S CORRECTED. TO GET TO
TWENTY TWENTY SO I DIDN'T MAKE
IT.
I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU AT I WAS
IN AND REASONABLE STANDARD.
BUT NOW THAT I'M OLDER.
YEAH I DO WANT TO HAVE AN
OFFICER WITH TWENTY TWENTY
VISION. TO BE ABLE TO SEE.
WHAT'S GOING ON TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SPLIT SECOND DECISIONS WITH
ALL OF THEIR FACILITIES AT 1100%
[inaudible]
CAPABILITIES.
AND SO -- MY IT'S NOT A QUESTION
BUT IT IS A A FIRM REQUEST IF
NOT AS CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE --
ALMOST A DEMAND FROM BOTH SIDES
[inaudible]
THAT YOU.
GET PAST THE TRAUMA.
IF YOU NEED ME TO GET YOU
SOMEBODY TO HELP YOU HAVE SOME
TALKING SESSIONS OR A DIVORCE
ATTORNEY OR SOMEBODY TO GET YOU
TOGETHER.
GET RID OF ALL THE THE PAIN.
AND TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN STOP.
FUTURE PAIN.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I SEE NOT
ONLY HERE BUT I'VE ALSO SEE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ALSO SEE IN THIS
AUDIENCE.
THERE'S A LOT OF PAIN.
THAT.
AS LEGISLATORS.
YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS SAY WE CAN'T
LEGISLATE PAIN AWAY YOU CAN'T
LEGISLATE RACISM CAN'T.
BUT WE CAN WE CAN PUT IN PLACE --
LAWS THAT HELP US MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION.
AND I HEAR FROM BOTH SIDES THAT.
YOU WANT TO GET THERE.
IT'S A QUESTION OF HOW.
AND I'M HOPING THAT.
AS IT MOVES OUT HERE WE CAN GET
THERE.
AND SO.
WITH THAT IF YOU'RE AREN'T ANY
MORE QUESTIONS.
I WANT TO THANK THE WITNESSES
FOR YOUR FOR YEARS YOUR
TESTIMONY.
I WANT.
TO THANK THE AUDIENCE FOR
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY.
AND I WANNA THANK YOU AND WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN HAVING PEOPLE
COME IN STATE THEIR NAME --
WHETHER FOR WHATEVER NOW IT WILL
WHERE THEY STAND ON THE ISSUE.
AND WHAT ORGANIZATION I BELONG.
TO AND TO MIKE'S ON EACH SIDE
THERE WILL BE THE DEAL THE
WITNESSES ARE DISMISSED AND WE
WILL BEGIN OUR PROCESS.
OF ME TO USE.
NAME ORGANIZATION.
I'M SORRY I TAKE THAT BACK WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH THE WELL WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT FIRST AND THEN
WE'LL DO OPPOSITION.
SO AND SUPPORT FIRST AND THEN
OPPOSITION TO SAME.
WAY WE DID THE THE OTHER SIDE.
AND AFTER THAT I'LL BE QUICK THE
COMMITTEE WILL DO THE FORMAL --
VOTE ON AB [inaudible]
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
YES I'D.
THAT MIGHT WORKING IS THIS MIKE
WORKING.
MIKE OF SEARS WORKING.
JUST SAY TESTING.
ONE TWO THREE TESTING YEARS.
SENATORS GOT IT THE WORKING ON
UP STEERS SO WE CAN BEGIN DOWN
HERE [inaudible]
NAME.
ORGANIZATIONS TESTS WHEN I
OBSERVER YOUR PRO SO GO.
GERMANS AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES THAT AT DIXIE IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
ACTUALLY THAT'S WERE.
DESPITE NOT USUAL AT THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO IN DOUBLE ACP IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM.
OKAY I'M JUST KIDDING ABOUT THE
PLAN.
BACK TO THIS.
REVEREND KEVIN CONTROL ROSS
SENIOR MINISTER OF UNITY OF
SACRAMENTO LEADER WITH
SACRAMENTO ACT IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
VERONICA NELSON MEMBER A BAY
PACK BUT WAPA SACRAMENTO
REALTORS AND IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LESS SIMMONS WOULD SACRAMENTO
ACT AREA CONGREGATIONS NOT
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB -- THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
JACKIE GROWING UFCW WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINKS THANK YOU ACTUALLY W.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINA MALES
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
AB GREAT INTERSECTIONAL TOPIC IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING ASHLEY RABBIT SHEA
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LEGAL WOMEN VOTERS.
GOOD MORNING VANESSA QUITE ARE
WITH USE ORGANIZING DISABLED AM
PROUD AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU MA'AM.
SAFEST AKA BOBBY JOHNSON.
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED THE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
SIR.
WILLIAMS RULE FUTURE SOCIAL
WORKER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
LET NAY THE NIECE NOR WOULD WITH
INSTITUTE DEVELOPING EQUITY
ADVOCACY AND LEADERSHIP ALSO
KNOWN AS IDEAL AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA ACT TO
SAVE LIVES THANK YOU MA'AM.
RUSSELL RAWLINGS SUPPORTING
DISABILITY ACTION COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU
RUSSELL.
LAWRENCE CARTER WITH THE
ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS IDEAL
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU SIR.
COMO FERGUSON FOUNDER SEXTAPE
LAXITY UNION FORMER PRESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE CHAPTER BY OUT OF
WHAT THEY OF TURNING CORPORATE
IT CAN APPLY CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
TO NINETY TWO ALL RIGHT I NOTIFY
BETA HOUSE.
CANDID SHOT AND OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY RESIDENT -- AND SHORTEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
NINETEEN THANK YOU MA'AM.
BRANDING KENNEDY A MEMBER OF CAP
OFF SITE FOR TURNING CORPORATION
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF BILL AB.
THREE NINETY TWO I KNEW.
IN IRWIN WITH SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
YEAH BRITTANY'S I'M STRONGLY
INFORMED THE BILL AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM.
ALICE CORLEY MOTHERS AGAINST
POLICE BRUTALITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- RIGHT SHE
SAID THE PRESIDENT CEO OF LIFT
OF LOVE ALWAYS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU LIFT
A BLUFF.
ANSWER REAL MUHAMMAD IN OF
SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY A WILLIE
MCCOY.
AND IS STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU SIR.
DANIEL PERERA FATHER.
MICHAEL BRUNNER.
BARLEY MURDERED AT THE HANDS OF
WOODLAND P. THROUGH EXCESSIVE.
UNNECESSARY [inaudible]
DEADLY FORCE.
ORDER AB.
THREE NINETY TWO NO JUSTICE NO
PEACE.
THANK YOU SIR.
MULLIN OUT OF THIS ALTHOUGH WITH
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
IS STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM.
MERCER BRIAR HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE NINETY TWO STRONG LEE
AND MY BROTHER MY CAREER JUSTICE
MICHAEL BURKE KILLED WHILE
HANDCUFFED.
AND AND AN ARM NOT POSING A
THREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAMELA FEELS ON MY
MOTHER I AM NOT BECAUSE IT.
WAS KILLED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT LET US
LAY OUT.
THANK YOU.
YES YOUNG MAN.
HE SUPPORTS HIS BILL AND WHO
FAIR REPRESENTING HIS UNCLE
MICHAEL BRECKER THINKING THANK
YOUNG MAN.
HI MY NAME IS JUST SIDE VALDEZ
AND I AM THE MOTHER OF JOSIAH
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE I HAVE TO LIVE.
EVERY DAY WATCHING MY SON LIVE
FROM THE TRAUMA IN THE AFTERMATH
POLICE LIKE IT'S IN A NEEDS TO
STOP.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELLIE I'M WITH THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION ON THE
COUSIN OF JUNIOR RODRIGUEZ WHO
WAS FOURTEEN SHINE KILLED BY
SOMETHING A P. D. IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI I'M CINDY JOB IS FROM SAN
JOSE MY SON WAS EXECUTED BY
SOUNDS A PD I'M A STRONG.
SUPPORTER AB THREE NINETY TWO
THANK YOU HE WAS ON ARMED.
YOU SPEAK.
MANAGERS RODRIGUEZ I'M FROM STOP
COALITION -- HI SIX STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BILL -- IN REGARDS TO
MY COUSIN JAMES DATA ROSA.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE THESE -- THE
SISTER OF JACOB DOMINGUEZ HE WAS
SHOT AND PANEL SAY I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TED CARRILLO I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
MIGHTY OAKS.
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STRONG
AND THE ACLU WE ARE ALL STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE NINETY
TWO AND I HAVE A LETTER TO
SUBMIT TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO MIGHTY OAKS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS REGINA AND JACOB
DOMINGUEZ AS SAM WHO WAS
MURDERED EXECUTED BY CELL THE PT
I STRONG SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN BRUNNER
I'M WITH INDIVISIBLE CAMERAS ARE
CALIFORNIA STRONG AND THE ACLU
AND I'M VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ROSY JOB IS ALMOST
SILICON VALLEY DE BUT I'M ALSO A
FAMILY MEMBER IMPACTED BY.
THE VIOLENCE OF POLICE BRUTALITY
JACOB DOMINGUEZ WAS MY NEPHEW
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS I'M AFRAID COR I AM A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY WITH THE
STUDENT GOVERNMENT AND ACLU I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RALPH WHEN USE MY
NEPHEW JACOB DOMINGUEZ WAS
MURDERED BY A CPT STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
SCHERING GROUND.
UP WAS SACRAMENTO PEACE ACTION
STRONGLY SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO REAL JOB FOR THE OF TWO ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHARON WATKINS MOTHER
OF PHILIP WATKINS SHOT AND
KILLED BY SAN JOSE POLICE
DEPARTMENT FEBRUARY ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
CLARK EAST ACLU KINGS COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS BARBARA
OKAMOTO THE GRANDMOTHER OF
CHRISTOPHER OKAMOTO WHO WAS
MURDERED BY BAKERSFIELD PD I'M
FROM STOP COALITION I'M STRONGLY.
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SHARIF ALI HE SACRAMENTO HAS
INTERPRETED HONORABLE MODEL MY
NAME IS PATRICIA.
WE'RE GOING BACK AND FORTH.
GO AHEAD SURE IF I LEAVE
REPRESENT MASS YOU KNOW SUPPORT
HE SACRAMENTO I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THIS AND NOT A GUN.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM YOU'RE NEXT I'M SORRY HI
MY NAME IS PATRICIA PERSKY.
I'M ALSO HERE FOR CHRISTOPHER
OKAMOTO.
WHO SHOT AND KILLED AND WITH THE
STOP COLLATION?
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
YES SIR MY NAME IS CORTES MORE
I'M THE FATHER ROSARIO MATT WHO
WAS MURDERED.
IN A SHOT IN THE BACK BY LAPD
AND I'M STE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE NINETY TWO WITHOUT IT
WHITE SUPREMACY CONTINUE TO
FLOCK TO CALIFORNIA TO GET A
BASS KILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT.
MY NAME IS ABLE THEN IS THE
DAHLE AND THE FORMER STATE REP
FOR ALLIANCE RECOVERY COMMUTING
PALMER.
FORMERS NASH REPRESENTED
POPULARITY I AM CURRENTLY TO PUT
HIS CAMPAIGN.
I AM CURRENTLY PROCESSING BUT
NOT A ALLY A BLACK LIVES MATTER.
I AM ALSO INVOLVED IN DOUBLE ACP.
I AM SO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE HUNDRED LET THOSE
CHILDREN LIVE.
I THANK YOU MA'AM OF THE CLOCK
FAMILY LIVES.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WHAT DO WE DO?
LOGGING ME OUT ITS MEDIA CITY
SPEAK WELL PREDICT ALL YOUR ME.
AS THE MY CRY IS TO MY PAIN.
I'M THE MOTHER VERSION ARE YOU
MAC KILL APRIL TENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A CRUCIAL MALL.
THEY FOUND THE OFFICES OUT OF
POLICY TOOL ROOM FOR KILLING MY
SON SO PLEASE PASS THIS BILL SO
THEY MAY BE PROSECUTED FOR
KILLING MY BABY.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SHE AND MOTEL ABDUL MORALIS SELF
FOR THE MORE SCIENCE TEMPLE OF
AMERICA UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A
NEED FOR AB THREE NINETY TWO
BECAUSE SO MANY OF US ARE
UNAWARE OF THEIR STATUS AND
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
I'M STEFAN ANDERSSON THE BROTHER
OF PASSING OF HIS BILL --
BECAUSE I COME FROM A FAMILY DE
SER LA.
HI MY NAME IS SANDY SANCHES --
THE MOTHER VENTING UNIONS HE WAS
MURDERED BY TWO CELLS EIGHT P.
EASE.
OFFICERS AND AFTER THEY KILLED
MY SON THEY GAVE EACH OTHER A
HIGH.
FIVE SEOUL WE NEED THIS BILL
PLEASE PASS GET THIS BILL PASSED
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
KAELIN DEAN ALIGNS FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR AND POLICY LINK
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORTER
OF AB THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MAYES JUNIOR SOME SOME
AFTERNOON YES COUSIN I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
YES MY NAME IS ANSWER A MOHAMMED.
JAILING PROMOTIONS -- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU PRO
LIFE.
GOOD MORNING I'M AT THE CHECK
OUT OUR AS THE MOTHER OF JAMES
TAYLOR'S AND MURDERED BY MAKE
SURE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
EIGHTY THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
USER [inaudible]
YOUR NEXT.
YOUR NEXT -- GOOD MORNING I'M
JAMES SHALL BE FORMER PRESIDENT
CEO OF THE GREATEST SEGMENT
OPENLY FORMER MAYOR CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS SAID IS THAT YOUR SITES.
REFORM AGAIN THE COMMISSION I'M
HERE TODAY. TO SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF PASSING THIS BILL IS
VERY IMPORTANT THIS LAWS ON THE
BOOKS SINCE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS.
IT'S TIME TO CHANGE THANK YOU
SIR.
HI MY NAME IS GERRY HARPER I'M
HERE REPRESENTING ACLU FROM
KINGS COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING MARIA SCHOOL A
LITTLE REMINDER THAT CRISTINA
SCHOOL A LITTLE AND I SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME SUSAN WALL FROM HERE
TODAY WAS SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
AND THE FAMILIES IN THE SAN JOSE
AREA WHO LOST LOVED ONES. TWO
POLICE VIOLENCE I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ADAM WHAT A KING AND
THE CHAIR OF THE SOCIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
AT THE UNIVERSALIST UNITARIAN
CHURCH RIVERSIDE.
I'M A LEADER WITH INLAND
CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE
SB GO CALIFORNIA AND ITS STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL LET US LIVE.
MY NAME IS JEREMY WHITE WITH THE
MAY FIRST COALITION IN THE ME
TWO SURVIVORS MARCH AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY AT
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU SIR.
LYNN BERKELEY BASKIN ON BEHALF
OF THE GREATER SACRAMENTO JEWISH
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COUNCIL WE
ARE SO IN SUPPORT.
WITH THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
I'LL BE AT THE FOUNDER DIRECTOR
OF EXONERATED NATURE STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD TO SEE OB.
ANY CARMONA -- WITH PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA PRO COAST SPONSOR AND
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU.
ARE WE NOW.
IS ONE MORE DOWN HERE.
EVE MADISON RIVER BAY PAT.
AND BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME
HERE.
AND AND WORKMAN CLONE SUPPORT
THANK YOU BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
THE BILL NOW MOVES. TO THE
GALLERY [inaudible]
FIRST.
ONE STEPHEN CASTELLANOS TRUSTEE
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
CYNTHIA WHAT AND ALL MY NEPHEW
AUGUSTINE GONZALEZ WAS KILLED BY
THE HAIR OF POLICE.
HERE SHOT THIRTEEN TIMES WITHIN
SEVEN SECONDS.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND I SUPPORT
THE THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
CARLA GONZALEZ MOTHER BOASTING
GONZALEZ THAT WAS SHOT IN
HAYWARD ON NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL HE WOULD BE
ALIVE TODAY THIS BILL IS IN FACT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROSIE PEREZ I LIVE IN
LA COUNTY MY SON WAS KILLED BY A
CENSUS COUNTY POLICE DEPARTMENT
ALL SERIES POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
I STRONG SUPPORT HIS BILL I'LL
BE A FOREVER BE THE MOTHER.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS SHANNON GROW I'M HERE
FROM A COUSIN JOHN.
STARKS.
HE WAS BEATEN DOWN BY FIVE LA
SHARES.
IN THE MEN'S CENTER BUT ALSO
REALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT NEEDS TO STOP.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS BEN COR I'M HERE WITH
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND
A TEACHER WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VINCE
THE STUFF NAM HERE REPRESENTING
THE ACLU ON BOARD MEMBER IN
PASADENA CALIFORNIA AND SEE CARP
THE COALITION INVESTIGATING
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT OF PASADENA
POLICE.
I SPEAK FOR THE RM NUMBERLESS
VISIT AND VICTIMS AND PASADENA
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL STRONGLY.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI CESAR GOMEZ I'M HERE WITH THE
ACLU OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NORMAN NELSON
RESIDENT OF YELLOW COUNTY ALSO A
MEMBER OF ENVISIONED JUSTICE
MEMBER OF OUR LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS AND THEY PACK AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI VALERIE VETERAN I AM THE
MOTHER OF ERIC RIVERA WHO WAS.
MURDERED BY TWO VERY NEGLIGENT
AND INCOMPETENT LAPD OFFICERS
AND OUR WHOLE HEARTEDLY STAND BY
THIS BILL BECAUSE MY SON'S LIFE
MATTERED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KILEY MILLIONS ACLU AS SUPPORT.
EMILIO PRO COSPONSORED WITH YOU
JUST AS COALITION LIFTING OF
DANIEL LOPEZ WAS KILLED BY
COMPANY SHARES THE CELL PHONE IS
NOT A GUN.
THANK YOU SIR.
ASTRAZENECA EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED TO
MASTER WORKERS AND I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI I'M LINDA REVIEW OF CALAVERAS
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL I'M HERE FROM THE A.
C. L. U. [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AUDREY GEORGE HERE FROM WHITE
PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES IN LOS
ANGELES I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT WILL SAVE LIVES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CURRENT HAMILTON
I'M HERE WITH THE ACLU
SACRAMENTO AND THE WINDS OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT.
AND STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ROSY UP BY THE I'M
A YEAR -- USC STUDENT AND I'M
HERE WITH THE ACLU AND POOR AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU FIGHT
ON HELLO MY NAME IS MONICA RAMOS
I'M HERE WITH ANTI POLICE TEAR
PROJECT.
AND YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION I'M
ALSO REGISTERED NURSE AND A
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND M. STANDING IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I NAME IS KAMEL COURT I'M
REPRESENTING NAY IN THE BLACK
SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE BAY AREA
ALSO I'M HERE WITH A P. T. P.
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE BLACK RISE
LIBERATION PARTY NEW GENERATION
OF THE BLACK PANTHERS AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
[inaudible]
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHARON WASHINGTON I'M
A GRADUATE STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
STATE AN EDUCATOR AND THE
FOUNDER OF BLACK LIVES MATTER
MANTECA AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE NINETY TWO
JUSTICE BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
THANK YOU.
I AM IN NO SO GABRIEL -- ACLU
ANTELOPE VALLEY CHAPTER AND ALSO
THE THE ACLU KINGS COUNTY
CHAPTER.
AND A STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
EIGHT THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
CHRIS SANCHEZ ACLU ON THE BALLOT
CHAPTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RICHARD PEREZ OF THE
GRANDFATHER OF PT CARESSING GOT
KILLED.
IN RICHMOND BY RICHARD POLICE
OFFICER.
A HE GOT REWARDED BY GETTING
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND HE'S BEEN OFF FOR FOUR YEARS
NOW HE SUPPORT THE BILL AND I
SUPPORT AND THEY SUPPORT THE
BILL OKAY.
I'M PATRICIA PEROT'S I'M PT'S
GRANDMOTHER HE WAS KILLED BY
RICHMOND POLICE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS JANUARY SIGNED THE
SISTER OF CHARLIE SALINAS KILLED
BY THE POLICE IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE SINGER CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANKYOU.
MY NAME'S STEVE ROGERS AND
CITIZEN MEMBER DIGGING IN POWER
NOW AS WELL AS THE COALITION AND
SURE OF VIOLENCE -- MY WILL BE
COMING UP HERE FOR AS MANY YEARS
IT TAKES FOR THIS BILL TO PASS
WITH THE WORD NECESSARY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PAUL DO WANT --
ACLU SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MEMBER
AND I'M HERE WITH MY CHILDREN
SUPPORT AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AND CLEARING WITH WHITE PEOPLE
FOR BLACK LIVES IN LOS ANGELES
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M ONLY ONE VEIN FROM INLAND
CONVERSATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE
IN STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HEY MY NAME IS BLAME COGAN I'M
HERE WITH THE FAMILY OF THE ANTI
GARBER WHO WAS UNARMED WHEN HE
WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED BY BARSTOW
POLICE WHO FIRED SURE THIRTY
SHOTS. THIRTY SHOTS IN PUBLIC
WITH THEIR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE VEGA I'M A
MEMBER OF THE STAMINA DINO
COUNTY YOUNG DAMS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THERE'S THIS BILL SAY
THEIR NAMES AND DON'T FORGET
THEM.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS DRAW FURRY AND I'M
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE NINETY
TWO AND I SUPPORT THE OF THE
FAMILIES OF THE FALLEN LOVED
ONES.
AND THEIR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DENNIS HEWLETT SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN RELATE CHIRLA SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
JOHN TODAY BECAUSE THE ANNALS.
ACLU STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SERGIO MARCY ALL BLACK LIVES
MATTER ALLIES SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PAUL.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI CAME WITH YOU'LL CHESS THIS
COALITION I SUPPORT THE BILL MY
NEPHEW CHRISTOPHER DE ANDRE
MITCHELL WAS MURDERED THE TOWERS.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS A HERO WHY I LOST MY
PARTNER QUENTIN THOMAS IN TWIN
TOWERS CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
MARCH NIGHT THE LAST YEAR AND IS
SUSPICIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES.
HE WAS IN A ONE MAN STILL -- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THREE NINETY
TWO PLEASE PASS THE MY NAME IS
SHARON HAYNES.
MY SON WAS MURDERED METALLERS
POLICE DEPARTMENT DECEMBER NINTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HIS ONLY
CHILD -- SUPPORT IN THE MAIL
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW -- THEM.
EVERY.
I'M GOING.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M THE KAISER WITH THE LA
CATHOLIC WORKER I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS ERIN BRATTON I AM A
PROUD PEPPER DIED SCHOOL LAW
GRADUATE.
ONLY NEO **** -- AND TRIGGER
HAPPY CONSTABLES THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
ANY OF THE IT WAS ASSASSINATED
BY POMONA POLICE AFTER HE FILED
A COMPLAINT AT THE STATION THE
ONE OF PHILLIPS DANTE ARBOR.
AND THE DANIEL PICK IS STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S ANY BANKS AND HERE
WITH THE ANTI POLICE CHAIR
PROJECT IN THE JUSTICE TEAMS
NETWORK WE'RE BOTH PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO MY NAME IS
ELLEN CHAPMAN I'M HERE WITH
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DOUG TRIED WELL INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG AND UNITED METHODIST
CHURCH SHOPS SACRAMENTO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
FERRIS WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
MY NAME IS SHARED ON EVANS ON
WITH CSU SACRAMENTO'S POLITICAL
SCIENCE DEPARTMENT A SEXTET BE
ISSUE AND ON THIRTEEN AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
FLORIDA MAN ON I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELISA REPAIRS -- I'M
WITH THE MEAL BY.
AND I STRONG SUPPORT IS A BILL
THAT IS LIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE MY LOOK AT THE ARNOLD COMING
ALL THE WAY FROM MADE BY SALINAS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
TO MY NAME IS YVONNE WHAT'S IN
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER ENOUGH
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL LET US
LIVE.
MY NAME IS DAVE ON A WATSON AND
I WITH THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
LOS ANGELES I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I LIKE TO SAY THAT
TRUST BETWEEN THE POLICE AND THE
COMMUNITY IT NEVER EXISTED.
MY NAME IS DAVE PICKENS PART OF
BLACK LIVES MATTER TO AND I'VE
WORKED THIS BILL BECAUSE I CARE
ABOUT ALL BLACK LIVES IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU SIR.
MICHAEL CAM FROM OURS COUNTY I'M
WAS A C. R. U. S. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS VERY SENSIBLE B. O. THANK
YOU.
HI AM JOE GOLAN FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M JULIE ALLEY FROM A SO YOU
WEBSITE CHAPTER EIGHT OUT OF
VETERANS FOR PEACE CHAPTER SEVEN
AND PEOPLE POWER I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL.
HI KIRSTEN MAGNUSON FROM THE
WEST SIDE CHAPTER OF THE ACLU AS
WELL AS PACIFIC PALISADES
DEMOCRATIC CLUB AND PEOPLE POWER
MARINA DEL REY ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ULYSSES COLEMAN
AND I'M FROM LONG BEACH IN OUR
SUPPORT TO YOU -- FOR JUSTICE
COALITION.
AND I'M SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
INGER OLSON STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TO SAVE LIVES.
I'M HAVING HAD THIS IN THE LA
I'M FROM LA A STRONG SUPPORT TO
BE A JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINE TWO LET US LIVE.
ON MARCH FIRST BRENDA RODRIGUEZ
TWENTY YEARS OLD WAS KILLED BUT
SALINAS POLICE DEPARTMENT MY
NAME'S ISRAEL VIA.
ALSO WITH ME BY A PROBLEM
MEMBERS OF THE ALLIANCE OF BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR PROBLEM MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA LINE. FOR YOU
THAT COMMUNITY JUST IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME THAT THE ROBUST THEM
AT THE JUSTICE COALITION AND I'M
A STRONG SUPPORTER THE BILL IN
THIS IS GONNA THINK WELL US WAS
TWENTY YEARS OLD WHEN HE WAS
SHOT IN THE BACK WHILE HE WAS
RUNNING BUT THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND THEN EXECUTED
WHILE HE WAS LAYING.
ON THE FLOOR BACKING FOR LIFE.
THANK YOU SIR.
I NAME IS JOYCE DEALING HERE
WITH UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
UNION STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO HI MY NAME IS
YOU WERE BORN -- HI SAYS THIS
WORKER AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S KRISTINA GONZALEZ
SISTER OF AUG STAYING GONZALEZ
SHOT AND KILLED IN HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ALSO WITH THE JUSTICE COALITION
CONSTITUENT OF DISTRICT FIFTY
THREE SUPPORTERS BUILT LONG
CARILLO DIED FROM PEPPER SPRAY
AND COUNTY JAIL.
MY NAME'S ADAM SMITH FOR MY
PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES IN LOS
ANGELES AND THE NAME OF ALBERT
RAMON DORSEY.
WHO WAS MURDERED IN OCTOBER OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BY LAPD
VALUES NAKED IN THE SHOWER
TWENTY FOUR HOUR FITNESS I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M JEREMY TREMOR WITH WHITE
PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES TO LOS
ANGELES CHAPTER OF SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE AND I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
[inaudible]
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU.
I'M THE AS LEMAK WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OF FATHER AND UNCLE
A YOUNG BLACK CHILDREN IN.
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU DOCTOR WEBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY MISTER AS YOU OF OUR NEW
JUNIOR WITH THE GREATER
SUBCOMMITTEE URBAN LEAGUE AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO HI GOOD SANDRA
JENNINGS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO -- MAINLY
I REPRESENT ALL THAT URBAN LEASE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES AND SAN
DIEGO AND SACRAMENTO AND ALSO
REPRESENT THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
OF THE LINKS INCORPORATED.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE NINE TWO AND THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME ISFLORENCE PROCENT
I'M FROM MERCER COUNTY AND WITH
UT W. UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF DAY
AB [inaudible]
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
LET THE SYLLABUS FROM PORTABLE
CALIFORNIA AND TULARE COUNTY
HERE WITH THE ACLU -- I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO HI MY NAME IS
SERGEANT IDEAL SO I KIND OF MEAN
MAY SECOND.
THREE I SUPPORT AB AB.
THREE NINETY TWO HI MY NAME'S
KATRINA VEHICLE AYE BROTHER
LOTUS SOUTHERN.
I SUPPORT.
IN ALL THESE BE.
EVEN WE ALL GOT SAME BLOOD.
WE ALL GOT TO ASK ME EVERYTHING.
I CAN'T EVERYBODY JUST CRAP AND
GET ALONG IT'S RIDICULOUS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM STEFAN CLARK. TO YOU FROM
OUR GREAT.
I WAS.
IN MY GRANDMOTHER'S BACK YEAH.
THANK YOU.
YOU SUPPORT THIS MY NAME IS JIM
MILLY ELENA AND I AM HERE WITH
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES UNITED FOR
JUSTICE WITH MARCH ON AND WITH
BAY PACK.
STEPAN CLARK THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOMINIC ARCHIBALD MY
SON IS NOTHING HERE SPEAKING HE
WAS GUNNED DOWN BY SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
I'M RETIRED US ARMY COLONEL TO
TIME COMBAT VET AT THE PENTAGON
ON THE DAY IT WAS HIT.
I SUBMIT TO YOU.
THAT THEY ARE MORE RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT AGAINST UNKNOWN ENEMY
THAN POLICE OFFICERS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE ON OUR STREETS
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND I WAS NOT I WAS WILLING TO
LAY DOWN MY LIFE AND YOU APPROVE
OF THIS AND I APPROVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
LOUISE MAY LIVE FOR AMNESTY
INTERNATIONAL.
AS WELL AS INDIVISIBLE AND THE
ACLU IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR -- LEE
BYNUM UW ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY ON BEHIND ON BEHALF
OF I JUST AS WORKERS AND THEIR
CLIENTS WHO CANNOT COMPLY WITH
ORDERS -- WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THAT EVERYONE UP TOP.
NOW WE'RE GOING DOWN. TO MY LEFT.
YOU MAY BEGIN MA'AM.
YOUR NEXT MY NAME IS SHERRY AND
I'M HERE ONBEHALF OF LEARNED SO
CREWS.
WHO IS SHOT IN HIS FACE CLOSE
RANGE FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH?
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND I
SUPPORT BILL THREE NINETY TWO
BECAUSE IT WILL HOLD THESE
ENTITIES THESE HUMANS THESE
PERSONS TO ROAM THIS EARTH.
AROUND OUR CHILDREN AROUND OUR
WOMEN IN AROUND ARE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THANK YOU.
CAN MORE U. D. W. WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER.
HERE IN SUPPORT ABSOLUTELY 1%
AND STANDING IN THE GAP FOR OUR
MEMBER MY OR YOU CAN LEAVE THE
WHO WAS SHOT AND KILLED BY
POLICE IN BI<c.cyan>.</c>
THANK YOU.
YES HI MY NAME IS CHERYL CRUZ
I'M THE MOTHER LORENZO CORALS
WHO WAS KILLED BY ROCKLIN PD.
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THANK YOU
IN I DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOING BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HE SAID.
HI MY NAME IS LETICIA BEARING MY
SON WAS KILLED OCTOBER TENTH TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN BY CHP -- ON
THE I FIVE FREEWAY HE GOT HIT BY
A CAR FIRST AT SIXTY FIVE MILES
AN HOUR AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
COPS ON I LIVES DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THEN THE MAYOR.
GABRIEL GARCIA WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS VALERIE WOULD SET
MY COUSIN MARIE SO BARREN JUNIOR
WAS KILLED OCTOBER TENTH TWENTY
SIXTEEN BY THE H. B. IN IRVINE.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU -- KEVIN WHAT IS ALL
THE CURRENT MEDICAL STUDENT
ALUMNI OF JOHNS HOPKINS SCHOOL
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
HERE WITH WHITE COATS FOR BLACK
LIVES AT UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JUDY AGENTS MY SON
WAS MURDERED IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AUGUST TWENTY SECOND
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND I'M
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AB.
THREE THIRTY TWO I MEAN THE
THREE NINETY TWO PLEASE PASS AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SIMEON
DANCED WITH THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK WE DO BELIEVE
THAT -- POLICE ABUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABUSE IN THE
COMMUNITY IS A BILL IS A HEALTH
CONCERN IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS YES AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TRACY ALDERMAN
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL MY NEPHEW
JASON ALDERMAN WAS KILLED BY BPD.
ALONG WITH MANY OTHERS IN THE
COUNTY.
THANK YOU.
HI ANGELES ART -- FIRST YEAR
MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE REPRESENTING
WHITE COATS FOR BLACK LIVES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARIE COUGHING GO.
THIS IS MY NEPHEW FUHRMAN
VINCENT DOWNES WHELAN.
THE ANAHEIM DEPARTMENT KILLED
HIM JULY SECOND TWENTY SIXTEEN
THEY USE THE CHAU CALL I
APPROVED. TWO THREE NINE THREE
NINE TWO IT'S TIME TO END POLICE
VIOLENCE THANK YOU.
YES SIR SPENCER MAY MEDICAL
STUDENT WITH WHITE COATS FOR
BLACK LIES AT UC DAVIS MEDICAL
MEDICAL SCHOOL I STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
FOR GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS FUHRMAN VINCENT BUT
IN SWELLED UP.
I AM THE FATHER.
OFFERMAN VINCENT BROTHERS ONE OF
WHOM WAS MURDERED.
BY THE ANAHEIM P. D..
EVERY BIT OF IT IS ON FOOTAGE.
I SHOULD DRAW.
FROM SOME POOR THIS BILL THREE
NINETY TWO AND I CHALLENGE YOU
THANKS WILL PROVE IT SIR THEY
MUST BE STOPPED THANK YOU SIR.
SIR MICHAEL GASTON OF YOUTH
FORWARD IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS DHEERAJ NIGHT OF MY
PHONE NAME IS DEAR TO US NINETY
TWO HE WAS THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
WHEN HE GOT LOCKED UP TO
SOMETHING YOU CAN DO IN THE
POLICE THREATEN HIM.
HE'S BEEN LOCKED UP A FIFTEEN
YEAR THESE TWENTY EIGHT NOW
AFTER.
FORTY THANK YOU SIR SB THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU SIR WOULD
YOU JUSTICE COALITION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MY NAME
IS WANDA JOHNSON I'M THE MOTHER
OF OSCAR GRANT THAT WAS KILLED
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE AT THE FRUIT WILL BART
STATION.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
OFFICER SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND THEY SHOULD USE ALTERNATIVE
MEASURES NOT THE MEASURES OF
JUST WITH THE MINDSET SHOOTING
TO KILL.
THIS HAS TO STOP AT A MUST STOP
TODAY THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS RAYMOND GARCIA I'M
HERE REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO ACT
AND PICKLE CALIFORNIA -- SEVEN
OF CRISIS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL JUST ON A HUMANITARIAN
LEVEL I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MY NAME
IS D. EMMERT I AM THE PASTOR OF
LUTHERAN CHURCH OF THE CROSS
HERE IN EAST SACRAMENTO AND I
ALSO AM A MEMBER OF SACRAMENTO
KIND AREA CONGREGATIONS TOGETHER.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE NINE
TWO I CAN DOWN A BROKEN KNEE
BECAUSE IT'S THAT IMPORTANT
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT.
HI MY NAME IS GERRY FOR SIDE I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES I'M THE FOUNDER
OF A BAND OF VOTERS I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF PEOPLE POWER.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL IN
HONOR OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN MY
FAMILY OF ALL COLORS MANY IN
FROM HAVE MENTAL ILLNESS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER VERY MUCH.
FOR THIS BILL I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLEGRA TAYLOR WITH
SACRAMENTO ACT.
B. Y. L. P. THE VILLAGE
ADVOCATES OF SACRAMENTO.
AND DOUBLE ACP WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS LEE SOMEONE CHAKA I
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA LIEU LACK
OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
AND STANDS.
FOR THE LEAGUE OF LATIN AMERICAN
CITIZENS -- DOCTOR WHEREVER
THANK YOU LATINOS ARE WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
OR LET ME NUMBER IS YES HE GOT
ESTATE SO YOU HONESTLY AND THEN
THE SACRAMENTO STATE HE SIGHED
BUT THEY SAW IT OR HE NINETY
OTHER SOME BAD NOT ONE OF THE
LAST WEEK THAT THIS MUST IMPACT
THAT THIS WOULD BE ALL IN SAID
THAT A POLICIA.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE STILL YAKKING A
PRESENT THAT NOT MUCH UP BUT
UNLESS I BE THAT'S USE THE MOST
UP WE ARE NOT HAVE IT BUT IT'S
NOT IN THE GOOD MORNING DEREK
MORGAN WITH THE OTHER BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MET MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY MOOD AT
SAM REAL FAR DIRECTOR OF MUCH
FOR LAST CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINETY TWO AND THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER FOR PUSHING FOR
JUSTICE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MATT THEY ON THE
GARCIA MEMBER OF BLACK LIVES
MATTER LOS ANGELES AND DIGNITY
AND POWER NOW I'M A CONSTITUENT
OF MIGUEL SANTIAGO AND OVER FIVE
HUNDRED BLACK AND BROWN LIES.
MURDER BY LAW ENFORCEMENT LAST
SIX YEARS UNDER JACQUI LACY I
STAND WITH THE FAMILIES AND THE
MOTHERS OF THIS MOVEMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE NINETY
JACKIE LACEY YOU GOT TO GO.
NEXT HI I'M ANNA THING WITH MARK
FOR LIVES CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
YEAH GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
FERNANDO LOPEZ AND I'M HERE FROM
SANTA CLARA COUNTY TO SUPPORT
THE THREE NINETY TWO ON BEHALF
OF MY BUDDIES I LOVE WAS WAS
MARRED BY CUTS IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
LOU LIVES MATTER.
THANK YOU.
HI ON A REAL MEMBERS -- MY NAME
IS SKY I'M WITH MARCH FOR OUR
LIVES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THREE NINETY TO A UNIFORM SHOULD
NOT STOP YOU FROM BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR YOUR ACTIONS
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSE VIE WITH SILICON
VALLEY BE BOOK IN THE CLEARING
HOUSE FOR PRISONERS UNITED OF
SILICON VALLEY -- AS ADVOCATE
FOR THE PRISONERS HUMAN RIGHTS
THE SENATE AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY JAILS I SUPPORT THROUGH.
NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M VIENNA GUY GOES WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS.
HI MY NAME IS JOSE RYAN I
SUPPORT.
THEY NINETY THANK YOU YOUNG MAN.
HI MY NAME IS DENISE PERERA MY
DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY I SUPPORT THIS
BILL I URGE YOU TO DO THE SAME.
DO NOT BE AFRAID OF THE
REASONABLE PERSON STANDARD IT IS
NOT NEW NOVEL OR NEBULOUS IT IS
APPLIED EVERY DAY IN THE
CRIMINAL COURT.
THIS IS COMMON SENSE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
IT'S LIGHT TO YOU AND ME AND IT
SHOULD BE APPLIED TO THE POLICE
AS WELL MA'AM.
LET'S TRY THIS AGAIN.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE I BLOG I'M
HERE FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
FOR MY NEPHEW HE CITED LOPEZ HE
WAS MURDERED IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY JAIL.
WE NEED JUSTICE.
THANK YOU.
MY MY NAME IS APRIL VANDYKE I'M
A DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER I SEE
THE EFFECTS OF BRUTALITY ON MY
CLIENTS EVERY DAY -- THEY SUFFER
FROM ANXIETY AND PTSD I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD HI UNDER THE NAG LOG I'M
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA I'M HERE FOR
A PSYCHE LOPEZ AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SHAWNA JOHNSON WITH
FAITH IN ACTIONS LIVE FREE
CAMPAIGN ON BEHALF OF THE
THOUSAND CONGREGATIONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS OFTEN
APPEARED AS I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MY BOYFRIEND HE SAY
LOPEZ AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. TO LISTEN TO TEARS
WITH SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AN
EXTRA POINT.
THANK YOUNG LADY.
I'M I'M -- RIPPER AS MY SON P.
PRESS MURDERED BY RICHMOND
POLICE DEPARTMENT OB STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY FOR COMMUNITY TRUST.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS YOLANDA LE DOES MY
WITH SILICON VALLEY DEBUG IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
LAWRENCE DINER FOR FROM BEVERLY
HILLS CALIFORNIA I'M HERE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH MY BLACK AND
BROWN.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS BECAUSE I
HAVE TWO SONS TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY FIVE THIS WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN TO THANK YOU IN.
I'M JENNIFER ROBERTS WITH
INDIVISIBLE COLUSA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M RAIN SHARE WITH THE JUSTICE
FOR JASMINE PHILLIPS TEAM FROM
CHICO CALIFORNIA AND LIKE
DESMOND PHILLIPS OVER HALF THE
PEOPLE KILLED BY POLICE IN
BI<c.cyan> COUNTY.</c>
HAVE A HISTORY OF MENTAL ILLNESS
KNOWN TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AT THE
TIME AND MOST OF THOSE WERE
DURING WELFARE CHECKS.
MY NAME IS DENISE COLORADO I'M
HERE WITH INDIVISIBLE LUCIC
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THREE NINE TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ADRIAN
SHARE ON FOR MORE THAN AN YOLO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ERIC HOLDER UP I'M A
MEMBER OF INDIVISIBLE COLUSA
COUNTY.
I WISH THIS BILL WERE NOT
NECESSARY BUT I THINK IT'S CLEAR
THAT IT IS I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS NO LAST WEEK I'M
PROBABLY HERE FOR CALIFORNIA
POLICY SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE PAN AFRICAN GLOBAL TRADE
INVESTMENT CONFERENCE.
THE OUR CENTER FOR AFRICAN PEACE
RIVER ARE RECONCILIATION.
THE HAWK INSTITUTE AND KLAY
FEDERAL ROSS A GUY WHO TELLS
ABOUT IT HELLO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID PHILLIPS I'M
HERE FOR MY SON DEAD MEN
PHILLIPS HE WAS MURDERED IN
CHICO CALIFORNIA. THREE
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THREE
OF THE FIVE OFFICER THE SHOT MY
SON.
HAD BEEN TO MY HOUSE BEFORE.
SO SLATED TO OF HIS MENTAL
ILLNESS I DO SUPPORT AB THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS RUSS GOKHALE YOUNG
VALLEJO RESIDENT AND ALSO
REPRESENTING FORMER RICHMOND
COUNCIL IMAGE OF AKA BECKLES --
PLEASE PASS AB THREE NINETY TWO
LET'S PROTECT OUR BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
I NAMES EVENT I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE JUSTICE FOR DESMOND TEAM
FROM CHICO CALIFORNIA AND
INDIGENOUS SUPPORT COLLABORATIVE
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU GREETINGS MY NAME IS
SAMI NONIUS FROM FATHERS AND
FOUND IS A SOUND WALKING AND
STOCKTON.
THAT IS LIVE WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
GOOD TO SEE YOU SAM YES SIR.
I AM RIGHT IN DOING YES HERE TO
SUPPORT MY BROTHER ERNEST I KNEW
THIS WAS SHOT THIRTEEN TIMES
FROM ANTIQUE A POLICE OFFICER
HAD NO WEAPON WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY I'M FROM SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT TO DO.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME ISROSE MARIE DO I GUESS
AND I'M MY SON ERNEST TRYING
THIS WAS ASSASSINATED BY JOHN
MOODY OF MEN TO GO PEE DEE.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS -- CELEBRATE IN FROM
THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY OF WORK
FOR FATHERS AND FAMILIES AND
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT HIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANNA CORTEZ AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MY SON SANTINO
TREVINO HE WAS KILLED BY TWELVE
OFFICERS IN LA IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I SUPPORT THIS
BILL HE'S A HUMAN BEINGS.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
YES SIR YEAH MY NAME IS TO WANT
SAY CLARK OF THE STUFF ON CLARK
FAMILY.
AND WE SUPPORT AGGRO.
WE SUPPORT BILL AB THREE NINETY
TO A BETTER THANK YOU SIR.
YES MY NAME IS THE SMITH DOWN SO
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT HIS BILL
THIS IS MY SON J. THE BROTHER
WHO WAS EXECUTED IN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA.
BY TO STOCK THE POLICE IN THE
SHARE AND THIS IS WHAT I GOT MY
SON BACK.
BOB TO BE ABLE TO BEAR HIM NO
FAMILY SHOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THIS.
NO JUSTICE NO PEACE YES MA'AM
THANK YOU.
MALAKAR ALL MEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN PARTNERSHIP.
THIS IS ABOUT ENDING THE
RACIALIZED ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS
AND WE ASKED TO LIVE.
PLEASE VOTE ON AB THREE NINETY
TWO THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM MY NAME IS FORM SO I
SHOWED YOU I'M EDUCATION
ADVOCATE.
A MENTOR FOR DOESN'T FUND OF
SOME WORKING.
I'M A FATHER AN ASSOCIATE PASTOR
PLEASE PASS.
AB THREE NINETY TWO PLEASE THANK
YOU YES MA'AM.
MY NAME IS ONE THAT HALL I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE QUITE YEAH
DURHAM WHOSE.
IS THE ART OF STEFAN KERR WHO
WAS KILLED.
BY POLICE AND I AM HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS I LIVE VEGAS IN I'M
HERE FROM LEGAL SERVICES ARE
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US ARE NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO BECAUSE STATE
TERROR AND PTSD DON'T HAVE TO BE
THE NORM AND I COMMUNITIES.
MY NAME IS AT WAR LOW GRAVITY ON
FROM FATHERS OF FAMILIES A SAN
JOAQUIN A WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND THAT IS LIVE.
THANK YOU.
LENDING CLOUDY WILL LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
[inaudible]
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATIE
DIXON I'M WHAT ELLIS PC ALL OF
US AND THEN STRONG SUPPORTER A.
B. THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ADRIANA COME OUT
ENOUGH I AM HERE FOR JUSTICE FOR
LOUISE GONGORA PAT.
ON MY END MEXICAN MAN WHO WAS
KILLED ON APRIL SEVENTH TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN THE SPAN OF TWENTY
EIGHT SECONDS WHILE HE SAT.
ON THE GROUND POSING NO THREAT.
I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
EIGHTY THREE NINETY TWO WEEKS I
AM STERN A LAW LIKE THIS WILL
SAVE LIVES IT COULD HAVE SAVED.
LOUISE'S LIFE THANK THANK THEM.
HELLO MY NAME IS SABINA CROW
CITY I AM THE POLICY MANAGER
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR PURCHASE
FOR CHILDREN AND IN MY
INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY I'M AN
ATTORNEY WORKING WITH PRISONERS
AND CONVICTED FOLKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WEBER
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WE
SUPPORT A AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THE NUMBER IS A
SEMINAR GOING ABOUT THEIR MINOR
IS THE MATTER WHAT ABOUT THE
AMOUNT THAT ARE TO SHIP IT OUT
BUT IT IS NOT FROM CISCO.
YOUR BANGOR UP FOR THAT AS
TIMELINE.
BUT OUR GLOBAL DISTILLS CAM
MULTI LOSE [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
CA.GOV.
MY NAME IS JOSE MANUEL GOING BUT
UP PAT I AM THE BROTHER RUSE
GOING WITH A PAT WHO WAS KILLED
BY SFPD.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS LAW
BECAUSE IT WILL BRING.
AN END TO POLICE IMPUNITY IT
WILL CREATE POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THANK YOU ARE RIGHT ON THE SIDE.
MY NAME IS DANTE ARE.
AND THIS IS NO WELL NO WILL SIGN
THE BACK.
WHILE THE HOTEL.
OF OUR POLICE HE WAS AWARDED A
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
HIS FAMILY.
AND ONLY A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
A. B.. THREE ARE YOU TO THANK
YOU SIR WE MATTER.
AND YOU MATTER WE ARE BETTER
THANK YOU SIR HAVE A GREAT DAY.
VICTOR PECADO NATIVE OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
ARMED WITH MOTHERS ON THE MARCH
AGAINST POLICE MURDERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO PASS ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
HELLO -- I'M DANIEL FROM THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND I'M
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT -- FOR THREE
NINETY TWO WE'RE WE'RE KILLING
OUR FUTURE AND THAT'S NOT COOL
THANK YOU DOES NOT DO THAT.
MY NAME IS VICTOR TAURUS BROTHER
OKAY SO SUBTLE FULLER GUY WHO
KILLED BY TENNIS I FEEL SFPD
OFFICERS SHOT AT NINETY NINE
TIMES.
HE TWENTY FIVE WILL IN THE TRUNK
OF A CAR I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
RACHEL HEARING TEN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
IRVINE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB THREE
NINETY TWO BECAUSE WE KNOW ON
AIR BY DESERVES OTHER PARENTS
AND THEIR KIDS THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
HI I'M KIM THOMAS RESIDENT
AMANDA CALIFORNIA MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER.
I MARCHED IN THE NUMBER IN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MARCHES IN THE
SIXTIES NAME I CAMP CAM THOMAS.
I AM I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
STILL HAVING TO DO THIS ALL
THESE YEARS LATER.
IN SUPPORT OF THREE NINETY TWO
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIANNA CALLING
DAIS I'M WAY Y. J. C..
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT CAESAR
CRUISE HE WAS KILLED BY AND
HIGHS.
AND HIGH.
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CAN YOU
RESERVOIR CANNOT A GYMNASTIC
WORKERS LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ARE YOU THOMAS
WITH YOU JUST COALITION ON HERE
ON THE BEHALF OF DEVON BROWN.
HE WAS KILLED BY THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT AT THIRTEEN
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MONEY AS WE GET THIS OUT OF THE
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR SOLDIERS
JUSTICE HER SUPPORT THIS BILL
BEHALF OF MARKEL THAT WAS SHOT
TWENTY FOUR TIMES BY THE MODESTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS UNARMED -- AND HE WAS
SHOT AT A TOTAL FORTY SEVEN
TIMES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME TODAY'S ALREADY ALSO
WITH COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE YOU'D JUSTICE OUT OF
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING DAPHNE DECIDING ON
BEHALF OF NATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUTH LAW STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU HELLO
MY NAME IS CHECK WITH HERNANDEZ
I'M WITH COURAGE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL MY OTHER COUSIN WAS
RECENTLY KILLED IN HIS JAIL CELL.
WHY THREE POLICE WHO OF FOCUS
THAT CAN BEAT HIM TO DEATH AND
PUT HIM UP AS HE HANGED HIMSELF?
JIM MARTINEZ FRESNO ACLU -- ALSO
FAMILY MEMBERS STEVEN VARGAS
SHOT AND KILLED -- BUT NINE
BULLETS BY AN OFF DUTY POLICE
OFFICER WITH FOR PREVIOUS
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING --
INCIDENCES -- HERE TO SUPPORT AB --
THREE NINETY TWO TRANSPARENCY
AND DE ESCALATION PLEASE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MORE TEIJIN FROM
COURAGE AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARGARET HITCHCOCK
I'M A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST I WORK WITH
YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN THE BAY
AREA -- I'M ALSO HERE WITH ANTI
POLICE TERRACE PROJECT AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OUT WHEN WILSON AND
I'M WITH COURAGE AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS BILL.
DEBORAH CUNNINGHAM AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB THREE NINETY
TWO WEBER.
HI MY NAME'S KRISTINA FLORES --
I COME WITH COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS AND I
AM STRONGLY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I'VE JUST TAKEN OVER
FOR THE CHAIR TEMPORARILY ALSO
WON'T BE -- GUIDING THE COMMENTS
THANK YOU.
I'M FRANCESCA'S STERILE I'M HERE
WITH INDIVISIBLE YOLO AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS COURSE A LOOSE BUT
ONE WITH COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
STARKEY JUSTICE IN OAKLAND.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL MY
FRIEND ALEX MANTLE WAS KILLED BY
SAM SCHOOL POLICE DEPARTMENT MY
FRIEND WHO I GOT I WAS KILLED BY
CELL SAN FRANCISCO.
POLICE DEPARTMENT ADJUSTING
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
HI.
THE CHAIR WITH CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER
APOLOGIZE.
HERE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
NINE TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LISA CLOSE THE MOVE
TO THE MICROPHONE.
I'M SORRY.
MOVE TO THE MICROPHONE SO WE CAN
START.
IT'S VERY CLOSE MY NAME IS LISA
CLOSE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL I'VE BEEN A VICTIM OF
POLICE VIOLENCE A SERIOUS BODILY
INJURY.
IN A SITUATION WHERE I WAS
SCARED OKAY IF YOU COULD.
NOT GO WE GO ON TO THE NEXT
SILENT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELA CHAN I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL OF A
AT AB THREE NINE TWO ON BEHALF
OF THE ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA THEY GIVE YOU.
MY NAME'S DAVID JACKSON -- MY
DAUGHTER WITNESSED A POLICE
SHOOTING AT THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY BLATANTLY
LIED ABOUT.
SHE'S BEEN TRAUMATIZED BY THAT
EVERY SINCE DO YOU.
GUYS YOU KNOW HAS THIS THING IF
YOU WANT TO KEEP YOUR JOBS THANK
YOU.
NEXT PATRICIA AROUND SACRAMENTO
STATE UNIVERSITY SOCIAL WORK I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF EVERYONE WHO
HAS LOST THEIR LIVES I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN ORDER TO
SAVE LIVES.
AND SO I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT MY CHILDREN THE HANDS OF
THE PEOPLE THAT SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT US.
MY NAME IS NO WELL JONES I'M
WITH PASSED TO CARE AT UC
BERKELEY A RESOURCE FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE A BLOCK
SINGLE MOTHER AND BETTER AND WAS
BRUTALIZED BY POLICE THROWN TO
THE GROUND WITH THEIR TEETH
KNOCKED OUT SO PLEASE VOTE YES
THANK YOU.
YET MANY HIGHER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE BLACK LAW STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION OF LINCOLN LAW
SCHOOL HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
TIMED IT OVERALL THIS OUTDATED
LAW WE SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KENDALL DON IMUS
IN THE UC BERKELEY WITH SUPPORT
LETTERS IN THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND I I SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE THAT IS HAS IS A
RIGHT TO LIVE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAR ABRAMS I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND WE
DROVE AN HOUR JUST TO GIVE A TEN
SECOND COMMENT BECAUSE WE WANT
THE LAW TO ENSURE OUR SAFETY AND
SAID A POLICE OFFICER THAT MAY
OR MAY NOT CARE ABOUT OUR LIVES.
THANK YOU PLEASE PASS THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A PHONY ISSUE RAY
I'M A STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ANYTHING
THAT ENDS THE POLICE MILITARY
STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BILL MONEY MAY FEEL
ON THE NEPHEW OF SHELLING TENDO
FROM THE HEBREW COACH COMMUNITY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NILE MAY FEEL THE THE
NIECE OF SHELLING TENDO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CALL GUY MADE GUILD
AND THE NEPHEW OF SHELLING TENDO
WHO SHOT IN THE BACK.
BY A POLICE OFFICER UNARMED.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TIME HERE MAY FEEL
NEPHEW ARE SELLING HIM TELL NAY
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS LIZZIE AND HOW MUCH
TEN AND MY AND I'M A FAMILY --
SHELLING TENDO AND HE WAS SHOT
THREE TIMES IN THE BACK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KIM MY LEWIS I'M A
COUSIN OF SHOWING TENDO WHO WILL
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE WE WILL FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE.
RIGHT HI MY NAME IS ALONG THE
BANKS FROM THE HEBREW CULTURE
COMMUNITY AND SAN FRANCISCO
SHELLING TYNDALE'S MOTHER.
THAT WAS SHOT AND KILLED JANUARY
THIRD MYSELF STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I SAY TO YOU WHEN
THE COP KROLL THREE TIMES DON'T
DENY THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KARIM MAYFIELD
BROTHER SELLING TENDO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SLICE ACUTE THE WICKED THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MORNING HOW MUCH IN
ON THE BECAUSE OF THE SHELLING
TYNDALL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHNNY MAY FEEL --
SUPPORT IS BILL I'M HERE BY BY
WAY OF MY UNCLE SELLING TENDO HE
WAS SHOT THREE TIMES IN A BUT
THANK THANK YOU HI AM YES YES IN
A TEACHER TO SINCE SAM SCREEN
PASSCODE ISSUE CAN CAUSE OF
SELLING TENDO AND I STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SARAH HOW CLEAR
CHANDLER ON THE FAMILY MEMBER OF
SHELLING TENDO AND I TRULY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MISS LEMOND JONES A
TEACHER WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I AM A TEACHER OF SELLING
TENDO WHO WAS SHOT IN THE BACK
THREE TIMES BY A POLICE OFFICER.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THE CAR IN A FIELD
ON THE NEPHEW.
OF STRUGGLING TO NO NOT STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KEREN MAY FEEL OF THE
HEBREW CULTURAL COMMUNITY SISTER
LOS ALLINGTON BILL AND DUE TO
THE POLICE VIOLENCE IN THE
SENSELESS KILLING OF MY BROTHER
IN LAW SHELLING TENDULKAR
DAUGHTER HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
MEET HER UNCLE MYSELF STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OKAY DO WE GET THE ENTIRE FAMILY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO THIS SITE.
HELLO -- MY NAME IS JACOB NAIL --
UC BERKELEY STUDENT AND ALSO
REPRESENTATIVE CAL'S BLACK
STUDENT UNION -- I SUPPORT AB
THREE NINETY TWO AS MY COUSIN
FRANK FRANCE ALL RAINER WAS SHOT
TWICE IN THE FACE BY OAKLAND PD
AND I FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO HAVE
POLICE OFFICERS FARLEY.
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND STAND BY MY
GENERAL'S.
MY NAME IS DARIA THE REASON DAY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
GO.
DID YOU APPOINT WHAT LOOK AT ME.
YOU YOUR NEXT.
MY NAME IS OUT UP AND I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
AND POLICE BRUTALITY AND HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS THANK YOU.
EXOR YES I'M CURSED LÏNG THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND NURSES IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU SEE IN A NEXT.
MY NAME'S EILEEN SCHNITGER I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO WHERE THERE'S
TOO MANY BLACKS IT'S AND SHOT
DEAD BY SACRAMENTO PD.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
IT'S UNNECESSARY STAYS DOWN.
MY NAME IS MEGAN SOMEONE I'M A
RETIRED NURSE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE I LIVE IN ARDEN ARCADE
AREA OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND DESPITE ONCE AFFECTS US ALL.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY SECONDS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOE A FRANCO A NUMBER
OF THE CAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE.
HAS A RIGHT TO THIS -- DESERVE
TO LIVE A LONG LIFE AND CREATE A
FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES AND TING
VETERANS [inaudible]
THE FRIENDS.
JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS TERRY MURRAY I'M FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL I AM HERE. TO
FOR THE DOING THIS AND THE
RIVERA FAMILY WHERE THEIR SON
WAS SHOT. FORTY EIGHT TIMES
THANK YOU SIXTEEN YEARS OLD.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MARTHA ALL THE GREEN AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY
SPECIFICALLY MY ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE YEAR OLD FATHER WHO TURNED
DOWNTURN ONE TWO WEEKS AGO.
I'D LIKE ALL BROWN MEN IN ALL
BLACK MEN TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE THAT LONG
WITHOUT THE THREAT OF THE POLICE
OFFICER.
OVER EXERTING THEIR POWER THANK
YOUS BYE NOW NEXT MY NAME IS ANA
COLLECTING STAN I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER WORKING IN OAKLAND WITH
YOUTH WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
AND I'M HERE ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MERCEDES ROMAN I CAME
WITH THE ACLU I COME IN SUPPORT
OF THE FAMILIES OF THE FALLEN.
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN
ORDER TO PREVENT FURTHER
UNNECESSARY DEATHS.
THANK YOU YEAH MUCH ASIDE LET
THE NURSE IN BOTH LOCAL AND SAY.
APPLE YEN AVE THAT IS NO
ENTITLES THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL MURRAY FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY.
I STAND HERE -- WITH THE THE
RIVERA FAMILY -- AND ALL THE
VICTIMS -- STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU SIR --
HI MY NAME IS ERICA JOURNEY I'M
VISITING SCHOLAR AT BERKELEY AND
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY'S
TERRIFIED BUT POLICE KILLINGS.
AND ME AS A MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY --
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
JOHNNY MANDEL REPRESENTING THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO DOCTOR WEBER FOR
BRINGING IT UP.
THANK YOU.
HAVING A RUMOR IS OUT WITH A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALEXA HORNER I'M A
LOYAL LAW SCHOOL GRADUATE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
BRUCE PALMER SACRAMENTO JEWISH
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO ADAM KEVIN ON
BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR CECIL
KANSEN PROFESSOR OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE THAT SEX STATE. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WITH THE
STATE OF NEW YORK AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
TIM CAMERA ON BEHALF OF THE
STONE WALL DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF
GREATER SACRAMENTO -- OUR CLUB
ALONG WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY RESIDENTS WITHIN
CALIFORNIANS SACRAMENTO SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
PROP CO SPONSOR URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ADRIN MOHAMMED -- WITH THE UNION
OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF
THE SACRAMENTO BLACK AND
DEMOCRATS IN SUPPORT.
IT'S GOT A NIFTY BUT WITH THE
OTHERS REPRESENTING MOTIVATING
INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP FOR PUBLIC
CONVENTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RHONDA RENFRO FROM SOLANO COUNTY
VALLEJO CITY AS A MATTER OF FACT.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I ASK THAT THIS COMMITTEE NOT.
IGNORE THE VOICE OF THE PEOPLE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DOMINIQUE NONE OF
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DENISE
FRIDAY.
ON THE MOTHER CALLED ME FRIDAY
SAY HIS NAY.
SAY IS NOW.
HE WAS ASSASSINATED BY OFFICE
TODAY NEW WHALES IN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA TWENTY SIXTEEN AND I
STRONGLY.
SUPPORT PASSED IN SUPPORT THIS
PAST HIS BILL.
SB THREE NINE TWO BECAUSE IT IS
NECESSARY FOR THEM TO STOP
KILLING OUR CHILDREN IN THE
STREET.
THANK YOU MA'AM THIS.
THEN WHAT.
DO YOU HAVE FAMILY CTF REQUIRE
[inaudible]
SO.
NO MA'AM YOU'LL BE REMOVED
[inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
IF.
IF WE CONTINUE.
I HAVE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO SPEAK.
IF YOU WANT TO HEAR THEM HOLD ON
I HAVE A MICHAEL [inaudible]
SHE IF YOU WANT TO HAVE EVERYONE
VOICES HEARD.
WE HAVE TO BE RESPECTFUL
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
MY NAME IS LISA DAVIS I LIMóN
VALLEJO CALIFORNIA WERE WILLING
TO COME HE WAS GUNNED DOWN -- BY
SIX POLICE OFFICERS I REPRESENT --
THE ANTI POLICE TERROR PROJECT
BLACK LIVES MATTER AND THE
CALIFORNIA NICE NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND SEE THIS AS A
HUGE PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THREE NINE TWO PAMELA DRAKE
MEMBER OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE
STAFFER FOR OAKLAND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER NIKKI FORTY NOT A BASS
AND THREE OTHER COUNCIL MEMBERS
WHO MADE A STATEMENT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ALSO A MEMBER.
OF THE WELLSTONE DEMOCRATIC
RENEWAL CLUB.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT ANY
LONGER.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT CALL THIS
IS COMMON SENSE BILL PASSED THE
BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
I'M JACK KERR'S WHILE FROM THE
WELLSTONE DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL
CLUB IN OAKLAND AND BERKELEY WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ANNA JOHNSON FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA TOO MANY OF THE USE
THAT I WORK WITH IN MY CAREER
HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THIS TYPE
OF VIOLENCE PLEASE PASS THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DORIS BROWN I HAVE FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN TO OUR WHITE. TWO
ARE BLACK I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
UNFAIR IT IS. TO OUR BLACK
COMMUNITY THAT POLICE THEY ARE
BIASED.
I'VE SUPPORT SB OUR AB THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS HAVE YOU HAD
THE S. R. FROM WATSONVILLE
AMERICANIZATION SKULL GOT US I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SO THAT
OUR TEETH I AM FROM YOUR
CALIFORNIA I AM A FROM A
NONPROFIT ANGULAR WHICH HAS GOT
US AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNA RIVERA.
I'M FROM KIRK CALIFORNIA AND I'M
FOURTEEN CUT US.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WHEN I WAS THERE MY NAME IS AS A
ORTEGA AND I'M FROM SAN JOSE AND
MY ORGANIZATION IS GOT US AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
BLACK AND BROWN LIVES MATTER?
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S ALONDRA JODY -- FROM
GILROY CALIFORNIA AND WITH GOT
US AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NO FOR THIS UP FROM
YOUR CALL CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS DEAL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S JUSTIN
GOVERNMENTS ARE FROM YOUR
CALIFORNIA AND SO ON THIS PLAN
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAISY GARCIA I
AM FIFTEEN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOUNG
LADY IN AND I'M ALSO HERE FOR
JUST ZERO METAL WAS FOURTEEN
YEARS OLD WHEN HE WAS KILLED BY
LAPD AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
THE MAN IN THIS MY NAME IS THE
ERA.
FROM GORY CALIFORNIA AND HI.
MY NAME IS THE LA RIVER A I CAME
FROM GREAT CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL SO VADER.
AND I'M WITH THE LA YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE TOO
MANY OF OUR YOUTH AND ADULTS WHO
ARE BLACK AND BROWN ARE GETTING
KILLED THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS AN OLD PIECE --
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER YOUTH MENTOR
ON IN A MEMBER OF STAFF ALL
CLARK AND ALL THE VOICELESS
BROUGHT PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT BE
SPOKEN ABOUT BY OUR
REPRESENTATIVES.
I WANT TO ASK YOU IF WE'VE
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY'S NOW.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA ROBINSON
AND I ASK THAT YOU GUYS START
HERE IN SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
NEED CHANGE AND WE NEED. TO MAKE
A WAY FOR PEOPLE TO SURVIVE
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE RESPONSES WHICH OF THE
CALL THIS REMAINING RIGHTS
INSTRUCTS THE PART OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MANUAL ARE SOME A RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO ON AND I'M IN SUPPORT
IS BILL I'M FORCE ALSO ASKED TO
BRING A MESSAGE FROM THE COOLEY
A SPIRITUAL LEADER.
OF THE COMING ATTRACTIONS ON
THEIR SAN DIEGO.
PASSES BUILT THE WALL OR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE HUMAN.
LIZZY BEACON WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JOCK WHO ALSO WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I'M I'M IDEA I'M WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MARISSA MAZA WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CAN WE GO FROM THE ADDRESSES
COLLEGE MORE ART BECAUSE MUCH OF
THIS BILL I'M HERE FOR JOHNSON
CUEVAS AND DEANGELO POSE WHO
WERE KILLED IN LA COUNTY.
OF ALL THE PEOPLE YOU'VE HEARD
ME TO USE FROM TODAY THAT STILL
LESS THAN ONE THIRD OF THE
PEOPLE KILLED IN LA COUNTY BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW MY NAME IS JACOB
JACKSON I'M WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION I'M HERE FOR A
CITY PAN AS WHO WAS KILLED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS -- IN ARE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I SYSTEM -- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL TO ALSO COME
FROM AREA WILL WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF DOING.
SOMETHING IN THE NATION I'M JUST
ASKING IF WE HAVE BOUNDARIES AS
USUAL THEY SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
AMOUNT OF BOUNDARIES THANK YOU.
MARK FILL PART WITH POLICY LAKE
IN THE ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
WE ARE AT YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
OPPOSITION SPEAK AGAIN QUIET.
AND THEN DOCTOR WEBER WILL CLOSE.
AND THEN WE WILL CLOSE THE RULE
BOAT SO I'M ASKING ALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A PUBLIC SAFETY TO COME
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SPEAK.
DOCTOR WEBER WILL CLOSE.
AND THEN WE WILL VOTE.
SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
LEARN READ REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY PATROLMAN
PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA PORAC.
SIVA WHICH IS IS SAMBERG INYO
COUNTY -- DEPUTY SHERIFFS AND
SAN FRANCISCO PEEL AWAY -- WE
ARE POSE BUT AS DOCTOR WEBER
KNOWS WE'VE WORKED WITH HER
OFFICE WITH THE ACLU FOR ALMOST
SIX MONTHS TRYING TO REACH SOME
AGREEMENT ON LANGUAGE WE WILL
CONTINUE. TO DO THAT AS THIS
BILL MOVES IF SHE'S WILLING WE
ARE TOO YES THANK YOU.
DAVID ROBINSON CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSE THE
BILL BUT LOOKING FOR TO WORK
WITH DR WEBER ON SOME AMENDMENTS
HOPEFULLY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHEN MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES WE MAKE THE SAME
COMMITMENT TO WORK TOWARDS AN
AGREEABLE RESOLUTION ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
PROP HIGH TERROR AT THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
MATTHEW CYBER THAT WE HAVE THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE IN THE ASSOCIATION FOR
LOS ANGELES DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
YES SIR MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GRANT WARD IN THE PRESENT AS HE
BY THE SAME INYO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S EMPLOYEE BENEFIT
ASSOCIATION -- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF A HOLISTIC APPROACH BUT
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU.
NEXT MISTER TURN MEMBERS SHAUN
RUN WITH THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS
WRITTEN TODAY.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
PHIL JONAS FROM SAM DOWN SHARE
SOME PLACE BENEFIT ASSOCIATION
AGAIN WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
DIALOGUE CONTINUING BUT WE ARE
POSTED ON ITS FRESH.
GOOD MORNING THIS CHAIR MEMBERS
RANGE SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASOCIATION ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE CHEF
CHAT BIANCO AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S -- ASSOCIATION THE
I'M SORRY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SHE WAS.
NEXT THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME'S ERIC PARRIS I'M
BROTHER TO SLAIN DEPUTY ROBERT
PARIS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
FAMILY IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
HAS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM MY NAME'S
LEADER HARPER WITH THE SALMON IN
A COUNTY SHERIFF'S EMPLOYEE
BENEFIT ASSOCIATION A RETIRED
DETECTIVE IN OPPOSITION OF THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DAVE WALLACE SOME
RETIRED POLICE OFFICER AND
BROTHER TO MURDERED STANISLAUS
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFF DENNIS
WALLACE.
WE STAND FIRMLY IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MERCEDES WALLACE
I'M A SURVIVOR SPOUSE OF A
MURDERED.
DEPUTY.
AND I'M IN TOTAL OPPOSITION OF
THIS FORM THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS KIM WALLACE.
ONLY A MEMBER OF A FALLEN
OFFICER I AM IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. TO MAKE MAN SEE RPA
MEMBER STANDING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU DON CAPCURE BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNIT OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KATE WHILE YOU WILL NOW HAVE
DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU EVER.
WHENEVER.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
YOU MAKE CLOSE.
YES MY AS MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL AS I BEGAN
ONE OF THE THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL.
AND AND THE FACT THAT ALL OF YOU
GAVE ME TIME TO MEET WITH YOU
AND TO DISCUSS THE ELEMENTS OF
THE BILL I REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO -- I
THANK THOSE WHO CAME TODAY I
MEAN AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
FROM THE AUDIENCE THAT -- PEOPLE
CAME FROM ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
MANY OF THE WORKING CLASS
INDIVIDUALS TAKING OFF FROM WORK
TO COME TO HELP YOU TO
UNDERSTAND.
THEIR PAIN AND THEIR CONCERN
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THEM FOR COMING.
IT WAS NOT EASY FOR ME TO ACCEPT
THIS BILL AS A BILL FOR ME TO
SPONSOR YOU NEED TO KNOW THAT --
IS THERE A LOT OF THINGS THAT GO
INTO THE DECISION AS TO WHETHER
NOT YOU GOING TO DO A BILL.
THAT'S BROUGHT TO YOU BY A COULD
A COALITION OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
WANT TO BRING CHANGE.
I'VE HAD MANY THOUGHTS ABOUT NOT
DOING THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS A
DIFFICULT BILL AND IT IS TAKING
ITS TOLL CLEARLY ON MY STAFF.
ON ON ME AND ON MY FAMILY.
OF WHEN YOU'RE VILIFIED AND YOU
TALKED ABOUT IN THE IN THE
MANNER IN WHICH IT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE AND IS NOT REFLECTIVE
OF WHO YOU ARE AS A PERSON.
AND SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
TRY TO BRING CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA I KNOW THAT AND IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SPONSOR THESE BILLS
AND TRY TO EXPLAIN TO OTHERS HOW
YOU FEEL.
I'M OFTEN REMINDED OF THE MOVIE
A TIME TO KILL.
WHEN AT THE VERY END THE LAWYER
GAVE ITS SCENARIO OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE YOUNG GIRL AND
HE SAID CLOSE YOUR EYES AND
IMAGINE SHE WAS WHITE?
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE WAY
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO HELP
FOLKS UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY. FOR OVER
THREE HUNDRED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS NOW AND STILL FIND
YOURSELF.
ONCE AGAIN UNFAIRLY TREATED
OFTENTIMES BECAUSE OF BIAS.
BUT CLEARLY OF DISCOVERING THAT
THE NUMBERS THAT TALK ABOUT THE
DEATH OF UNARMED AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO MALES IS
TRULY OUT OF PROPORTION. TO
THEIR POSITION IN THE SOCIETY IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBERS.
AND IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A
PASSPORT FOR CHANGE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY WE
HOPE PUT ANY OFFICER AT HARM
THAT IS NOT THE INTENT.
IS TO ONCE AGAIN ADDRESS THE
CRITICAL ISSUES WE FACE IN THIS
NATION FOR FOUR HUNDRED YEARS.
OF HOW WE TREAT OTHERS WHO DON'T
LOOK LIKE US.
AND HOW THEY FEEL SOMETIMES
BEING UNFAIRLY TREATED.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT MY
COMMUNITY DOES NOT FEEL
ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED BY LAW
FOR BLOOD WORK IN THE IN THE
READING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT WHEN THEY
CALL THE POLICE OFFICERS THEY
ARE AFRAID MUCH MORE FOOD NOT
ONLY WHAT IS OUTSIDE THAT
THEY'RE FIGHTING BUT WHAT
THEY'VE MADE EXPERIENCE ONCE A
PERSON'S ARRIVE.
I FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT MY
COMMUNITY OFTEN ON REPRESENTED
ADEQUATELY IF YOU CAN BE FROM
THE SUPPORT OF POLICE DEPARTMENT.
IN OTHER WORDS THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CALL THEIR POLICE AND
KNOW THAT WHEN THEY ARRIVED THEY
GOING TO GET GOOD SERVICE.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE TREATED
FAIRLY.
AND THAT IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
THIS BILL I HOPE STRIKES A
BALANCE CLEARLY THERE WERE THOSE
WHO WANTED THINGS FAR MORE
EXTREME.
IT IS NOT DESIGNED IN ANY WAY TO
VICTIMIZE ANYONE.
BUT IT IS DESIGNED TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE OF POLICING IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO THE WE ARRIVE AT A SITUATION
WHERE WE ARE TO PUT IN EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IS ARE TREATED WITH
RESPECT.
AND THAT WE RESPECT LIFE.
THAT WE RESPECT LIFE AND THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT.
I HAVE NEVER MET PEOPLE MORE
PAINFULLY HURT THAN THOSE WHO IN
THIS AUDIENCE.
IT IS MADE ME KEENLY AWARE OF
JUST HOW DEEP AND HOW HARD THE
PAIN IS WHEN PEOPLE DON'T
BELIEVE THIS BEEN FAIRNESS AND
JUSTICE.
NOT JUST THE LOSS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL BUT THE METHOD IN
WHICH IT THEY'VE BEEN LOST.
AND I THINK YOU CAN STILL FEEL
THE PAIN THAT'S THEIR FROM FIVE
AND SIX AND TEN AND TWELVE YEARS
OF MOTHERS AND NIECES AND
NEPHEWS AND COUSINS WHO LOST
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO DON'T BELIEVE THAT THEY GOT
THE FOR YOUR SHEER OF WHAT TOOK
PLACE?
THIS IS NOT DESIGNED TO ONCE
AGAIN TO HEAD PAMPER OUR POLICE
OFFICERS FROM DOING THEIR JOBS.
WE NEED THEM TO DO THEIR JOB.
BUT IT IS TO SET A STANDARD IN A
BAR FOR PRACTICE AND TRAINING
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY ARRIVALS AT
A CONCLUSION BUT WE WILL HAVE
FEW INDIVIDUALS HARMED AND NOT
MORE.
IT IS NOT OUR INTENT TO SPEND
OUR TIME TALKING ABOUT
PROSECUTING OFFICERS BUT HOW DO
WE PREVENT THE UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE SEE EVERY
DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
I SPEAK TO YOU AS A MEMBER OF
THIS ASSEMBLY IN MOST OF YOU
KNOW ME I DON'T DO THINGS OUT OF
MALICIOUSNESS I ON'T DO IT OUT
OF VINDICTIVENESS I NEVER HAVE.
NOT ONLY AT THIS ASSEMBLY BUT
THROUGHOUT MY ENTIRE LIFE AS AN
EDUCATOR FOR FORTY SOMEBODY IS A
SAN DIEGO STATE.
BUT I'VE STUDIED THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
AND I KNOW WHAT IT IS ABOUT AN
OPENING IN PRESENTING THIS BILL
BASICALLY OPEN SOME LOANS THAT
MOST OF US DON'T WANT TO HAVE
OPEN ANYMORE.
AND YET WE SEE THE PRODUCT OF IT
EVERY DAY WHEN WE SEE THE
UNFORTUNATE THINGS THAT HAPPEN
IN OUR STATE.
SO WE CAN NO LONGER SHOULD SIGN
UP LONGER HIDE BEHIND THE
LESSONS ALONG WHAT NO LONGER
HIDE BEHIND THE SCHEELS THAT ARE
IN FRONT OF US.
WE HAVE TO CONFRONT THE ISSUE
THAT IS THE YEAR AND THE ISSUE
WAS FAIRLY CLEAR IN CALIFORNIA.
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
MALES ARE BEING SHOT MORE THAN
ANYONE ELSE.
WHAT ON ARMED?
AND THEY'RE A LOT OF INCIDENTS
THAT GO INTO IT.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO NECESSARILY
MAKE OFFICES IN CAPABLE OF OF
DEALING WITH THE COMMUNITIES BUT
WE WANT TO ARM THEM WITH THE
RIGHT KIND OF TRAINING.
KIND OF STANDARDS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT MAKES OUR
BUT OFFICERS STRONGER AND BETTER
AND MAKES OUR COMMUNITY SAFER.
THIS BILL IS APPLIED IN OTHER
STATES HAS NOT DONE WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE THINK IT WILL DO WHICH IS
TO LIVE POLICE OFFICERS UP AND
PROSECUTE ALL OF THEM.
WHAT IT IS DONE IN SEATTLE AND
WHAT IT IS DOING IN SAN
FRANCISCO HAS MADE THOSE
COMMUNITIES SAFER?
HAVE MADE A OFFICER SAFER AND
HAVE MADE OUR COMMUNITY SAFER WE
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US.
AS WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OFFICERS WHO WANT TO WORK ON
BEHALF OF CHANGE BUT IT IS CLEAR
THE CHANGE HAS TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND AB THREE NINE TWO IS THE
FIRST STEP IN THAT CHANGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
AND THEN.
OUR THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER TOO
FOR BRINGING THIS AND BRINGING
THIS TO THIS COMMITTEE -- I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND AND AND
ASKS.
THAT THE COMMITTEE MOVE THIS
FORWARD TWO CHAIRS RECOMMENDING
AND I BUT MOST IMPORTANT -- I
THANK YOU FOR KEEPING THE
CONVERSATION GOING.
AND FOR THE OFFICERS WHO CAME TO
THE TO THE MIKE. FOR THE US
POLICE ASSOCIATIONS WHO CAME TO
THE MIKE AND SAID THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH DR WEBER.
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE I'M
GOING TO HOLD YOU TO THAT --
BECAUSE THAT'S IMPORTANT YOU'RE
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THIS IS
DOCTOR WEBER.
HAS ALLUDED.
TO AND SO WITH THAT MOVING THIS
BOARD -- I'M A VERY OPTIMISTIC
INDIVIDUAL I THINK WE'LL.
WE'RE GONNA GET HOPEFULLY GET TO
A PLACE WERE WE CAN.
END THIS TRAUMA ON BOTH SIDES
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY A
NEED A NEED A MOTION
[inaudible]
THANKS AGAIN.
WHEN AB THREE NINETY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER -- JONES --
IRAQI NOTE LACKEY NOPE
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
DEEP.
NO.
NO KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK HI QUIRK
I SAN DIEGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WICKS HI WICKS I
THAT MEASURE PASSES DOCTOR WEBER.
SO WHAT NOW
.
OKAY DOCTOR WEBER HAS ANOTHER
BILL.
THAT SHE WOULD LIKE TO GET PAST
ALSO WHICH IS NOT RELATED TO
THIS SO THOSE OF YOU.
YOU CAN QUIETLY THAT NOT ON THIS
BILL IF YOU COOK WIDELY -- ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
SEVEN AB. SEVEN OH TO LISTEN
[inaudible]
TO VICTIM COMPENSATION.
I GUESS IT'S A BREATH
[inaudible]
I GUESS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH. TO ME TO CALL.
THEY ARE.
MORE THAN THAT THAT WAS THE PLAN
OF ACTION OKAY [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
SO DR.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
YES MISS -- I HAVE MY THINKS IS
GOOD AFTERNOON BUT THANK GOD
IT'S NOT.
MORNING C. R. AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT YOU AB SEVEN
OH TWO WHICH WOULD INCREASE
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR EXONERATED
INDIVIDUALS.
IT'S NOT -- IT EXONERATES ARE
RELEASED FROM PRISON WITHOUT
ADEQUATE SUPPORT SERVICES TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES AND WE
JOINED THE COMMUNITIES.
EXONERATES EXPERIENCE A MIDDLE
HEALTH CHALLENGES OFTEN BEING
RELEASED DUE TO A DO MANY ISSUES
SUCH AS TRAUMA EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND BROKEN
RELATIONSHIPS. TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES PREVIOUS LEGISLATION HAS
PROVIDED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO EXONERATE THE MEDICARE HEALTH.
HOWEVER MENTAL HEALTH SIR
PROVIDERS WHO ACCEPT MEDICARE
ALLOWED LIMITED AND EXONERATE
STILL STRUGGLE TO RECEIVE THESE
SERVICES.
AB SEVEN OH TWO WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD TO REIMBURSE
AND EXONERATED PERSON OR PROVIDE
DIRECT PAYMENT TO THESE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS.
HEALTH SERVICES [inaudible]
YES. SEVEN YEAH SEVEN OH TWO
OKAY.
YOU'RE FINE I AM I RIGHT YOU
KNOW I'M GETTING THE BEST OKAY
SIGNALS OKAY.
MOVE THAT REALLY I THINK THAT'S
SEVEN OH TWO THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY DESIGN A RATED
NATION CALIFORNIA TOURNEY'S THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
AND ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS -- I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN
FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL --
MISTER CHAIR IS THAT CORRECT.
THE OPPOSITION HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
WITHDRAWN FROM THE BILL.
OF THOSE THE LAST THING HEARD
BUT MAYBE NOT HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN HELLO WE JUST GO WITH IT
OKAY WELL THAT IS ALL WE
ANDERSON ANTHONY WITH EXONERATED
NATION IT GOOD AND IT MAY CO
HERNANDEZ WITH CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
YES -- REAP WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY [inaudible] ONE I THANK
YOU -- GOOD MORNING FIRST AND
FOREMOST AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME.
AND GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY NOW THE
WORST REPRESENTED EXONERATED
COMMUNITY.
MY NAME IS OVER YET ANY I WAS
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE A SPACE
SEVENTY YEARS IN PRISON. FOR
BEEN FRAMED FOR MURDER ROBBERY
IN WHICH I DID NOT COMMIT --
AFTER MY RELEASE IN -- TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN ARE BEGINNING TO
BECOME ACTIVE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY SORT OF TRY TO CREATE
A SITUATION TO HELP US --
REALIZING IN UNDERSTANDING MY
SUFFERING WHEN I STILL GO
THROUGH IN REGARDS TO MY MEN
ALWAYS CONCERNED.
AND TRYING TO FIND HELP THE
APPROPRIATE HELP THE WRITING OF
THOSE WHO TO GO -- TO HAS BEEN A
DIFFICULT TASK I'VE BEEN HOME
NOW EIGHT YEARS AND I STILL HAVE
NOT.
GOT THE APPROPRIATE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE.
ARM AND AS AS DOCTOR WEBER SPOKE
AND I AM VERY THANKFUL AND
GRATEFUL -- FOR THE PASSES OF AB --
TEN FIFTY THEY GAVE THEY GAVE
WHITES IN OTHER WORDS -- TO MEDI
CAL TO MEDICATE.
OF REALIZING HOW THAT WILL
BENEFIT US -- BUT WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR THE SUPPORT OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
UNDERSTANDING -- THE LAST JOB
WAS IS SO YOU KNOW IT IT GOES
PASSAGE JUST OUR COMMUNITIES WE
REALLY FIGHT -- TO SORT OF KIND
OF REALLY GREAT OURSELF WITH OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS MOST IMPORTANTLY --
THE BOND WHICH WAS BROKEN
BETWEEN US IS THE ONE IS REALLY
TREMENDOUS DIFFICULTIES IN
REINCORPORATE NOT.
INTO SOCIETY IS AS THE SECOND
PART OF IT WELL BECAUSE WE HAVE
NOT GOT IT TOTAL GRIP OF SORT OF
SEPARATE OURSELVES FROM THAT
COMMUNITY TO THIS COMMUNITY --
AND SORT OF HOW TO THAT PROPERTY
MEDICATION -- THIS BILL WHY HERE
WHEN ONLY.
ONLY HELP US -- BUT IT WOULD
GIVE US IS ALSO SUPPORTING
GUIDANCE IN OTHER WORDS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO A FUTURE.
SECOND THE MOTION.
OKAY YES REMEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RESULT
KEEP A PREFECT NASSER HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION FROM
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS I'M ALSO BOARD
MEMBER EXONERATED NATION I DO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND JUST
ADD A COUPLE THINGS --
MISTRANSLATED.
ORGANIZATION EXONERATE NATION
CONVENED -- EXONERATE HE'S NOT
ONLY FROM CALIFORNIA FROM OTHER
STATES -- LAST YEAR TO HEAR FROM
THEM DIRECTLY AND WHAT THEIR
STRUGGLES FOR THIS WAS ONE OF
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES -- THAT
EXONERATES STRUGGLED WITH NOT
ONLY IMMEDIATELY UPON THEIR
RELEASE BUT FOR PROLONGED PERIOD --
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT DESERVES
UNIQUE -- SUPPORT -- AND PROLONG
SUPPORT FROM THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THOSE REASONS I WE ASK FOR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CAN YOU HEAR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE GOING BACK AS
FOR DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND FOR
ELLA BAKER CENTER CAN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARGOT GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JIM WYNNE BURGER ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
ALEXA WARNER I'M A LOYAL LAW
SCHOOL GRADUATE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CYNTHIA SANDERS GFW SEE MOUNT
DIABLO DISTRICT PRESIDENT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DOMINIQUE NON
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU A MONICA SANDALS WITH
ME BY SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LEISURE MERS -- NEED BONTA A
FULLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME
BY LHASA BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
CALIFORNIA LIFE FOR YOU TO
COMMUNITY JUSTICE IS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEVENTY BETTER SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY ON SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JACKIE WILSON SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BUT NO RUSH TO SEVER CISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARK FILL PART WITH POLICY LINK
IN THE ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GERMAN TANKS AND PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
APRIL VANDYKE IN STRONG SUPPORT
DINI'S PER DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TALK TO EVERY MAY CLOSE ARE WE
ASK FOR YOUR I RESPECT.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I THINK WE HAVE A
MOVED AND SECONDED DOMESTIC
PROUD AUTHOR OF OBESE -- I KNOW
FULL WELL I'M PORTANT THIS IS A
P. WERE EXONERATED -- BUT THAT
WE PROVIDE ALL THE RESOURCES OR
AND RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE AT
OUR DISPOSAL. TO MAKE SURE THEY
BROUGHT BACK.
INTO COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE.
SO DO WE HAVE NOT DONE
ADEQUATELY SO I THINK DOCTOR
WEBER FOR BRINGING THIS.
FOR A MINUTE SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
AN EIGHTY SEVEN OH TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. TO
ANSWER I LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN DEEP.
I DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
THE MEASURES ON CALL -- WE NEED
ONE MORE.
WE NEED TO GET MORE DEMOCRATS IN
HERE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
SO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU COMMITTEE
WE NEED YOU HERE.
SO I DO HAVE SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS --
OFF CALENDAR -- ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB NINE OH FOUR CHAO WAS PULLED
BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB
FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT BOND.
WAS ALSO PULL BY ALL.
AND LET ME DO THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR -- ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB THREE OH THREE
CERVANTES MENTAL HEALTH SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS TRIAL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SIX NINE ONE
MCCARTY CHILD DEATH
INVESTIGATIONS REVIEW TEAMS.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB SEVEN OH ONE
WEBER PRISONERS EXONERATION
HOUSING COSTS.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FRAZIER PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOP DEVELOPMENTAL.
DISABILITIES ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR
SALAS CRIMINAL PROFITEERING.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN
FORTY A GREAT CRIMINAL FINES
STATE SURCHARGE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
AND IS THERE IN THE OFFICE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT
INVESTIGATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB
FOURTEEN NINETY THREE CHAIN GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
PETITION.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB
FOURTEEN NINETY SIX FRAZIER
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN
OH THREE WEEKS -- CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM.
AND ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR JONES
SAWYER UNSAFE HAND GUNS AND
EXEMPTIONS.
SOME MOTION TO MOVED CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AS A SECOND. TO CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR JONES
SAWYER.
JUICER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ALSO ON CALL.
WE GET MORE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HERE -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA HAS ASKED
TO GO NEXT OUT OF ORDER.
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE SHE IS.
MEMBERS ARE TRYING TO GET SOME
OF THESE ITEMS DONE SO WE WHEN
WE RECONVENE AT ONE THIRTY WE'RE
NOT HERE TILL.
FIVE YOU'VE GOT A CALL BACK IS
YOUR OKAY.
THIS IS THE
YEAH
.
THIS IS JOHN
[inaudible]
THIS
YEAH.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE A FORD
[inaudible]
OUR YEAH [inaudible]
JOHN [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ROLL EYES [inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
GLORIA.
OUR FINAL ITEM BEFORE WE GO
[inaudible]
TO LOOK RECESS.
THIS IS YOU MAY BE YES.
THAT YOU WANT ME.
YES SIR -- OPPOSED TO PUSH
SOMETHING ELSE OKAY.
WE CAN ALL HEAR YOU KNOW
FANTASTIC EVERYTHING'S HOT THAT
WAS BRILLIANT WHAT I JUST SAID I
WANT YOU TO KNOW -- DAVID
SHERMAN I'M HERE TO PRESENT AT
FORTINO -- FIVE BASICALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS REDUCE OF
IT RECENT RECIDIVISM.
START.
THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
BY STATE HIGH HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE WHO WERE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED ASK BEARD
I BOW AND I HAVE A WITNESS HERE
ON A TYRONE BUCKLEY OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
YES SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HOUSING CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY NONPROFIT
WORKING SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO A FORTUYN AFFORDABLE
PLACE LIVE INCLUDING THOSE
EXITING STATE PRISON.
A HOUSING CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE WE KNOW
THAT THERE EXISTS A STRONG
LINKAGE BETWEEN -- HOMELESSNESS
AND INCARCERATION WE KNOW THAT --
PAROLEES WHO ARE HOMELESS OR
SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
RECEIVE A RECEIPT WITH A BAND.
THEIR HOUSE COUNTERPARTS
PROBABLY -- FORMALLY INCARCERATE
PEOPLE ARE TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND
THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FUNDING TO BE
USED FOR PERMANENT HOUSING --
FUNDS NAVIGATORS DEFINED PERMIT
HOUSING FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
REQUIRE CDC ARE TO WORK WITH OUR
HOUSING DEPARTMENT OVERSEE THE
HOUSING ASPECT.
AND IT REQUIRES AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION OF CDC OUR PROGRAMS.
FUNDING HOUSING TO ENSURE
EFFECTIVE.
WE KNOW WHAT IT TAKES IN
HOMELESSNESS RESPOND RELATIONS
AND A HOME WITHOUT A LIMIT ON
STAY IS WHAT THAT IS.
BY MAKING THESE MINOR REVISIONS
THESE PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA CAN
ACCOMPLISH TWO GOALS WITH A
FUNDING REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
AND HOMELESSNESS AND ENSURE
INDIVIDUALS EXITING STATE PRISON
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE
UPON RE ENTRY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND OUR DRIVER.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT ANY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SEEN [inaudible]
NONE -- IS MADISON BAY PLAQUE
SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU.
NEED A MOTION.
MOTION THAT WE DID THAT WE DID
THAT.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER.
AT THE AS CHAIRMAN PROVIDE
STABLE HOUSING TO THE POPULATION
REDUCES RECIDIVISM STRENGTHENS
COMMUNITIES AND PROMOTES EQUITY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF
CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB FORTINO FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER -- ACTORS -- IRAQI.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAN.
DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
QUIRK.
SANTIAGO WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURES ON CALL NEEDS ONE MORE.
BIG CHECK
[inaudible]
BUT AT THE GARCIA OKAY COUPLE
COME ON OUT
.
AB -- TWELVE EIGHTY TWO ITEM A
THIRTEEN AND AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED
I DON'T [inaudible]
TWENTY EIGHT MISTER KALRA.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE BILL.
ON THE OTHER BOTH.
THE SECOND.
IS THE CHAIR FOR HIS START WITH
A. B. SIXTEEN HUNDRED SIXTEEN
HUNDRED YEAH.
OKAY THAT IS OUT OF THE MOTIONS
ON SIXTEEN HUNDRED YES YES.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE OPTION WAS ON THIS BILL FOR
YOU TODAY THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
THREE CHANGES. TO EXISTING
PITCHES MOTION PROCEDURES TO
ENSURE GREATER ACCESS TO DUE
PROCESS AND THE RIGHT TO A
SPEEDY TRIAL FOR PERSONS CHARGED
WITH CRIMES.
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF THE PUBLIC
STATUS AS PEOPLE TO TWENTY ONE
AND ENSURE THAT EVIDENCE IS
BECAUSE I WAS ALREADY MISCONDUCT
IS BROUGHT TO LIGHT WHEN IT IS
RELEVANT TO A DEFENDANT'S CASE.
TYPICALLY IN AN EFFORT TO BRING
PITCHES MOTION TIMELINES TO A
LINE OF THE REGULAR COULD NOT
DISCOVER THE NOTICE TIMELINES.
MAYBE SIXTEEN HUNDRED A MAN
EVIDENCE CODE THE EVIDENCE FOR
DELYLAH TIME PREDICTIONS
COVERING MOTIONS TO PUT.
WITH THE NOTICE PERIOD FOR
DISCOVERY MOTIONS -- CASES.
AS A FORMER DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER OF EXPERIENCE FIRST
HAND THE CHALLENGE.
OF OF PURSUING -- TIME NOT WAIVE
JURY TRIALS USUALLY BECAUSE OF
MY CLIENT COULD NOT BE ALLOWED.
IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IT WAS
CRITICAL TO QUICKLY FILE AND
FOLLOW UP ON THE RESULTS WITH
PICTURES MOTION.
GIVEN THE EXPO THE EXPERIMENT A
TIME TO REST.
THE FORMER LEASE PURCHASE
INFORMATION AT THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS ABOUT DEFENSE
COUNSEL AND THE PROSECUTOR.
OF OFF OFTEN RENDERED THE
WITNESSES THE WITNESSES REVEALED
AS A RESULT OF THE PICTURES --
BUT UNDER THE MALLS ARE DONE
USABLE OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE LIST.
OF POTENTIAL WITNESSES.
DEEMED THE INFORMATION NOT READY --
BEFORE THE JURY TRIAL PROCESS.
THIS PLACE BOTH DEFENDANTS --
AND PROSECUTORS AS WELL AS OUR
USUAL PROCESS IN GENERAL ON FOR
A POSITION WITH THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK TRIAL.
IS BOUNCE AGAINST THAT HAVE BEEN
IS RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES AN ALIGNMENT
CORRECTION TO THE CHANGES MADE
IN SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE FROM
LAST YEAR BY ENSURING THAT
COURTS MAY NOT ISSUE A
PROTECTIVE ORDER.
THE MANY THE USE OF RECORDS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS POINT
THIS LIMITS THE ABILITY TO ISSUE
PROTECT ORDER IF THE PUBLIC
RECORDS RETAIN PROPERLY AND WITH
IN ACCORDANCE TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
LASTLY TO IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
BUT ALSO REPEAL RESTRICTIONS
EXEMPTING SUPERVISING OFFICERS
FROM THE DISCLOSURE OF RECORDS
OF THE PRIOR MISCONDUCT WHEN IT
WHEN IT IS PERTINENT TO A
DEFENDANT'S RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS.
THIS PROVISIONS ESSENTIAL TO
SHOWING A PATTERN OR PRACTICE ON
THE PART OF SUPERVISORS WHO
COVER UP OR FEEL TO REPORT
MISCONDUCT OTHER SUPPORT.
BUT ALSO OF FOR THE SAME
PROTECTIONS ALONG FOR SOME BY
SUBJECTING THE PITCHES MOTION
FOR SUPERVISING OFFICER RECORDS.
THE SAME JUDICIAL SCRUTINY
ALREADY REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
IT WILL BE LIMITED TO WHAT IS
RELEVANT TO THE CASE AS
DETERMINED BY THE JUDGE.
BY MAKING THESE MODEST CHANGES
CALIFORNIA CAN MAKE PITCHES
PROCEDURES LESS BURDENSOME AND
TIME CONSUMING BY INCREASING
FAIRNESS.
IN CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS AND
PROVIDE GREATER TRANSPARENCY.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE AND MAKE NOTE OF THE
TICKET NUMBER WITNESSES TEST AS
WELL.
BY MORNING TOTAL YOU DON'T HAVE
TO USE ALL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SUSAN
LEFT FIND THE ASSISTANT PUBLIC
DEFENDER OF NEVADA COUNTY UP
NORTH WHERE I SUPERVISE THE
MISDEMEANOR DIVISION -- I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF PUBLIC
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I'M HERE WITH KATHLEEN FROM
THE ACLU WE'VE DIVIDED UP THE
WORK AND I'M A SHORT MY COMMENTS
TO ABOUT HALF OF WHAT THEY WERE
BUT I'LL BE AVAILABLE IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE POINT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH A
BEAST THAT AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED
SEEKS TO FIX AND THAT IS THE
CURRENT PROCESS FOR FILING
PITCHES MOTIONS IT SIMPLY TAKES
TOO LONG.
IT DOESN'T EXCESSIVELY LONG
NOTICE REQUIREMENT OF SIXTEEN
DAYS WHEN NEARLY ALL THE OTHER
MOTIONS THAT AYE FILING CRIMINAL
COURT REQUIRE JUST TEN DAYS
NOTICE.
A DIFFERENCE OF SIXTIES MIGHT
NOT SOUND LIKE MUCH TO YOU BUT
TO SOMEBODY WHO'S SITTING IN
JAIL ON A MISDEMEANOR CASE.
THAT'S A CRITICAL AMOUNT OF TIME.
THAT'S BECAUSE A PERSON WHO'S
CHARGED WITH A MISDEMEANOR ALSO
HAS A STATE AND FEDERAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO A SPEEDY
TRIAL WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
SO BY REDUCING THE NOTICE PERIOD
FOR HEARINGS ON PITCHES MOTIONS
FROM SIXTEEN DAYS DOWN TO TEN
DAYS.
IT WILL MAKE IT MORE IN LINE
WITH ALL THE OTHER CRIMINAL
MOTIONS IT WAS STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS AND ALLOW MORE
MISDEMEANOR DEFENDANT TO
ACTUALLY FILE THESE MOTIONS
WITHOUT WAIVING THE RIGHT TO A
SPEEDY TRIAL.
THIS CHANGE IN THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT WILL PROVIDE THOSE
IN CUSTODY MISTER MINUTES WITH A
MUCH MORE MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE PITCHES
PROCEDURE.
AND THAT WILL RESULT IN MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS AND
WITHIN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
SO AFTER ALL -- WE ALL WANT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THE
PROPER TOOLS ARE ALREADY THERE
BUT IF THEY COME TO USE THEIR
NOT ACCESSIBLE THEY'RE NOT
HELPING PEOPLE.
SO I'LL LEAVE MY COMMENTS THERE
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
I'LL BE AVAILABLE AND AGAIN I
ROOM I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KATHLEEN GOOD
AROUND THE FROM THE ACLU OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN OUR LITIGATION
DEFENDING SB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE PRIOR TO
THAT I WAS A PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR
ABOUT A DECADE WHERE I ARGUED
WROTE MANY PITCHES MOTIONS.
I TOO WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
AT THE TWO OTHER AMENDMENTS THAT
I THINK ARE VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THAT AB.
SIXTEEN HUNDRED SEEKS TO FIX IS
BY REPEALING EVIDENCE CODE.
TEN FORTY SEVEN THIS -- THE BILL
WOULD.
ENABLE CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS TO
OBTAIN CRITICAL PRIOR MISCONDUCT
INFORMATION FOR SUPERVISORS THAT
ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE NOT MET THE
DEFENDANT DIRECTLY WERE INVOLVED
IN WRONGDOING.
AT SUCH A SIGNING OFF ON THE
SUBORDINATES FALSE ARREST.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO A FAIR
TRIAL IT'S SOMETHING THAT --
MANY OF US COULD HAVE USED IN
MISDEMEANOR JURY TRIALS THAT WE
HAVE ARGUED TO SHOW A PATTERN OF
WRONGDOING.
SUPERVISORS WHO SIGN OFF ON
OTHERS OFFICERS FALSE REPORTS
SHOULD NOT BE EXEMPT FROM HAVING
THEIR MISCONDUCT DISCLOSED.
AND THE FINAL THING AB SIXTEEN
HUNDRED DOES IS IT CLARIFIES
THAT WHEN THE INFORMATION ABOUT
POLICE MISCONDUCT IS AVAILABLE
FOR THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
THE COURT CANNOT LIMIT ITS
DISCLOSURE THROUGH A PROTECTIVE
ORDER.
THIS MAY SEEM LIKE A COMMONSENSE
SIMPLE CLARIFICATION.
BUT IT LET ME ASSURE YOU IS
SIMPLE CLARIFICATIONS ARE
WELCOMING NECESSARY IN CROWDED
CRIMINAL COURT ROOMS AND THIS
INFORMATION IN THIS BILL WILL BE
HELPFUL TO ALL STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING D. A.'S PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND JUDGES.
I REMAIN AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I TO
LITERATURE I VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN.
SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IS
THE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JOCK WHO WILL SEND SERVICES GO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALEXA WARNER LOYAL LAW SCHOOL
GRADUATE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
DOMINIQUE NON FOR THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA FOR A
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ISRAEL VIA WITH ME BONTA SALINAS
IS STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN YOU RESIDENT PRIVATIZATION
STRONG SUPPORT.
NOT SURE HERNANDEZ SOME WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BON
STRONG SUPPORT EQUAL PROTECTION
UNDER THE LAW.
TODAY'S PRAYER DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY ALSO
MISDEMEANOR SUPERVISOR AND SO I
SECOND WHAT.
MS LEFT SAD NOT BEING ABLE TO
ATTACK THE CREDIBILITY OF THE
ONLY WITNESS AGAINST YOU REALLY
DID DEPRIVE THE DEFENDANT THE
RIGHT TO A FAIR TRIAL SO PLEASE
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
APRIL VANDYKE DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BUT NO DOUBT YOU SEPARATE CISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAITLYN DEAN THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AND POLICY
LINK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AS PIONEERS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DOWN THE MIDDLE WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU GIVE ME DOES THIS
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
POSSIBLY OF JUSTICE COALITION
FOR STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEE.
NO OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- JEFF
RECOMMENDED I WHAT'S CALLED A
FIVE SECOND.
I EIGHTY SIXTEEN HUNDRED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
CHEN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOPE BAUER-KAHAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WICKS.
I MEASURES ON CALL NEEDS TO MORE.
AB [inaudible]
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO GO
THANK YOU SAMPLE TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO A LOT FASTER.
THANK YOU SIR -- THANK YOU THE
OPTION TO PRESENT THIS BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO PROHIBITS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
FROM ASSISTING OR ALLOWING
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS TO
ARREST DETAIN OR OTHERWISE TAKE
INTO CUSTODY.
INDIVIDUALS IN STATE CUSTODY FOR
IMMIGRATION PURPOSES.
I'M ABOUT EL THE FEDERAL
MINISTERS EXECUTIVE ORDER SECOND
AND MEMORANDUMS OF OUTLINED A
MASSIVE TO DETENTION AND
DEPORTATION STRATEGY.
WHICH RELY HEAVILY ON
QUESTIONABLE AN ABUSE OF TACT
TACTICS THE CONFLICT WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW AND IN
CONTRADICTION OF FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN AND CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
AS PART OF THIS STRATEGY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS SUCH NOT
ONLY LEVERAGING COMPELS STATE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENFORCE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW.
IT IS ALSO WORK TO UTILIZE
PRIVATE SECURITY COMPANIES IN
THE SEPARATE.
AS A RESULT OF THESE ACTIONS THE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HAS BEGUN TO
RELY HEAVILY ON THE USE OF
PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS TO
ENFORCE.
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW WHICH
INCLUDES THE UNLAWFUL
AUTHORIZATION OF PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS TO TAKE INTO
CUSTODY DETAIN ARREST IMMIGRANTS
WHO HAVE SECURED THE RIGHT TO
RELEASE FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISONS.
THIS IS IN DIRECT CONTRAVENTION
OF ESTABLISHED FEDERAL AND STATE
LAW AS WELL AS WELL ESTABLISHED
LEGAL PRECEDENT.
FEDERAL LAWS CLEAR UNDER THE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION NATIONALITY
ACT AND ITS IMPLEMENTING
REGULATIONS PRIVATE CONTRACTORS
ARE NOT AUTHORIZED TO ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAW.
THIS MEASURE TAKES THE IMPORTANT
STEP OF MATURING THAT CDC ARE
COMPLIES WITH FEDERAL LAW BY
PROHIBITING PRIVATE SECURITY
CONTRACTORS ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA
PRISONS. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DETAINING TAKE INTO CUSTODY OR
RESTING INDIVIDUALS FOR
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES
WITH ME OFF ALSO CAN ORGANIZE
WITH THE USE JUSTICE COALITION
AND ANGELA CHANCE SENIOR POLICY
DIRECTOR AND STOP ATTORNEY WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CO SPONSORS OF A. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
[inaudible] FIVE MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANGELA
CHANT ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR TO
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
ADVANCINGJUSTICE.
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS I'M HERE TODAY
TO PROVIDE THE TESTIMONY OF DNIA
NORM WHOSE EXPERIENCES OF
GETTING TURNED OVER TO PRIVATE
SECURITY CORPORATION BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
INSPIRED THIS BILL AB.
ONE TWO EIGHT TWO SO MY NAME IS
NEAR NOR AND I'M A YEAR YOU
COULD YOU I'M A FELLOW AT
ADVANCINGJUSTICE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS.
I ALSO INFORMALLY INCARCERATED
AYE SIR FIFTEEN HAPPY YEARS AT
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY IN CHOWCHILLA
CALIFORNIA.
I PAINT A COLLEGE DEGREE WALLS
INCARCERATED I ALSO GRADUATE FOR
ME SORT OF JUSTICE PROGRAMS AND
THE CHIEF VARIOUS LOCATIONS
CERTIFICATES IMPROVE MY JOB
SKILLS.
I WAS GRANTED PAROLE AFTER THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS ON THE
SUITABLE FOR RELEASE BUT SOON
AFTER I WAS TOLD BY PRISON
OFFICIALS THAT.
ICE IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT MAY COME AND ARREST
ME FOR WEEKS UP UNTIL MY REST I
WAS OVERWHELMED THE STRESS AND
FEAR THAT WAS GONNA BE
REARRESTED.
ALL ALL OVER AGAIN BY ICE FACE
WORST PRISON CONDITIONS IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION AND MAY
NEVER SEE FREEDOM IN AMERICA
AGAIN THE ONLY HOME I'VE KNOWN
SINCE I WAS FIVE YEARS OLD.
OR A MOTHER AND I CAME TO THE U.
S. AS CAMBODIAN REFUGEES.
ON MAY NINTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AFTER A STRESSFUL FEW
WEEKS OF WAITING I FINALLY MADE
IT IN THE POLL HOLDING TANK WITH
THREE OTHER PEERS GETTING READY
TO PAROLE BUT TO MY DEEP
DISAPPOINTMENT OFFICER IN A BLUE
UNIFORM PUT THOUGHT WASN'T ICE
OFFICER.
WHO I LATERFOUND OUT WORK FOR
PRIVATE SECURITY CORPORATION
NAMED G. FOUR S. WACKENHUT
ORDERED ME TO TURN AROUND WITH
MY BACK TO HIM PUT MY HANDS HIGH
UP AGAINST A WALL SPREAD APART
MY LEGS?
AND WITHOUT ANY WARNING YOU
PLACE HEAVY CHAINS AGAINST MY
WAYS CHANGE THE GETS MY ANKLES
AND CHAINS AROUND BOTH OF MY
WRISTS ALL I COULD DO WOULD BEND
MY HEAD DOWN AND HOLD BACK MY
TEARS.
WITH FEELINGS OF SHOCK FEAR
NUMBNESS AND DISAPPOINTMENT.
ACROSS TO ME FROM WERE MY PEERS
WERE EXCITED FOR THEIR FREEDOM
AND HAD WITNESSED MY ARREST THEY
CONNECTED WITH WITH ME CONNECTED
EYES WITH ME EYES FULL OF
SADNESSA KNOWLEDGE OF THE NOT
THAT THE UNDERSTOOD.
MY DISTRESS AND MY GRIEF ALSO
REALIZE I WAS THE ONLY DETAINEE
ARRESTED THAT MORNING WITH AN
IMMIGRATION HOLD.
AND THEN SHORTLY THEREAFTER I
WAS PLACED IN THE BACKSEAT OF AN
UNMARKED WAY THEY ON WITH ONLY
ME AND THE MALE OFFICER.
WORK FOR G. FOR US I THEN
TRANSPORTED BY TWO DIFFERENT
OFFICERS -- THEN THE FIRST MAN
FOR AN HOUR THE GERMAN ANOTHER
FOUR HOURS TO YUBA COUNTY JAIL
WHICH RENTS SPACE FOR ICE WHERE
THE PAIN FOR THE NEXT SIX MONTHS
IN IMMIGRATION CUSTODY.
WHAT ALL THAT EXPERIENCE WITH
THE LEGAL SYSTEM PRESIDENT
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM I WISH NO ONE
TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE STRESS
AND HUMILIATION OF BEING
ARRESTED? FOR DEPORTATION
PURPOSES ESPECIALLY IF PAROLE
SHOULD BE A TIME OF JOY AND
NERVOUS ENERGY WHERE ONE IS
LOOKING FOR TOWARD SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITIONAL GROWTH WHICH
INCLUDES BEING SURROUNDED BY
SUPPORT OF LOVED ONES AND THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS WHY EMERGING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO VOTE YES ON AB ONE
TWO EIGHT TO THE NO PRIVATE ICE
ACT AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
NEWMAN IS SPOKE WITH JUST
COALITION -- I TOO WAS ALSO
TAKEN BY A KEY FOR A SECURITY
CONTRACTOR SO JUST A BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON MYSELF.
I WAS SIXTEEN MY DAD PASSED AWAY
FOR LACK OF RESOURCES IN THE
COMMUNITY I WOUND UP IN THE
STREETS AND I WANT TO BE IN TRY
TO KIND OF DAHLE AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN THIS WAS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE COMMENT
THANKFULLY BECAUSE OF SB TWO
SIXTY I HAD A CHANCE TO GET OUT
LOW THE EARLY.
SO IN MY PRO DAY CAME IT WAS A
RELEASE BUT IT WASN'T LIKE
WALKING HOME REALLY SO IT'S MUCH
LIKE WHEN HE HAS SEEN.
I AFFECTED RESOLVE MY PRO PAPERS
BEING HANDED OVER TO DISCARD
CONTRACT.
AND A DISKETTE ACCOUNT CHECK AT
THE SIDE TO TAKE CUSTODY OF ME.
AND THERE IS NO WAY THAT.
A PRIVATE CONTRACTOR COULD
ARREST MINISTRY.
WE CAN'T.
YOU KNOW WHEN I WENT TO A TECH I
WAS EXPECTING AN ICE AGENTS COME
SOMEBODY HAD A UNIFORM SAID I'M
WITH IRIS I'M HERE TO ARREST YOU
BLAH BLAH BLAH HERE'S A WARRANT
FOR YOUR ARREST I DON'T SEE ANY
OF THAT IT WAS JUST A MAN COMING
IN.
BUT YOU KNOW HE WAS ARMED AND
ALL THAT COME WITH SHACKLES WITH
CHAINS TELL ME TO GET UP ON THE
WALL.
AND THAT WAS IT WAS GET SHACKLE
CAM CHAIN REALLY HEAVY REALLY
HEAVY THINGS I REALLY PARTY CITY --
WITH -- IN A FORTUNE IN THAT DAY
WAS IT JUST ME OR WAS OUT TO
OTHER PEOPLE IN A TANK WENT
THROUGH THE SAME THING SO IT'S
THREE OF US BEING PUT INTO A VAN.
INTO WHAT WAS A STRIPTEASE
ESSENTIALLY A HOLDING TANK ON
WHEELS.
MAMA BEING TRANSFERRED TO ICE
BECAUSE THE NOT KNOWING WHERE
WE'RE GOING NOT ONLY THEY CAN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THEY WERE
GOING WE CAN'T TELL YOU HOW WE
CAN HELP TO US WE CAN'T TELL YOU.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING THEY WERE
JUST WEAR HEARING ORDERS WERE
HERE IN OUR CONTRACT PICK YOU UP
WE TAKE YOU WHICH UP NOW FOR TO
TELL US TO INVESTED US ALL.
SO YOU HAVE MORE RIGHTS WHEN YOU
COME TO GET YOU.
BECAUSE YOU'RE STILL STUCK IN TO
FIND IN A PRISON ENVIRONMENT
WHEN THEY DO TO EXCHANGE TWENTY
DUE TO TRANSFER.
RIGHT THERE THERE TO EXECUTE A
CONTRACT WITH THE DEVIL MAKING
MONEY.
THEIR THEIR PROFIT OFF OF PEOPLE
PROFIT OFFER IMMIGRANTS THAT'S
THE ONLY REASON EXISTS EVERYONE
FOR US IT WOULD BE IN THAT
BUSINESS THAT BUSINESS WHEN
EXIST AT ALL -- BUT THANKFULLY.
IN AUGUST OF LAST YEAR ACTUALLY
GOT APART INTO GOVERNOR BROWN
AND THAT'S THE ONLY REASON MY
CASE I STOPPED.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON FOR ONE
FOR THAT I WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY THE SOCKS MONEY BUT AT
THAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION JERMAINE
SINCE PRESIDENT CAL FOR CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH ARE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO ABOUT MY
COLLEAGUES FROM PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ISRAEL VIA WITH ME BY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
AT THE END OF THE WATER
MOTIVATING INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP
REPUBLIC INVESTMENT STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
DOMINIQUE NOT LET ME HAVE THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA MY VIETNAMESE PEOPLE.
SABINA PRO CITY POLICY MANAGER
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR PERSONS
WITH CHILDREN.
I'M PROUD CO SPONSORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS I LIVE VEGAS IN WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN ALL OF US AND THEN
WE ARE CO SPONSORING A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HEALTH REPORTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HELPING ELSE LONG
COLLABORATIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
WORKING IN ORGANIZATION THAT
ADVOCATES FOR PREDOMINATELY
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
GABRIEL GARCIA WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER REPRESENT CAMBODIAN
LAOTIAN MOM AND BEEN MISTREATED
ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CHUCK -- WILSON SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
DEEPENING TECHNICIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CAN YOU GO WITH THE JUSTICE
COALITION WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DONNA MANDEL ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND ARE WONDERFUL
IMMIGRATION UNIT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SAMMY NUNEZ
FATHERS OF POUNDS OF SAN JOAQUIN
IN STOCK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KAELIN TEAM THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AND POLICY
LINK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MORNING MR MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
CASEIN NONE TO SHOWING -- TO HAS
BEEN MOVED INTO SECOND
[inaudible]
I'LL MOVE.
I'LL SECOND I THOUGHT.
WE DID THIS.
NOW CONCERNING THE YOU MAY CLOSE
EXPECT THE ASTEROID BUT THE
COMMISSION.
WE WE DOUBLE MOVED INTO THAT
MAKES IT EVEN BETTER.
CALL THE ROLL ON EIGHTY TO
EIGHTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS JONES
SAWYER.
I DON'T ANSWER I LACKEY
BAUER-KAHAN DEEP KAMLAGER-DOVE I
AM KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK
SANTIAGO WICKS.
MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS THREE
WILL RECONVENE.
SURE WE'LL GET THERE THANK YOU.
HOW QUICK IS MR GARCIA'S YOU
HAVE GARCIA YEAH THIS IS DO IT
OKAY?
SB SIX SIX FIVE SIX MOVE THE
BILL SECOND.
LET'S CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
SIX FIFTY SIX ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. EIGHTY
SIX BY SIX HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED
FOR COORDINATED.
AN INTERSECTIONAL STRATEGIES IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE FACTORS
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO VIOLENCE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT SO MUCH OCCURS
CURRENT POLICIES A PUBLIC
FUNDING RESPONDED BY THOSE IN A
REACTIONARY FASHION RATHER THAN
A PREVENTATIVE.
ONE CREATING AN OFFICE OF
HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES
WITH THE GOAL OF SHOWCASING THE
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR AND PUBLIC HEALTH
INEQUITIES WILL HELP TO REDUCE
INCIDENTS OF VIOLENCE IN THE
STATE.
PLEASE THIS OFFICE IN THE
PURVIEW THE SURGEON GENERAL THAT
AND BASS AND COMMUNITY BASED
PREVENTION STRATEGIES. TO SORT
OUT THAT VISION BECOMING A
REALITY.
THIS TO OFFICE WILL BE TASKED
WITH DEVELOPING IMPLEMENTING AND
MONTEREY CALIFORNIA VISION AND
PLAN FOR VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
SAFETY AND HEALING BY CONNECTING
THE VISION PLAN TO THE
GOVERNMENT STRATEGIES FOR YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT CRIMINAL AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE REFORM
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND OTHER
RELATED AREAS OF OPPORTUNITY.
IDENTIFYING IN INTEGRATING
TRAUMA CENTER DIAGNOSTIC TOOLS
JUST EARLY AND PERIODIC
SCREENING DIAGNOSTIC NOSES AND
TREATMENT TO SUPPORT VIOLENCE
PREVENTION INTERVENTION HEALING
AND CREATING AN INTERACTIVE
COMMUNITY ENGAGES STRIDES THE
PRIORITIZE THE VOICE THE PEOPLE.
DIRECTLY IMPACTED AND DOING THE
WORK TO PREVENT VIOLENCE TO
PROMOTE PEACE AND HEALING AND
COMMUNITIES ALONG SIDE THIS BILL
IS A BUDGET REQUEST FOR A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION SIX MILLION
DOLLARS SUPPORT STAFF.
CONSULTANTS IN THE INITIAL
EXPENSE ASSOCIATED WITH CARRYING
OUT THE TASK FOR SPONSORED BILL
THESE OF THE OFFICE AB SIXTY SIX
IS OUR CONTINUAL UP OF EVOLUTION.
MOVING AWAY FROM REACTING TO
VIOLENCE RIGHT COMMUNITY WITH OF
FURTHER ENFORCEMENT AND
PUNISHMENT -- AND FOCUSING MORE
ON HEALING OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WITH THAT A RESPECTED
ASPIRIN I BOWED LASKO OF OUR
WITNESSES TO TAKE OVER THIS ITEM
WAS MOVED AND SECONDED BY MS COM
LAGER [inaudible] FIVE MISQUOTE.
YEAH AND THE ITS LETTING THEM
KNOW THAT MOVIE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF -- MY NAME IS MARK FILL
PART AND I'M WITH POLICY LAKE IN
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR -- WHERE A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND ESSENTIALLY THIS
ORDER -- WITH THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER FROM THE GOVERNOR --
GOVERNOR NEW SOME -- IS THE
INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL -- THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER --
WENT ON TO ENCOURAGE THAT -- THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ESTABLISH OR
APPOINT A SURGEON GENERAL.
AND THAT THE SURGEON GENERAL
MARSHALL THE CROSS SECTOR ENERGY
AND INSIGHTS OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS.
PUBLIC SERVANTS IN IT EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS TO ADDRESS THE
HEALTH INEQUITY -- THAT SO MANY
CALIFORNIANSSPACE AND
PARTICULARLY TO GET TO THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THESE INEQUITIES --
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG HISTORY --
IN COMMUNITY OF DOING VIOLENCE
PREVENTION WORK -- DATING BACK --
TO PEACEKEEPING EFFORTS IN LOS
ANGELES -- ST INTERVENTION
EFFORTS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
CITIES LIKE RICHMOND -- IN
CITIES LIKE SAN JOSE AND SAN
FRANCISCO AND SANTA ROSA -- THIS
OFFICE IS MEANT TO FURTHER
SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS AND TO
STRENGTHEN THE COORDINATION
AROUND VIOLENCE PREVENTION TO
ENSURE THAT.
THE PREVENTION OF VIOLENCE
ADDRESSES THE FULL SPECTRUM OF
VIOLENCE IN THE NEEDS THAT
COMMUNITIES HAVE.
OF OFTENTIMES THE ISSUES THAT
ARE FACING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WHEN
IT COMES TO ISSUES OF PILOTS ARE
DRESSED IN A WAY THAT IS FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON SUPPRESSION -- AND
TOO LITTLE EFFORT GOES INTO
FOSTERING THE SOLUTIONS OP
FOSTERING IN INVESTING IN THE
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
PEOPLE TO HEAL TO ADDRESS TRAUMA
AND TO ESCAPE CYCLES OF VIOLENCE.
THIS PROPOSED OFFICE WOULD DO
THAT EVERYTHING.
I'M GOING TO YIELD THE BALANCE
OF MY TIME TO SEND THE NEW YES
FROM FATHERS AND FAMILIES OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN SO THAT WE CAN
EXPEDITE THIS MATTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE FIRST TIME I
STOOD UP TO VIOLENCE I WAS FIVE
YEARS OLD.
HOW OLD WERE YOU?
AT THAT TIME MY SO MY MOM GET
BRUTALLY BEAT.
AND I WANTED TO STOP.
AND I INTERVENE AT LEAST
ATTEMPTED TO AND I WISH SOMEBODY
WAS THERE TO HELP OUR FAMILY OUT.
BUT IT'S ALMOST THIRTEEN YEARS
OLD I WAS KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL
EXPELLED FOR FIGHTING.
AND I WAS SOMEBODY WAS THERE
[inaudible] TO INTERVENE.
BUT I WITHIN A YEAR LATER I
WASN'T INCARCERATED THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CENTER AGAIN PROVIDING.
REPRODUCING THE SAME ONE THAT
I'D WITNESSED AND I WAS SOMEBODY
WAS THERE TO INTERVENE.
BUT DEMOS EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD A
FATHER TO CHILD.
AND I SHE GOT SHOT WITH A TWELVE
GAUGE SHOTGUN AT POINT BLANK
RANGE WITHIN A MONTH OVER BIRTH.
AND AGAIN I WISH SOMEBODY WAS
THERE. TO INTERVENE.
I THINK THE BEGUN TO THEREAFTER
AND UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO SPEND
SOME TIME REFLECTING ON WHAT I
WANTED TO DO FOR THE REST OF MY
LIFE AGAIN I WISH SOMEBODY WAS
THERE. TO INTERVENE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL ACROSS THE
TRAJECTORY OF YOUNG PEOPLE'S
LIVES BECAUSE THIS IS THE SAME
STORY THAT HAPPENS TO COUNTLESS
YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE COMES A TIME
WHAT WE HAVE TO HAVE LESS
WISHBONE AND MORE BACKBONE AND
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA. TO BE THE
A STATE THAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE TO BE THE GOLDEN STATE FOR
EVERYONE.
WE WORK WITH FATHERS INCOMES A
SOMEWHAT CAN WE HAVE ONE OF
TWELVE TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS
IN THE STATE IT'S HAD A DRAMATIC
IMPACT IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
STOCKTON BE.
IN WITH THE RESULTING 40% DROP
IN VIOLENT HOMICIDES IT'S
WORKING WHEN WE ACTUALLY SHIP
THE ATTENTION FROM A PUNISHMENT
MODEL TO AN ACTUAL RESTORED OF
HEALING CENTER MODEL WITH A
COMMUNITY.
ACTUALLY IS -- IS ACTUALLY
DELIVERING THE  VICES
DISRUPTED GENERATIONS OF PAIN
AND VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND WE ASK YOU TO ACTUALLY --
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO ALSO BELIEVE
THE NATION ON THIS ISSUE RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF CRIME
SURVIVORS OUTSIDE RALLY AROUND
THESE ISSUES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE PROPER DIAGNOSIS OUT TO CURE
IT'S TIME WE PROBABLY DIAGNOSE
CALIFORNIA'S ISSUES.
AND APPLY THE PROPER TREATMENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME PROP PROP
CO SPONSORS WITH VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
FEBRUARY BUT MOTIVATING
INDIVIDUALS LEADERSHIP REPUBLIC
ADVANCEMENT AND STRONG SUPPORT.
DEANGELO MAP WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES -- COSPONSORED VERY
PROUD CO SPONSOR IN POSSIBLE.
I FIGURED I MEET IS ON THE HAVE
A LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA PRACTICAL SPONSORS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
SIR MICHAEL GASPING OF YOU
FORWARD IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SIMILAR AGAIN CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SABINA PRO CITY POLICY MANAGER
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR PERSONS
WITH CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI ANGELA CHEN POLICY DIRECTOR
ADVANCING JUSTICE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOMINIQUE NON FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO ARI FRY LIQUID GIFFORDS
LAW CENTER TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANDREW CAN PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MENDOZA WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT.
SELENA TABLE WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION ALSO
SUPPORT.
LENDING CLOUDY WILL LEGAL
SERVICES OF PRISONS WHICH
CHILDREN STRONG SUPPORT.
I LIVE FIGURES IN LEGAL SERVICES
OF PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GABRIEL GARCIA WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AS FUNDING IS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOD IS ON TO THE FATHERS OF
ELLISON LOOKING STRONG SUPPORT.
JACOB JACKSON WE YOU JUST AS
COALITION A STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN MIGUEL YOU JUST AS
CONDITIONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BY WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT.
CAME IN DEAN ALIGNS FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR AND POLICY LINK
PROUD COSPONSORED IN SUPPORT.
ALSO GIVE JUSTICE COALITION
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SHE IN ON ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CNN.
YOU MAY CLOSE I'M JUST GRATEFUL
TO SUMMER GARCIA FLEMING THE
OPTION YOU PRESENT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOOK.
THANK YOU A CHAIR STRUCK ME NINE
CALL THE ROLL.
ON EIGHTY SIX FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE JOBS. FOR
CLARIFICATION -- THE MOTION FOR
A. B. TWELVE EIGHTY TWO SHOULD
BE TO PASS TO JUDICIARY.
THANK YOU SIR.
I NINETY SIX FIFTY SIX JONES
SAWYER.
CHEN SIR I LACKEY BARRICADE HAN
DEEP COME LONGER DEATH HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
SANTIAGO WICKS.
I MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS
THREE WILL NOW RECESS UNTIL ONE
PM.
AND RECONVENE OUR REGULAR ORDER
OF BUSINESS.
IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX OUR
REGULAR ROOM THAT WE NEED AND
AGAIN WE'LL RECONVENE.
IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX AT ONE P.
M.
.
YEAH YEAH.
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY